ALAN ARCHULETA ATKINS BABY
BACKER PORCHES BRADFORD CUT BY
ADAM PORTELLI DALLY DODD DURAZO
EGGMAN GLAZER ONES ALL S. GROVE
HERZBERG WEST SO- TANTO JONES
CAN LONGER LAYERED LEYVA THE
MON MCGUIRE MELINDA'S MEN
NEWMAN NIELSEN A SHOW OF HANDS
FORTUNE TINO ROSSI RUBIO
SKINNER STERN AMBERG WHAT
HOUSEKI. WINNER WELL. MEMBERS
OF A QUORUM IS PRESENT. WITH
THE MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS
BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE. WE WILL BE
LED IN PRAYER THIS MORNING BY
SENATOR PENN AFTER WHICH PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING WE WERE WE WILL
BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG BY
SENATOR PART DO YOU KNOW. A
PRAYER. ARISE THE LIVING SPIRIT
AND HELP US EMBRACE THE DAY
AHEAD. AWAKEN OUR EYES AND EARS
FOR REVELATION. INVOKE NEW
WISDOM WHICH IS OUR DAILY BREAD.
ATTACKED IN USE THESE PROGRAMS
OF THE DON. GIVE US THE GIFT OF
COURAGE TO MAKE US BRAVE AT
HEART GIVE US THE GIFT OF TRUTH
AND ALWAYS SAY. GIVE US THE
LIGHT OF VISION ON WHICH TO
EMBARK REFRESHING NEWS THESE
PROGRAMS OF THE DON. WE ARE
STEWARDS OF CREATION GIFTED
INTO LIFE. ENTRUSTED WITH THE
CARE OF ALL THAT IS. YOUR CALL
TO THE WORK FOR JUSTICE BUT THE
PRICE OF STRIFE. IN NINETY ONE
THESE PROGRAMS OF THE DON. EACH
DAY PROVIDES A MILESTONE ON THE
WAY. SURPRISING US WITH PARADOX
AND HOPE. WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR
THE BLESSING OF ANOTHER DAY AND
BRACING ASIS PROGRAMS AT THE
TIME. A MAN. MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS IT'S MY HONOR TO DO THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE THIS
MORNING PLEASE JOIN ME AND HAVE
A CHORUS LINE OF ONE VOICES
WEEKS PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO OUR
WONDERFUL COUNTRY I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA AND TO
JUST. WHICH IS. ONE NATION
UNDER GOD INDIVISIBLE WITH
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
THE FORCE. HAPPY THURSDAY
MEMBERS JUST A REMINDER
PURSUANT TO THE SENATE RULE
THIRTY FIVE IN SENATE RULE
FIFTY SIX DEBATE DEBATE MAY BE
LIMITED TO A TOTAL OF FIVE
MINUTES FOR THE AUTHOR FOR
MANAGER WHICH INCLUDES OPENING
CLOSING STATEMENTS AND THREE
MINUTES TOTAL FOR SENATORS TO
CHOOSE TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
DEBATE JUST A REMINDER MESSAGES
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED
READ REPORTS OF COMMITTEE WILL
BE DEEMED RED. MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES DOES
ANYBODY HAVE EIGHT MOTION
RESOLUTION OR A NOTICE. SINGMAN
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK WE'RE
GOING TO DO TODAY SO WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH AN INFINITE
FINISHED BUSINESS. SO ARE YOU I
WANT TO ASK YOU TO BE PREPARED
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP ITEM
NUMBER FOUR. SEVEN EIGHT. AND
NINE SO WE WILL START WITH.
UNFINISHED BUSINESS ITEM NUMBER
FOUR SENATOR ALAN. HE IS
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL EIGHTY THREE
BY SENATOR ALAN AN ACT RELATING
TO COASTAL YOU RESOURCES
SENATOR ALAN THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
ALL RIGHT. AND YEAH. WELL OUR-
THE V. THE NEWSIES WOULD TELL
US. THAT- SEA LEVEL RISE
THREATENS TO ERODE CLIFFS AND
FLED HOMES ALONG THE ENTIRETY
CALIFORNIA'S COAST FROM SAN
DIEGO TO HUMBOLDT COUNTY'S R.
LA- ESTIMATES AROUND EIGHT TO
TEN BILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
EXISTING PROPERTY IN OUR STATE
IS LIKELY TO BE UNDER WATER BY
TWENTY FIFTY. HI THIS IS A BILL
THAT CREATES A FINANCING
MECHANISM IT'S ENTIRELY
VOLUNTARY WILL HELP CITIES THAT
ARE CURRENTLY FACED WITH
INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT POLITICAL.
CHALLENGES AS THEY GET ALL THIS
PRESSURE FROM THE LOCAL
RESIDENTS. TO BUILD SEA WALLS
AND DO OTHER TYPES OF
MITIGATION IT WILL GIVE THEM
INTO A FINANCING MECHANISM TO
HELP. TO ADDRESS THIS THIS THIS
THIS PROBLEM IT IS INCREASINGLY
BECOMING BOTH A POLITICAL AND
FINANCIAL PROBLEM FOR CITIES-
SO. HIGH IT CREATES A REVOLVING
LOAN FUND FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO BUY PROPERTIES WILL BE
THREATENED IN A DECADE OR TWO
ALLOWING THE OWNERS TO SELL
WELL THE HOUSE STILL HAS VALUE
AND YOU CAN RENT OUT THE
PROPERTY. MAKE BACK THE MONEY.
AND SO THE GOAL OF THIS BILL IS
FOR IT TO ACTUALLY BE A REVENUE
NEUTRAL THE BILL AS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE. IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NINE- IT'S BEST
IF ICAN ADVISE THE FLOOR WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO IS RECALL
THROUGH THE ROLL CALL ONCE
WE'RE GOING TO BE PLACING
EVERYTHING ON CALL AND SO IF
YOU MISS A VOTE WILL BE ABLE TO
PICK YOU UP WHEN- WE HAVE
EVERYONE HERE SO MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA. HI ATKINS
EIGHT YEAH BACKER. I PORCHES HI
BRADFORD HI HAVE A HYPERTENSIVE
HI DOLLY NO GOD. I TORONTO. I A
COMMON LASER I. HIGH GROWTH.
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. I HER TADO.
JONES CAN LONGER I LAYERED I
LABOR I THE MON I WIRE. I
MELINDA'S NO MAN. HI NEWMAN I
NELSON. I WOULD SHOW UP BOTH.
PAM I WORKED IN CHINO. I
BROUGHT FIVE RUBIO I SKINNER I
STERN AMBERG I LIKE OUR SKI I
WINNER. I WILL HI MEMBERS
AMANDA AND MEND WHAT I SAID
BEFORE- WE HAVE EVERYBODY ON
THE FLOOR NOW SO WE'RE GOING TO
GO THROUGH THE ROLL CALL ONE
MORE TIME IF WE YOU MISSED IT
NOW'S YOUR TIME PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. AT KINS BATES.
EGGMAN GROVE. HER TADO. JONES I.
THAT SHOW BOTH I. STERN. I
THIRTY TWO NOSE TO THE MAT THE
AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED. MOVING
ON TO ITEM NUMBER SEVEN.
SENATOR THE MOON IS PREPARED
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FORTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR LYNN MOUNT AN ACT
RELATING TO MEDICAL CENTERS
AMONG THE FORGERS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT SP FORTY IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS
CREATE AN INNOVATIVE PROGRAM TO
GIVE MEDIC HELP PROVIDERS
TRAINING VALIDATED ASSESSMENT
TOOLS AND PAYMENT CENTERS FOR
CONDUCTING COGNITIVE HEALTH
ASSESSMENTS IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE
THE STATEWIDE GOAL OF IMPROVED
ALZHEIMER'S DETECTION AND
DIAGNOSIS. I WANT TO ESPECIALLY
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SACRAMENTO WHO HELPED SHAPE
THIS BILL- IT IN A VERY GOOD
DIRECTION THE BILL IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP TO ENSURE
INDIVIDUALS RECEIVE A TIMELY
AND ACCURATE DIAGNOSIS WELL
GIVING PHYSICIANS THE TOOLS TO
EFFECTIVELY ASESS A PATIENT'S
CHANCES OF HAVING ALZHEIMER'S I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR WHEN I.
WAS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CENTER
PENN. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- I TOO WANT TO RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB FORTY
EIGHT AND- I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE VERY HARD WORK- THAT WAS
DONE BY THE AUTHOR OF THIS
BILL- AND I THINK THAT THIS
BILLS. WITH BECAUSE OF HER HARD
WORK AND- AND ALSO WANT TO
RECOGNIZE AND APPRECIATE THE
WORK THAT THE ADMINISTRATION AS
WELL. IN PARTNERING TO REALLY
BE SURE THAT WE WERE GOING TO
WE WERE REALLY GOING TO PLAN
THEIR IMPLEMENTED REGIMENTS TO
TRULY. SCREEN PEOPLE- FOR
ALZHEIMER'S HERE JUST A
CALIFORNIA AND SO I STRONGLY.
URGE AND I VOTE ON THIS BILL
THANK YOU. FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. FEDERAL MONEY MAY
CONCLUDE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN ISLAND. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA I. ATKINS BAIT.
BACKER I PORCHES. BRADFORD I
HAVE A- HI PROTESTING I DALLY
NO DOG I TORONTO I EGGMAN
GLAZER AIKENS ALL AS I GROW.
HERTZBERG HI WHERE SO. I HER
TADO I JONES NO CAN LONGER. I
LAYERED I LLEVA I THE MOON I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S NO MAN I
NEWMAN I NELSON NO A SHOW OF
BOTH HI PAM I FORTINO I ROSS I
REVIEW. I SKINNER. I STERN
AMBERG I LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER.
I WILL. PLEASE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS. EIGHT
PORCHES. EIGHT MEN GROVE. I
STERN WELL. FIVE THIRTY KNOWS
FOR THE AMENDMENTS ARE.
CONCURRED IN. FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT. SENATOR HERTZBERG IS
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL SIX FORTY SIX
BY SENATOR HERTZBERG AN ACT
RELATING TO EMPLOYMENT CENTER
HERTZBERG THE FLOOR'S YOURS.
THINK ABOUT PRESIDENT THE
JANITORIAL SERVICES IN THE
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA IS
CURRENTLY DRIVEN BY. INTENSE
COMPETITION BY CONTRACTS BY
JANITORIAL SERVICE FIRMS IN THE
PREVALENCE OF MULTIPLE CHAINS
OF LOW ROAD SUBCONTRACTING LOW
LABOR COSTS ARE THE PRIMARY
GROUNDS IN WHICH LOW ROAD
JANITORIAL CONTRACTORS COMPETE
FOR BUSINESS NOT INNOVATION. OR
PRODUCTIVITY. THESE LOW ROAD
EMPLOYERS TYPICALLY PROVIDE
LOWER WAGES AND FAIR WORKING
CONDITIONS AND TOO OFTEN
ENGAGING GREGIS WAGE AND
EMPLOYMENT VIOLATIONS FOR
JANITORIAL WORKERS. THIS
MEASURE BEFORE THIS BODY TODAY
SEEKS TO LEVEL THE PLAYING
FIELD FOR RESPONSIBLE
CONTRACTORS AND THEIR WORKERS
BY EXEMPTING JANITORIAL
COMPLETES FROM PAGA IF THE
EMPLOYEE WORK IS CONVERTED. BY
VALID IS COVERED EXCUSE ME BY A
VALID COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT- THIS TRANSFORMS THE
INDUSTRY ELIMINATES
EXPLOITATION ABUSE IT'S
SUPPORTED BY FREDDIE MERCURY
THE SINGER ON BOHEMIAN RHAPSODY
AMONG OTHERS. I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE. FOR
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. CENTER GROVE. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RESPECTFULLY I AM DEEPLY
RESPECT THE AUTHOR BUT
RESPECTFULLY RISE IN OPPOSITION
OF THIS BILL. YOU MIGHT WONDER
WHY BECAUSE WE ALL KNOW THAT
FOR THE LAST FEW YEARS I'VE
JUST RAILED ON THE ABUSES OF
PAGA. AND HOW TRIAL LAWYERS
HAVE TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF A LOT
OF EMPLOYERS IN THE STATE
BECAUSE PAGA. HAS TWO FORMS OF
PENALTY HAVE A LIABILITY PHASE
AND A PENALTY PHASE. AND SO IF
YOU'RE AN EMPLOYER AND YOU
HAPPEN TO BANK AT WELLS FARGO
IN YOU DON'T PUT THE PHYSICAL
ADDRESS OF THE WELLS FARGO BANK
THAT SHE BANK AT. THERE'S NO.
YOU GO TO THE PENALTY PHASE
WHICH IS NON WAIVER OF ALL THE
JUDGE CAN'T PICK A SIDE IT'S AN
AUTOMATIC TUNER FIFTY DOLLAR
PENALTY PER PAY PERIOD PER
EMPLOYEE. IF YOU HAVE A PERIOD
A COMMA DASH OR SOMETHING ON
YOUR PAYCHECK STUB. IT CREATES
HAVOC- BECAUSE IF YOU ARE. I
DON'T KNOW ABC COMPANY AND ON
THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S FILING
YOUR A. PERIOD BE PERIOD C.
PERIOD COMPANY. THAT AGAIN
CREATES ANOTHER VIOLATION. BUT
THIS. MEMBERS WE FIND IT IS
INTERESTING TO ME THAT YOU GUYS
ARE CONSIDERING YOU MOST LIKELY
WILL PASS A PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT EXEMPTS
JANITORIAL COMPANIES- THAT MY
COLLEAGUE- THE AUTHOR SAYS-
FOLLOWS THE LAW. AFTER DOING
SOME INVESTIGATION ON THIS
UNTIL I FOUND OUT THAT THE
ACTUAL COMPANIES SOMETIMES
LANGUAGE BECAUSE OF THE BILLING
YOU CAN IDENTIFY IF YOU DIG
INTO IT LIKE A FEW YEARS AGO
THERE WAS A BILL THAT EXCLUDED-
CERTAIN COMPANIES FROM HAVING
TO COMPLY WITH SOMETHING AS
LONG AS THEY MERGED WITH
ANOTHER COMPANY AND HAD SO MANY
EMPLOYEES WITHIN. A STATE OR
NATIONALLY AND THAT SHE JUST
HAD A BIG FLASHING RED LIGHT ON
IT THE CITY AT AND T. THIS BILL
SHOULD HAVE A BIG FLASHING RED
LIGHT ON IT THAT SAYS ABM. ABM
IS A CONTRACTOR THAT WORKS FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT
HAS THE LARGEST STATE
CONTRACTING FOR JANITORIAL
SERVICES THEY DO OTHER CONTACTS
CONTRACTS THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
FIND WORK ALL OVER. THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA INCLUDING
CLEANING- MOSTLY JANITORIAL
CLEANING SERVICES THEY'RE
REPRESENTED BY THE S. YEAH YOU
I FEEL LIKE THE S. YEAH HE WAS
MOVING IN A BETTER PLACE FOR
THE NEW PRESIDENT MAY BE ABLE
TO REPRESENT THESE EMPLOYEES.
BUT I'M DOING SOME MORE DIGGING
ON THIS PARTICULAR BILL AND THE
CONTRACTORS THAT IT WILL
PROTECT. LED ME TO THIS AND I'M
NOT SURE. I MEAN I LIMITED I
REALLY DIDN'T WANT TO BRING A
DOLLY FULL OF BOXES INTO THE
FLOOR HAS AN EXAMPLE SO ALL
THEY DID WAS PRINT THE
SUMMARIES. OF THE- CERTAIN
ITEMS. SO THIS BILL WILL
PROTECT A CONTRACTOR THAT HAS
EIGHTY NINE. EIGHTY NINE THIS
BILL IF IT PASSES WILL PROTECT
THE CONTRACTOR THAT HAS EIGHTY
NINE PAGA CASES FILED AGAINST
IT. EIGHTY NINE CASES WHERE
EMPLOYEES FEEL UNJUSTLY TREATED
WAGING OUR FAILURE PARTICIPATE
MEAL AND REST PERIODS REIMBURSE
PERIODS FAILURE TO PROVIDE
PRIVACY FOR JANITORIAL WOMENTO
LACTATE IN PRIVATE. THINK ABOUT
THAT ONE FOR A SECOND LET THAT
ONE SETTLEMENT FAILURE TO
PROVIDE AGAIN MILLIN REST
PERIODS NO REIMBURSEMENT FOR
EXPENSES MINIMUM WAGE NOT PAID
REST MILL PRES VIOLATES
OVERTIME RULES MY PAYSTUB
MINIMUM WAGE IN A WORKER WAGE
STATEMENTS WILL MEAL AND REST
PERIODS AGAIN. I'M NOT ABLE TO
TAKE A REST PERIOD DURING THE
NIGHT NO RELIEF SUPERVISOR
HARASSMENT PAYSTUB MINIMUM WAGE
MILITARISTS PERIODS WAGING
OVERTIME FAILURE TO SECURE
EMPLOYEE FINANCIAL INFORMATION
AND PROTECTED PRIVACY A
PREGNANCY RETALIATION RE HOUSE
HARASSMENT NEIL PERRY'S
RESTAURANT I'M NOT GOING TO
READ ALL EIGHTY NINETY YOU. AT
PAPA WAS PUT IN PLACE TO
PREVENT EMPLOYERS LIKE THIS
FROM TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
EMPLOYEES. PAGA IS A PROBLEM
THERE ARE GOOD EMPLOYERS OUT
THERE THAT JUST MISSED US
ISSUES ON THEIR PAYCHECK STUBS
AND THEY GET CAUGHT UP IN THIS
FRIVOLOUS LITIGATION BY THESE
TRIAL ATTORNEYS. BUT PASSING A
BE A PIECE OF LEGISLATION AND
THE VOTING I ON A BILL THAT
PROTECTS A COMPANY THAT HAS
EIGHTY NINE PAGA CASES FILED
AGAINST IT. FOR A GRIEVOUS
VIOLATIONS IS NUMBER ONE.
HYPOCRITICAL BECAUSE- WHAT YOU
DO IS YOU PASS LAWS ABOUT
PROTECTING JANITORIAL GROUPS
AND- YOU KNOW PROTECTING WOMEN
ON THE SHIPS. FROM SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND YOU'RE NOW
TAKING AWAY OF A WAY FOR THEM
TO HAVE A MECHANISM AGAINST A
BAD EMPLOYER- FLOOR. NUMBER
TWO. A PARTY IS A REAL PROBLEM
AND MAYBE ALL THESE CLAIMS ARE
FALSE I HAVE NO IDEA DOESN'T
SOUND LIKE IT WHEN YOU READ THE
DOCUMENTS IN THE WITNESS
STATEMENTS. AGAIN I DIDN'T
BRING THOSE IN HERE. OR NUMBER
THREE. WE JUST DON'T CARE ABOUT
THESE EMPLOYEES THAT NEED THIS
MECHANISM TO BE ABLE TO- FILE A
CLAIM AGAINST THEIR EMPLOYER
AND HAVE SOME TYPE OF THE
GREEDY SYSTEM OUTSIDE A UNION
CONTRACT THAT BINDS THEM TO
ARBITRATION. WITH NO REMEDY AND
SO OUT OF RESPECT FOR JANITORS
ACROSS THE STATE I ASKED FOR A
NO VOTE. SENATOR DOLLY. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS. I
ALSO RISE IN OPPOSITION BAND I
WANT TO SHARE THAT. IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WE HAD. A. B.
SIXTEEN FIFTY FOUR WHICH WAS A
RUBIO BILL THEY DID THE EXACT
SAME THING THAT THIS BILLS ARE
PRETTY CLOSE TO WHAT THIS BILL
IS DOING. AND I WAS ONE OF THE
ONLY REPUBLICANS THAT VOTED FOR.
BECAUSE I THINK THAT PARKER HAS
A HUGE AMOUNT OF. W. CIS. MANY
COMPANIES THAT ARE TRYING TO DO
THE RIGHT THING GET. FINED AND
SUED BECAUSE OF PARKING
VIOLATIONS. AND NOW WE'RE DOING
ONE OFFS THIS IS THIS IS
EXACTLY WHAT THE SENATOR FROM
BAKERSFIELD SAID THIS IS
EXEMPTING. UNIONIZED COMPANIES
WHO ARE BAD ACTORS IF YOU VOTE
FOR THIS BILL YOU'RE EXEMPTING.
COMPANIES THAT ARE BAD ACTORS.
YOU KNOW. WE HEAR ABOUT WE
HEARD YESTERDAY FROM. FROM THE
SENATOR FROM SANTA MONICA THAT
WE DON'T LIKE TO BE WE DON'T
LIKE TO BE PARTISAN WE DON'T
TALK ABOUT HOW. SUPPOSEDLY
REPUBLICANS HELP BUSINESS OUT.
THIS BILL RIGHT HERE IS EXACTLY
WHAT THE SENATOR WAS TALKING
ABOUT IF YOU VOTE FOR THIS BILL
YOU'RE HELPING EXEMPT A COMPANY
THAT HAS BEEN BAD. HOW'S THAT
GOING TO HELP THE WORKER. SO I
STAND WITH THE CENTER FROM
BAKERSFIELD I ACTUALLY VOTED
FOR THESE EXEMPTIONS BECAUSE I
THINK WE NEED TO FIX PAGA. NOT
ALLOW IT TO BE A TOOL. TO BE
MANIPULATED BY THIS LEGISLATOR
SO THAT COMPANIES GOOD OR BAD
CAN GET INTO A WAIVER THAT'S
WRONG. WHAT ARE WE GONNA DO THE
RIGHT THING THE RIGHT THING IS
A DRESS. THE PAGA.
INCONSISTENCIES THIS BILL WILL
NOT HELP THIS THIS BILLS GET IS
THE MOTHER MAY I. SYSTEM RUNNER
IF YOU GOT THE- LEGISLATURE'S
RIGHT TO GET INTO IT EXEMPTION
YOU GET ONE. IF YOU DON'T WE'RE
GOING TO PENALIZE YOU. THAT'S
WRONG BUT NO DO THE RIGHT THING.
CENTERED ON. YEAH I'VE GOT A
PRESIDENT I TAKE A DIFFERENT
VIEW OF THIS I DON'T DISAGREE
THAT THERE ARE ABUSES WITH PAPA
I TRY TO POP THE REFORM BILL
THIS YEAR I COULD NOT GET TO
FIRST BASE. AND I WASN'T
TALKING ABOUT ANY BIG THING I
WAS TALKING ABOUT A PAYSTUB
VIOLATIONS. SO LOOK IT. IN THIS
HOUSE IN THE OTHER HOUSE WE'RE
NOT GOING TO GET WIDESPREAD.
BREAKS FROM POP POP WE'VE GOT
TO DO IT INCREMENTALLY. YOU
OUGHT TO JUST SAY THAT. TO SAY
THAT WORDS WERE- IF WE VOTE FOR
THIS. THAT WE ARE- YOU KNOW IT
JUST AUTOMATICALLY HELPING BAD
ACTORS I THINK MISSES THE POINT
I'M GONNA VOTE FOR THIS BILL
TODAY BECAUSE I WANT TO START
DOING SOME MORE INCREMENTAL
WHAT OFF THINGS THAT HELP OUR
EMPLOYERS WHO ARE GETTING
BEATEN UP EVERY SINGLE DAY BYE
PADA ADD SOME CASES. THEY'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT IN THOSE
EMPLOYERS NED TO BE BEATEN UP
BUT IN MANY CASES PARTICULARLY
IN MY DISTRICT WHERE PEOPLE
COME TO ME IT'S JUST ABSOLUTELY
UNBELIEVABLE EXPECT WE ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE. SINGMAN
SENATOR HERTZBERG YOU MAKE
INCLUDE. THANK YOU MEMBERS AND-
I APPRECIATE THE ROBUST NATURE
OF THIS DEBATE AND I'M REMINDED-
BY MY DAD USED TO ALWAYS COLD
FLATTEN. IT BASICALLY SAYING
WHEN THE REASON FOR THE RULE
SEIZES THE ROLE CEASES. IN
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE SENATOR
DONE PAST. BOB HARGA. IN THE
UNDERLYING FRAMEWORK BRIEFLY OF
EMPLOYMENT LAW IS WHEN SOMEONE
DOESN'T HAVE THE PROTECTION H.
TWO OF A LARGER GROUP THERE'S A
DESPERATE BARGAINING POWER AND
SO WHETHER THOSE CLAIMS WERE
MADE BY ONE COMPANY OR ANOTHER
COMPANY CERTAINLY DOES EXIST
BUT THE SOLUTION HERE IS TO
BALANCE OUT THE DISPARATE
BARGAINING POWER SO THAT THERE
CAN BE A CONTRACT WITH RESPECT
TO THOSE POINTS THAT WERE
RAISED BY THE CENTER OF
BAKERSFIELD THAT WILL IN FACT
PROTECT THE WORKERS AND THAT IN
FACT SINCE YOU DON'T HAVE THE
COLLECTIVE TO SUPPORT THIS
IMBALANCE OF POWER. THAT'S WHY
YOU NEED PAGA AND WHEN YOU HAVE
THE COLLECTIVE PARTICULARLY
INDUSTRY THE BERKELEY TALKS
ABOUT HIS REPORT THE RACE TO
THE BOTTOM YOU HAVE A
PARTICULAR UNIQUE GROUP OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT NEED THAT
LEVEL OF PROTECTION AND SO THIS
IS A- BARGAIN IF YOU WILL THIS
IS SOMETHING. THAT IS AS- THE
CENTER FROM NAPA INDICATED OKAY
INCREMENTALISM BUT IT'S A BIG
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION AND
IT IS INFORMED BY THE
UNDERLYING ARCHITECTURE OF THE
DISPUTE OUR BETWEEN THE
INDIVIDUAL AND THE GROUP. AND
SO I THINK IT IS THOUGHTFUL I
THINK THAT IS CERTAINLY THERE
WILL BE A BUNCH OF COMPANIES
THAT WILL MAKE THE
DETERMINATION TO AVOID
PROGRESS. WITHIN ORGANIZED ON
THE OTHER HAND AND THAT'S A
GOOD THING AND SO WITH THAT
MEMBERS. I'D ASK YOU TO VOTE ON
THIS MEASURE THANK. ADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ARCHULETA I. ACTIONS BASED
NO BACKER HI FORGES NO BRADFORD
I COME BY OTHER HIGH COURTS HAS
HE HI DOLLY NO DOG. FIVE
TORONTO HI A COMMON GLAZER.
GONZALEZ I GROW NO HERTZBERG I
WISH SO HI BRITTONUM I JONES NO
KAMMERER. I LAYERED I LLEVA HI
THE MON I REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S
NO MAN. I NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO A
TROUBLE NO PAN HI FOURTEEN TINA
I ROCK FIVE REVERE FIVE SKINNER.
I STERN AMBERG I LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER I WILL. NOW PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN AT
KINS EGGMAN GLAZER. STERN. FIVE
TWENTY SIX NO NINE THE
AMENDMENT- CONCURRED IN. MOVING
ON TO ITEM NUMBER NINE SENATOR
AMBER GETS READY MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL THIRTY FIVE BY SENATOR
UMBERG AN ACT RELATING TO
ELECTIONS SENATOR UMBERG THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT POLITICS OF THE
RITUAL IS B. THIRTY FIVE. WAS
INTENDED TO CLEAN UP SOME OF
THE GLITCHES IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ELECTION- WHAT THIS DOES
THE AMENDMENTS IN THE ASSEMBLY
SIMPLY ALIGN THE- REQUIREMENTS
TO SUBMIT TAX RETURNS FOR
GUBERNATORIAL CANDIDATES WITH
OTHER DEADLINES AND TIMELINES
AND PROVIDE A CURE. IF IT'S NOT
A DREAM TO BE ADEQUATE ORIGINAL
VOTE. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SENATOR
BATES. QUESTION FOR THE DOCTOR
SENIOR MEMBER GROUP WILL YOU
TAKE A QUESTION THANK YOU
SATURDAYS SO. I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT A PROVISION IN THE HARBOR
THAT SAYS THAT THE- THE
REDACTED TAX RETURNS ARE LEFT
TO THE SECRETARY OF STATE TO
DETERMINE IF THEY NEED
SATISFACTION AND I AM NOT AWARE
THAT THERE'S ANY STANDARD THAT
HAS BEEN PRODUCED SINCE THERE
WAS A DEBATE OVER THE US
EARLIER THIS YEAR IN ANOTHER
ELECTION. IF THERE IN FACT A
STANDARD THAT IS GIVEN TO THE
SECRETARY OF STATE- CREATED
ALTHOUGH THAT IS NOT ARBITRARY
ON EACH AND EVERY I'LL RETURN.
THERE IS NOT A STANDARD THAT'S
BEEN CODIFIED IN THE LAW- THE
LAW WOULD APPLY A
REASONABLENESS STANDARD SO FOR
EXAMPLE IF SOMEONE REJECTS
THEIR SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER
THAT WOULD BE PERFECTLY
APPROPRIATE. THE SUMMER THE DAX
THERE YOU KNOW INCOME THAT
WOULD NOT BE APPROPRIATE AND SO
IT IS LEFT TO THE SECTOR'S
STATE AND SHOULD THE SECTORS
STATE BE ARBITRARY AND
CAPRICIOUS. THEN OF COURSE THEN
ONE HAS RECOURSE TO THE COURTS.
ON MY OWN TIME THEN- MEMBERS
WE'VE HAD SOME PRETTY SPIRITED
DEBATES IN HERE ABOUT ELECTION
INTEGRITY. AND WHEN WE LEAVE
THINGS TO SOMEONE INDIVIDUALS
DISCRETION- AND IT IS A
PARTISAN. POSITION WHICH I
BELIEVE SHOULD BE CHANGED THAT
RAISES THE IRE OF THOSE WHO DO
NOT AGREE OR BELIEVE THAT IT
WAS SO ARBITRARY AND IT HAD A
POLITICAL AGENDA OR MOTIVATION.
SO I WOULD RECOMMEND ON. OUR
BILLS LIKE THIS THAT WE TAKE A
REALLY CLOSE LOOK. AT THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE MAKING THE
LAWS THAT WE ARE. MAKE SURE
THAT THERE IS NOT AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THAT PARTICULAR
INDIVIDUAL WHO WILL NOT HAVE
THAT OFFICER EVER. HAVE SOME
STANDARDS BY WHICH THEY OPERATE
IN IS NOT LEFT TO THEIR
DISCRETION BECAUSE WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT IMPLICIT BIAS THOSE ARE
THE THINGS THAT UNFORTUNATELY
HAVE INVADED OUR ELECTION
SYSTEM AND THE INTEGRITY. AND
THE TRUST OF THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA HAVE AN R. LECTION
SYSTEM SO WITH THAT I DO NOT
INTEND TO SUPPORT THIS BECAUSE
OF THAT. BUT I DO APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR'S ATTEMPTS TO CLEAN
UP SOME OF THE PROBLEMS THAT WE
HAVE HAD THAT MORE NEEDS TO BE
DONE. THANK YOU. IS THERE ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SINGMAN CENTER AMBER YOU MAY
CONCLUDE FIVE THANK YOU MATTER
PRESENT WITHOUT GETTING TOO FAR
INTO THE WOODS WANT TO RESPOND
THAT IN MANY AREAS THE LAW
PROVIDES THE REASONABLENESS
STANDARD- THAT IS APPLIED IN
IMPLIED HERE AND AGAIN SHOULD
THE SECRETARY OF STATE- BE
UNREASONABLE. IN THEIR-
REJECTION OF A TAX RETURN
BECAUSE OF EXCESSIVE REDACTIONS
AGAIN THE THAT PERSON HAS-
ACCESS AND RECOURSE TO THE
COURTS VIRGIN I VOTE. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ARCHULETA FIVE ADKINS BASE
NO BACKER I FOR JUST. BRADFORD
I COME BY IT- I PROTESTING I
DALLY. DOT ARE YOU TORONTO I
EGGMAN GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE I
GROW. HERTZBERG HI WITH SO I
HER TADO. I JONES NO CAMCORDER
I LAYERED I LLEVA. FIVE THE MON
I REQUIRE I MELINDA'S NO MAN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. NO BUT SHOWED
BOTH. PAM FIVE THIRTEEN TINA I
BROUGHT. I RUBIO I SKINNER. I
STERN NUMBER HI I WORK OUT SKI
I WINNER. I WILL NOW PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN I
CAN. FOR JUST. DALLY. EGGMAN
GROWTH. A TROUBLED STERN. PRICE
TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS FIVE THE
AMENDMENTS THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MEMBERS ARE GONNA TEMPORARILY
PACIFIED FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN
AND WILL MOVE ON TO A LEVIN
TWELVE THIRTEEN AND FOURTEEN.
SENATOR EARLY MORNING SHE IS
PREPARED. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL FORTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR LE MON AN ACT
RELATING TO OIL AND GAS.
SATURDAY MORNING THE FLOOR'S
YOURS THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SP FORTY SEVEN IS A BACKUP OF
CURRENT SP FORTY SEVEN
ADDRESSES A SERIOUS PROBLEM
DESERTED WELLS IN CALIFORNIA
HAS BEEN ESTIMATED THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS LIABILITY OF AT
LEAST FIVE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS BUT UP TO
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS. DESERTED
WLLS ARE NOT ONLY FINANCE A
FINANCIAL LIABILITY TO THE
STATE BUT DANGEROUS TO THE
SURROUNDING ENVIRONMENT AND
RESIDENTS THE WELCOME LEAK
DEGRADING AIR QUALITY AND
CONTAMINATING OCCUPIERS HARMING
THE SURROUNDING COMMUNITY
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS REDUCE THE
AMOUNT THAT CAL JAM CAN COLLECT
AND SPEND. FROM TEN MILLION TO
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS AND REMOVE
CALGENE'S ABILITY TO RETAIN
UNSPENT FUNDS AND TO INCLUDE A
REPORTING REQUIREMENT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN ITEM.
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE THREE MEN PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS BASE NO BACKER. I
PORCHES. NO BRADFORD I HAVE A-
HI PROTECTING I DALLY NO GOD I-
AWESOME HI EGGMAN LASER HI
CONSOLIDATES I GROW NO
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HI HER TADO.
JONES NO CAN LONGER I LAYERED I
LLEVA I THE MON HI WIRE I
MELINDA'S NO MAN I NEWMAN. I
NIELSEN NO A SHOW OF BOTH NO
PAN. FORTUNE TINO I ROTH I
REVIEW. SKINNER HI STERN I'M
BERG HI I WORK OWSKI I WINNER I
WILL NOW PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ATKINS EGGMAN HER TADO
NO. PAM RUBIO I STERN. FIVE
TWENTY SIX KNOWS TEN THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. SENATOR WIENER.
HE IS PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL TWO
TWENTY ONE BY SENATOR WIENER AN
ACT RELATING TO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE SENATOR WIENER THE
FORAGERS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MY COLLEAGUES AS B.
TWO TWENTY ONE STRENGTHENS A
TIMELY ACCESS STANDARDS FOR
PEOPLE TO GET MENTAL HEALTH
APPOINTMENTS IT HAS RECEIVED
BROAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT SO ON
THE TWENTY FOURTH YEAR AFTER
THE FULL MONTY AIRED IN
THEATERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR RIVAL. IS IT IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
SIDE ITEM DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SINGMAN MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA
HI ACTIONS BASED. I BACKER. I
PORCHES I BRADFORD. BY ADAM HI
PROTESTING I DALLY NO DODD I
TORONTO I EGGMAN GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE HIGH GROWTH. HURTS
BERG HI WESTERN I HER TADO HI
JONES I CAN LONGER I GLARED. HI
LLEVA HI THE MON HI WIRE I
MELINDA'S HI MAN. HI NEWMAN I
NELSON.CONTROL OF BOTH HI PAM
I FOURTEEN TINA I BROUGHT. HI
RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN AMBERG
I LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER I WILL.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ATKINS BRADFORD I
ADMIN GROWTH. NIELSEN STERN.
FIVE THIRTY FOUR KNOWS ONE THIS
CAN BE MY MENTOR CONCURRED IN
PUTTING ON THAT FILE ITEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN CENTER
PRINTING- IS READY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWO FIFTY FIVE BY
SENATOR FORTUNE TINO AND ACTS
RELATING TO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE CENTER PRINTING OF THE
FLOOR'S YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS. ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE TECHNICAL IN
NATURE. THIS PROPOSAL TO FIFTY
FIVE IS JOINTLY AUTHORED BY MY
COLLEAGUE. SENATOR COM LONGER
AS WELL- SO THE MEMBERS WERE
TECHNICALLY IN NATURE AND
INCLUDE CHAPTER RING OUT
AMENDMENTS ONE MIGHT THINK THAT
THE PRODUCERS HEALTH BENEFITS
IS POPULATED BY. JERSEY BOYS
NEW YORKERS AND CALIFORNIANS
BUT THE INDUSTRY IS CENTRAL TO
CALIFORNIA THIS HELPS IT STAY
HERE AND PROVIDES HEALTH
BENEFITS TO ITS MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
CONCURRENCE WITH THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU. THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA I.
ADKINS EIGHT HI BECKER HI
PORCHES I BRADFORD I HAVE A I
DON'T HI CORTESE I DALLY I DON
I TORONTO HI A COMMON. LASER I
CONSOLIDATE HIGH GROWTH.
HERTZBERG I WAS SO I HER TADO
HI JONES. I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I LABOR HI THE MOON I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S I MAN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN I A TROUBLE I
PAM I PARDON TINA I BROUGHT. I
RUBIO FIVE SKINNER. I STERN
AMBERG HI CASKEY FIVE WINNER I
WILL. HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ATKINS EGGMAN GROVE I
EARNED. FIVE THIRTY SEVEN NO
ZERO DECEMBER MY MENTOR
CONCURRED IN. MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN FIFTEEN
AND SIXTEEN SENATOR GRASSO IS
PREPARED PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL THREE TWENTY ONE BY
SENATOR ALSO AN ACT RELATING TO
EMPLOYMENT CENTER DRIVE SO THE
FLOOR IS YOURS HELLO DOLLY I'M
SORRY I MEAN. MADAM PRESIDENT
THANK YOU. ASSEMBLYMEN MIMS
NARROWED THIS LEGISLATION TO AN
ADVISORY COMMITTEE THAT WILL
ONE DEVELOP EDUCATIONAL AND
VOLUNTARY GUIDELINES FOR
PROTECTING THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF HOUSEHOLD DOMESTIC
SERVICE EMPLOYEES AND TO. MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON WHAT-ADDITIONAL STEPS THE
LEGISLATURE OR THE DEPARTMENT
OF INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS MIGHT
TAKE TO BETTER PROTECT
HOUSEHOLD DOMESTIC SERVICE
EMPLOYEES. IS MEASURES A LATINO
CAUCUS PRIORITY AND IS
UNOPPOSED I BELIEVE THAT IS AN
IMPORTANT NEXT STEP TOWARDS
PROTECTING THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF HOUSEHOLD DOMESTIC
SERVICE EMPLOYEES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
THING THEN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA BY ATKINS.
EIGHT NOPE BACKER. FIVE FOUR
JUST KNOW BRADFORD I COME BY
ADAM HI PROTESTING I DALLY NO
DOT. THEY'RE AWESOME I EGGMAN
GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE HIGH
GROWTH NO HERTZBERG HI WEST SO
HYPER TANTO. I JONES NO CAN
LONGER I LAYERED I LABOR I THE
MOON I REQUIRE I MELINDA'S NO
MEN. I NEWMAN I NIELSEN. I A
TELEVOTE NO TAN I PERSON TINO I
BROUGHT I RUBIO FIVE SKINNER I
STERN AMBERG HI HI WE CAN SKI
FIVE WINNER I WILL KNOW. OKAY
NIELSEN I TO KNOW. PLEASE THERE
IS A CHANGE. SENATOR DODD. OKAY
KA CALL PLEASE CALL THE ABSA
MEMBERS. ATKINS DOT I EGGMAN
STERN. FIVE TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS
NINE THE SECOND AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MOVING ON TO A
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL THREE THIRTY FOUR BY
SENATOR ALSO AN ACT RELATING TO
DETENTION FACILITIES SENATOR
DRAWS OF THE FLOOR'S YOURS GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES S. B.
THREE THREE FOUR THE DETENTION
FACILITY ACCOUNTABILITY ACT IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE. IS B.
THREE THREE FOUR WE'LL HELP IN
FOURTH ENFORCE HEALTH AND
SAFETY STANDARDS FOR PEOPLE
DETAINED IN PRIVATE FOR PROFIT
PRISONS AND DETENTION
FACILITIES MANY OF THOSE
CONDITIONS ARE ABSOLUTELY
WICKED AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL
TAKEN IN THE ASSEMBLY OUR
TECHNICAL AND KEPT CLEAR FINE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
I ARCHULETA I AT KINS BAIT NO
BACKER I PORCHES NO BRADFORD I
HAVE A I PROTESTING I DALLY NO
DOG I DRAW SO I EGGMAN LASER.
GONZALEZ I GROW. NO HURTS BERG
I WAS SO. I TANTO HI JONES NO
CAN LONGER. I LAYERED I LIVE ON
HI THE MOON HI WIRE I MELINDA'S
NO MAN I NEWMAN I NELSON. NO I
TRIED BOTH. PAM HI FORTUNE TINO.
HI ROTH HI RUBIO. HI SKINNER
FIVE STERN I'M BERG I LIKE HOW
SKI I WINNER. I WILL KNOW
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ATKINS EGGMAN GLAZER I. A
TRUCKLOAD NO STERN. FIVE TWENTY
EIGHT KNOWS NINE THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MOVING ON FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIXTEEN SENATOR OTOBO SHE HAS
PREPARED PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL THREE THIRTY SIX BY
SENATOR- TELEPHONE AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC HEALTH
DECLARING THE URGENCY THERE AT
SIX FIFTY MEDIALLY SENATOR
TROUBLED FOURS YEARS MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBER SENATE
BILL THREE THREE SIX IS BACK IN
CONCURRENCE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
CLARIFY THE LANGUAGE AND
TERMINOLOGY OF THE BILL AT THE
REQUEST OF THE CAT. CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
CONFRONT WITH EXISTING OF
CONFORM WITH EXISTING PRACTICE
I ASKED FOR AN IPO. IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SAYING MAN MEMBERS THIS
ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SAYING
NINE I THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO ON
THE URGENCY. FIVE THIRTY SEVEN
NO ZERO ON THAT ON THAT
COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON
WE'RE GONNA TEMPORARILY PASS OR
FAIL ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN MOVE
ON TO EIGHTEEN SENATOR UMBERG
IS PREPARED PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL THREE SIXTY SIX BY SENATOR
UMBERG AN ACT RELATING TO
VEHICLE DISMANTLING CENTER
NUMBER FOUR IS YOURS. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS OF
THE SCHOOLS HERE ONCONCURRENCE
AMENDMENTS THIS SOMEBODY
CLARIFY THAT A BUILDING USED
FOR ILLEGAL AUTO DISMANTLING
THE PUBLIC NUISANCE SO THAT
THEY CAN BE SHUT DOWN THE
DAMAGES CAN BE RECOVERED BY
PUBLIC ENTITIES- CAN I VOTE.
FOR ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SAYING NONE THIS ITEM IS
ELIGIBLE. FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION.
SEEING ICE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THIS SIMPLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MOVING ON TO
NINETEEN AFTER WHICH WILL TAKE
UP TO TWENTY. TWENTY ONE AND
TWENTY TWO SENATOR UMBERG IS
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL THREE EIGHTY
SIX BY SENATOR UMBERG AN ACT
RELATING TO ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES
SENATOR AMBER. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS THIS- BILLED
SIMPLY AS AMENDED TO MAKE
TECHNICAL CHANGES ORIGINAL VOTE.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS. ANY DISCUSSION-
RATE SAYING NINE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS BAIT I BACKER I PORCHES
HI BRADFORD I HAVE A
HYPERTENSIVE I DALLY. HI TODD.
I TORONTO I AIKMAN GLAZER NOPE
AND SOLID. I GROVE. HI HURTS
BURKE HI WESTERN HI HER TADO I
JONES I CAN LONGER. I LAYERED I
LLEVA HI THE MON I REQUIRE. I
MELINDA'S FIVE MILLION FIVE
NEWMAN I NIELSEN I A TELEPHONE.
I CAN HI FORTUNE TINO I. ROSS I
REVIEW FIVE SKINNER. I STERN
AMBERG I LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER.
I WILL HI PLEASE CALL THE OB TO
MEMBERS. ATKINS AIKMAN TURN.
FIVE THIRTY SIX NO NO ONE
DECEMBER MY MEDS ARE CONCURRED
IN MOVING ON TO FILEITEM
NUMBER TWENTY CENTER WEST SO IS
PREPARED PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL FIVE EIGHTY NINE BY
SENATOR WEST SO AN ACT RELATING
TO AIR POLLUTION CENTER WAS SO
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU
MADAM. PRESIDENT AND SENATORS
SP FIVE EIGHTY NINE IS BACK ON
COME CURRENTS AMENDMENTS IN THE
ASSEMBLY ADDRESS POTENTIAL
CHAPTER IN ISSUES THIS BILL HAS
ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
ASTRONOMICAL. THREE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SAYING NON MEMBERS THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING NONE HIGHS THIRTY SEVEN
NO ZERO. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
SENATOR PENN HE HAS PREPARED
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL FIVE
NINETY EIGHT BY SENATOR PAN AN
ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT CENTER UPON THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK U. S. B.
FIVE NINETY EIGHT IS A
DISABILITY BACK IN CONCURRENCE
AFTER RECEIVING TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS BOTH- SAC RT AND
ARMED POLICE SUPPORTED SO
THEY'LL BE SINGING IN THE RAIN
IF YOU VOTE. HI SIR ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SAYING THAT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN. ALAN HI ARCHULETA I
ATKINS BAIT NO BACKER. I
PORCHES NO BRADFORD I COME BY
ADAM HI PROTESTING I DALLY. NO
DOG HI TORONTO I EGGMAN GLAZER.
NO CONSOLIDATES I GROVE NO
HERTZBERG I WAS SO I HER TADO I
JONES NO CAMCORDER FIVE LAYERED
I LABOUR I THE MON I REQUIRE. I
MELINDA'S NO MAN I NEWMAN I
NELSON. NO A SHOW OF THE. PAM
HI FORTUNE TINO HI RALPH HI
RUBIO. I'VE SKINNER I STERN
AMBERG HI FORECASTING I WINNER
I WILL NOW PLEASE CALL THE OB
TO MEMBERS. ATKINS EGGMAN A
CHOKE I. STERN. FIVE TWENTY
EIGHT KNOWS NINE DECEMBER
MEMINTA CONCURRED IN MOVING
UNDER FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
TWO SENATOR ARCHULETA IS
PREPARED PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL SIX FORTY THREE BY SENATOR
ARCHULETA AN ACT RELATING TO
AIR POLLUTION CENTER TO LEAD OF
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT HAD MEMBERS I
RISE TO PRESENT SENATE BILL SIX
FORTY THREE WHICH IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCESENATE BILL SIX
FORTY THREE TASKS STATE
AGENCIES TO PREPARE STATEWIDE
ASSESSMENT OF HYDROGEN FUEL
CELL ELECTRIC VEHICLES FUELING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND FUEL
PRODUCTION NEEDED TO SUPPORT
THE ADOPTION OF ZERO EMISSION
TRUCKS BUSES AND OFF ROAD
VEHICLES TO INCLUDE THOROUGHLY
MODERN MILLIE. AND HER FOOD
FUEL CELL ELECTRIC VEHICLE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MOVED- THE
RESPONSIBILITY FROM THE STATE
AIR RESOURCES BOARD THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
AND NARROW THAT VEHICLE
CATEGORIES COVERED BY THE
ASSESSMENT TO HEAVY DUTY AND
OFF ROAD VEHICLES THIS BILL HAS
NO OPPOSITION AND RECEIVED NO
NO VOTES FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY AFTER APPLE THERE
INDISCRETION OR. DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SAYING THAT MEMBER THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL ANY OBJECTION. SEEING NONE
ICE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO. THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN PUTTING ON THE
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY THREE
CENTER GONZALEZ IS READY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL SIX FIFTY BY
SENATOR STERN AN ACT RELATING
TO SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
CENTER GONZALEZ THE FLOOR'S
YOURS THANK YOU MISS- MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS OF RACE
PERCENT SP SIX FIFTY ON BEHALF
OF SENATOR STERN ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS PROVIDE THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
ACCESS. AND INFORMATION MORE
TIME TO COMPLETE REGULATIONS
AND ENSURE THE BILL IS NOT IN
CONFLICT WITH NATIONAL
STANDARDS FOR CERTIFIED PUBLIC
ACCOUNTANTS ARE RESPECTFULLY
ASPIRIN I THOUGHT. FOR ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
THING THEN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI AT KINS
BAIT I. BECKER. HI FORTIS NO
BRADFORD I HAVE A I DON'T HI
PROTESTING. HI DALLY NO GOD ALL
FIVE YOU'RE AWESOME HI EGGMAN
BLAZER HI CONSOLIDATES HI I
GROW NO KURTZ BURKE. HI WESTERN.
HI- TIDO I JOHN'S NO CAN LONGER
I LAYERED HI LLEVA HI THE MON I
REQUIRE. I MELINDA'S NO MEN. I
NEWMAN HI I NIELSEN. NO A SHOW
BOTH. HI PAM I FORTUNE TINO
FIVE ROTH I RUBIO FIVE SKINNER
FIVE STERNE AMBERG I LIKE HOW
SKI I WINNER. FIVE WELL. HI.
FIVE THIRTY ONE NO SIX THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MOVING ON TO ITEM
FILE I'M TWENTY FOUR CENTER
WEST SO IS PREPARED PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL SEVEN TWELVE BY
SENATOR WEST SO AN ACT RELATING
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT CENTER WEST
SO THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR PRESIDENTS
TODAY'S A LONG AWAITED DAY
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS BILL
FOR QUITE A WHILE NOW SEVEN
TWELVE WILL WRECK THE FIVE
YEARS OF LONGSTANDING
DISCRIMINATORY PRACTICES BY
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. THAT HAVE
DEPRIVED NATIVE AMERICANS FROM
FAIR PROCESS IN THEIR ATTEMPTS
TO ACQUIRE ANCESTRAL LANDS IT'S
BACK ON CONCURRENCE- THE
AMENDMENTS IN THE ASSEMBLY
SIMPLY. AMEND THE BILL TO TEN
DAYS RATHER THAN FIVE TO ALLOW
INK OF THE ECONOMIC INFORMATION
TO BE PRESENTED WITH- FROM
TRIBES. AND PENCIL HI TODAY'S
DATE IS CELEBRATED ALL OF YOU
REALLY ARE- THE WAY IS THAT ARE
GOING TO GIVE THIS BILL. THE
RUBY RED SLIPPERS TO GET IT
HOME. PLEASE IT'S BEEN UP
PARTISAN SUPPORT BILL I
RECOMMEND I VOTE. FOR ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SAYING MAN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA HI ADKINS.
EIGHT BACKER. HI FOR JUST.
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM. HI
CORTESE I DALLY. I WAS SO HI
HER TADO I JONES. I CAN LONGER.
I LAYERED HI LLEVA I THE MOON.
MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S I MEN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. I ASSURE BOTH.
I CAN I PERSON TINA I BROUGHT I
REVIEW. I SKINNER. FIVE STERNE
AMBERG HI HI FORECASTING I
WINNER. I WILL HI PLEASE CALL
THE OB TO MEMBERS. ATKINS BATES.
FOR JUST. DALLY EGGMAN GLAZER.
GROVE LIMONIUM STERN. FIVE
THIRTY ONE NO ZERO THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY FIVE SENATOR ROTH IS
PREPARED PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL SEVEN FIFTY THREE BY
SENATOR OFF AN ACT RELATING TO
EMPLOYMENT CENTER OFF THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES JUST AS
THE MASKED MAN ROSE FROM THE
DEPTHS OF THE CAVERNS BENEATH
THE OPERA HOUSE. LIKE THE
PHANTOM OF THE OPERA THIS BILL
HAS RISEN FROM THE CAVERNS OF
THE ASSEMBLY. UNMASKED FOR
CONCURRENCE THE BILL CLARIFIES
THAT THE EDT YOU CAN SURE BASE
WAGE INFORMATION WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD FOR THE
PURPOSES. OF EVALUATION AND
ANALYSIS OF STATE AND FEDERALLY
FUNDED WORKFORCE PROGRAMS.
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS SIMPLY
RESULT CHATTERING ISSUES
RESPECTFULLY AS FOR YOUR RIVAL-
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NINE MEMBERS
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO IN USING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL SAYING NINE
ICE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THIS
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SIX CENTER
GONZALEZ IS PREPARED. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL FOUR BY SENATOR GONZALEZ
AN ACT RELATING TO
COMMUNICATIONS AND CLAIM THE
URGENCY BARRACKS EXPECTS
IMMEDIATELY CENTER GONZALEZ THE
FLOOR'S YOURS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS TO SP FOUR INCHES OF
THE BILL CONFORM TO CURRENT LAW
AFTER THE PASSAGE OF THE
BROADBAND TRAILER BILL THIS
SUMMER. ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS
REPRESENT A COMPROMISE BETWEEN
BOTH LEGISLATIVE HOUSES AND
WILL ENSURE S. BEFORE AN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGUILAR CURRY'S
AB FOURTEEN R. AND ACTED
TOGETHER AND ULTIMATELY THIS
WILL ALLOW CALIFORNIA FAMILIES
TO RELIABLY STREAMS INTO DO. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER I VOTE ON
CONCURRENCE IN THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS. OR ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SING THEN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ARCHULETA HI AT KANSAS STATE.
BACKER HI FORTUS BRADFORD I
HAVE A BETTER LIFE PROTESTING I
DALLY NO DOG I TORONTO I EGGMAN
GLAZER. GONZALES I GROW. NO
HERTZBERG. HI WITH SO HI HER
TADO I JONES NO CAMCORDER. I
LAYERED I LLEVA HI THE MOON HI
WIRE. I MELINDA'S NO MAN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. NO SHOGO HI
PAM I PORTS AND TINA. HI RALPH
I REVIEW FIVE SKINNER I STERN
AMBERG. FIVE FOUR CASKEY I
WINNER I WILL. NOW PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ALAN I
ATKINS I EIGHT NO FORTUS.
EGGMAN GLAZER I STERN. WELL
KNOWN FOR AMBERG I DON'T KNOW.
FIVE TWENTY NINE KNOWS EIGHT ON
THE URGENCY EYES TWENTY NINE NO
EIGHT ON THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS. MEMBERS ARE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY SEVEN SENATOR UMBERG. HE
HAS PREPARED PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FORTY ONE BY
SENATOR ON BERG AN ACT RELATING
TO PRIVACY SENATOR UMBERG THE
FLOOR'S YOURS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES- THE
SUPPLEMENTS SIMPLY AMEND
DEFINITION EXPAND EXEMPTIONS
THEY CLARIFIED FORSMAN
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOVEL. IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. YES YEAH. SAY THAT
AGAIN. OKAY GOT IT. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA HI ATKINS.
BATES I BECKER HI FORTUS HI
BRADFORD I HAVE A HI HI FOR
TESTING I DALLY. I DON I
TORONTO I EGGMAN GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE I WROTE. I HEARD
SPURRED BY WESTERN HI HER TADO.
I JONES HI CAN LONGER. I
LAYERED HI LLEVA HI THE MON HI
WIRE I MELINDA'S. FIVE MEN I
NEWMAN I NELSON. I BUT YOUR
VOTE I CAN. HI PERSON TINA I
BROUGHT HI RUBIO I SKINNER HI
STERN. NUMBER ALL RIGHT I LIKE
HOW SKI I WINNER I WILL I. THIS
CALL THE UP TO MEMBERS. AT KINS.
ECKERMANN TURN. FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
PUTTING ON THE FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY EIGHT SIMONE AT CENTER
IN THE MORNING. IS PREPARED.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIFTY BY SENATOR
LAMONT AN ACT RELATING TO EARLY
LEARNING AND CARE. CENTERS
AMONG THE FLOOR'S YOURS HUMANA
HAS THE SP FIFTY IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE SP FIFTY ALLOWS
PROVIDERS IN THE STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM TO SERVE
CHILDREN EIGHTEEN MONTHS TO
FIVE YEARS AND PROVIDES BOTH
CATEGORICAL ELIGIBILITY AND
TWENTY FOUR MONTHS OF
CONTINUOUS ELIGIBILITY.
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS INCLUDE A
SUNSET DATE AND REMOVE
COMPONENTS OF THE BILL DEALING
WITH CONTRACTING AND
REIMBURSEMENT CHILD CARE IS AN
ESSENTIAL NEED AND I KNOW
SOMETIMES IT CAN FEEL LIKE
PEOPLE ARE PLAYING WITH FIDDLER
ON THE ROOF BUT IT IS AN
IMPORTANT ASPECT OF OUR
COMMUNITY. I RESPECT LAST NIGHT
DURING THE DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING MEMBERS THIS
ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION. SAYING NINE ICE
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCORDANT. WE'RE GOING TO
TEMPORARILY PASSED ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY NINE AND MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY WHICH IS
SENATOR SKINNER. SHE IS
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL EIGHTY ONE BY
SENATOR SKINNER AN ACT RELATING
TO SENTENCING. SENATOR SKINNER
THE FLOOR IS YOURS- THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS CSP
EIGHTY ONE PROVIDES GUIDANCE TO
THE COURTS. IN ISSUING SENTENCE
ENHANCEMENTS AND IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE WE WORKED
DILIGENTLY WITH STAKE HOLDERS
AND TOOK AMENDMENTS WHICH I
WILL BRIEFLY DESCRIBE IT THAT
EVERY MOVE TO THE FOLLOWING
OPPOSITION. NO LONGER A
POSTCARD THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
SAN DIEGO DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE THE SAN DIEGO DEPUTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S ASSOCIATION
AND OUR PEACE OFFICERS RESEARCH
ASSOCIATION PORAC THE
AMENDMENTS REMOVED THE
PRESUMPTION STANDARD. AND
INSTEAD PROVIDE THAT THE COURT
SHOW CONSIDERING AFFORD GREAT
WEIGHT TO SPECIFIED
CIRCUMSTANCES. WITH THE
AMENDMENTS ALSO CLARIFIED WHAT
THE SPECIFIED CIRCUMSTANCES ARE
AT&T THE PROVISIONS OF THE BILL
WILL APPLY TO SENTENCES ONLY
OCCURRING AFTER THE EFFECTIVE
DATE OF THIS BILL. JUST AS
MALONE ROUGE CELEBRATES TRUTH
BEAUTY FREEDOM AND LOVE THIS
BILL WILL DO THE SAME AS THE
GUARDS ARE COURTS IN APPLYING
SENTENCE ENHANCEMENTS I ASK FOR
YOUR I. VOTE. SENATOR NIELSEN.
MADAM PRESIDENT LAYS DOWN ON
THE SENATE. A LITTLE BIT OF
HISTORY HERE. SHE DIDN'T HAVE
CEMENT CAME ALONG AS A RESPONSE
TO SOMETHING THAT PASSED IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN CALL THE
DETERMINANT SENTENCE LAW. EVEN
GOVERNOR BROWN LIVED TO RUE THE
DAY THAT THAT PACKS.
DETERMINATE SENTENCE LONGER
SUPPORTED BY BOTH CONSERVATIVES
AND LIBERALS FOR VERY DIFFERENT
REASONS AT ALL. LIVE TO RUE THE
DAY. THE CONSERVATIVES WANTED
TO MAKE SURE BECAUSE OF THE
LEAK LEAK SENTENCING OF THOSE
ERRORS THE INDIVIDUALS WOULD
BSOLUTELY SERVE A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF TIME TO BE PUNCHED.
LIBERALS ELECTED BECAUSE NOBODY
KNEW HOW LONG THEY WERE GONNA
SERVE INDETERMINATE SENTENCE.
WITH ASSURE THEM OF THAT. SO AS
A PART OF THE CORRECTION OVER
THE YEARS. AND AS A PART OF THE
RESPONSE TO THE SEVERITY OF THE
CRIME WAVES THAT ARE REFLECTED
OUR SOCIETY AND OUR CITIZENS.
ENHANCEMENTS OF COLOGNE. WELL
THE REFORMERS HAVE NEVER LIKED
ENHANCEMENT. SOME OF EVEN CALL
IT A DOUBLE PENALTY. LOOK
ENHANCEMENTS ARE THE PRODUCT OF
CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR THAT WAS MORE
EGREGIOUS AND THEREFORE
REQUIRED AND JUSTIFIED A LONGER
SENTENCE FOR THAT INDIVIDUAL'S
BEHAVIOR. THIS IS JUST ANOTHER
PART OF THE LET'S GO EASY ON
CRIME- SUFFERS. DO YOU EVER
THINK ABOUT VICTIMS AROUND HERE
HARDLY EVER ANYMORE LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE VICTIMS ARE THE
CRIMINALS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
THE VICTIMS ARE NOT. THE REAL
TRUE VICTIMS. THE PART OF A
REFORM EFFORT WE JUST LOST A
SIXTY ONE YEAR OLD WOMAN. IN
SOUTH SACRAMENTO. TO A LOVELY
YOUNG MAN. WHO WAS GIVEN A LOT
OF LOVE. SEARCH NECK. INSTEAD
OF BEING. BUT HE WAS BAILED OUT
pPHIL HE HIT THE STREETS. THE
SIXTY ONE YEAR OLD WOMAN. AND
OUR TWO DOGS ARE DEAD BECAUSE
OF IT. MY POINT IS THERE ARE
CONSEQUENCES AND CONSEQUENCES
IN PART OR SENTENCE
ENHANCEMENTS. AND HERE WE'RE
GOING TO GIVE GREAT WEIGHT ALL
WE'RE GONNA LET THE JUDGES
DECIDE. AND MAYBE THE
PRESUMPTION LANGUAGE. HAS BEEN
LESSENED SLIGHTLY. BUT CLEARLY
THE PRESENT JOB REPORT THE
PRODUCTION IS THERE AND IF THIS
IS ALLOWED TO PASS. YOUR TD
THAT PRESUMPTION IS GOING TO BE
BACK AGAIN NEXT YEAR TO MAKE IT
EVEN MORE FIRM AND EVEN MORE
OBLIGING. THE JUDGE AND THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM. THE PERSON THAT.
REALLY WHAT THAT THAT CRIME
WOULD MAKE NO DIFFERENCE. I'M
SORRY LADIES AND GENTLEMAN. BUT
I DID GET A LITTLE BIT UPSET.
BECAUSE I'M SEEING FAR TOO MANY
TERRIBLE THINGS HAPPENING IN
OUR COMMUNITIES ACROSS AMERICA.
UNTIL WE AMERICANS STAND UP AND
SAY NO MAS. IT'S GOING TO GET
ONLY WORSE. CENTER GROVE. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE IN
OPPOSITION OF SPD ONE- NO
SENTENCE ENHANCEMENTS S. B.
EIGHTY ONE WOULD REQUIRE A
JUDGE TO STRIKE SINCE
ENHANCEMENTS UNDER CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES ALL WHICH WILL
RESULT IN VERY VERY VERY BAD
PEOPLE BEING RELEASED FROM
PRISON EARLIER THAN THEY
DESERVE. MY COLLEAGUES WHO
WROTE THE- WHO VOTE FOR THIS
BILL I WONDER IF YOU HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO. READ THE
SACRAMENTO BEE LAST WEEK WHICH
MY COLLEAGUE FROM AMY JUST
REFERENCED. A MAN NAMED TIMOTHY
DINNERS TROY DAVIS A MAN NAMED
TROY DAVIS A FIFTY ONE YEAR OLD
TRANSIENT WITH A CRIMINAL
HISTORY THAT INCLUDES TWO
FELONY STRIKE CONVICTIONS. OF
ASSAULT WITH A DEADLY WEAPON
AND ROBBERY WAS RELEASED FROM
JAIL ON HIS OWN RECORD COGNEX
IS. IN JUNE AFTER HIS ARREST IN
AN AUTO THEFT CASE THEY WERE
ONLY ABLE TO HOLD HIM. I CAN
TELL YOU THAT MR DAVIS WHO HAS
A RICH CRIMINAL HISTORY IN
SACRAMENTO BEE DATING BACK TO
TWO THOUSAND AND THIRTEEN.
INCLUDING CHARGES OF RESISTING
AN OFFICER BATTERY ON AN
OFFICER POSSESSING MASS
THREATENING AN OFFICER.
MISDEMEANOR SEXUAL BATTERY AND
ASSAULT AND BATTERY. EARLIER
THIS LAST WEEK HE WAS
APPARENTLY CAUGHT AT A RING
DOORBELL **** N LAND PARK.
THEN ON FRIDAY LAW ENFORCEMENT
HAS EVIDENCE AND HAS BELIEVES
THAT THIS EVIL MAN BROKE INTO
THE HOME OF MARY TIBBETTS. HE
KILLED THEIR DOGS BY MUTILATING
THEM HE RAPED AND MURDERED HER
ANY BURN YOUR HOUSE DOWN. THIS
PERSON SHOULD NEVER BEEN LET
OUT OF JAIL. A SWEET SIXTY ONE
YEAR OD WOMAN IS DEAD BECAUSE
THIS CRIMINAL BENEFITED FROM
THE POLICIES IMPLEMENTED BY
THIS LEGISLATURE AND A GOVERNOR
THAT LETS DANGEROUS PEOPLE BACK
OUT INTO OUR STREETS. IF
CONVICTED MR DAVIS COULD GET
THE DEATH PENALTY. EXCEPT THAT
THAT WOULD BE MEANINGLESS
BECAUSE WE SUSPENDED THE DEATH
PENALTY BY THE LEADERSHIP IN
THE STATE. SINCE ENHANCEMENTS
RECOGNIZES SOME CRIMINALS ARE A
VERY UNIQUE THREAT TO PUBLIC
SAFETY. AND THAT BY NO MEANS
WHICH THEY COMMIT THEIR CRIMES
AND THEY DESERVE ADDITIONAL
PUNISHMENT. SP EIGHTY ONE CENTS
AN ADDITIONAL MESSAGE THAT
WE'RE NO LONGER SERIOUS ABOUT
PROTECTING OUR PUBLIC AND OUR
COMMUNITIES. A LOT OF MONEY
HASN'T BEEN BEEN INVESTED IN-
LIKE MY COLLEAGUE FROM TO HEMA
SAID LEVYING OF THESE
PRISONERS. IN OFFERING THEM
CHOICES THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE
LIKE MR DAVIS THAT- I HATE TO
SAY IT BUT NO MATTER WHAT WE
OFFER THEM THEY'RE GONNA COMMIT
CRIMES. AND SENTENCING HANS
HANS SMITS HELP KEEP PEOPLE
LIKE MR DAVIS BEHIND JAIL IN
JAIL AND BEHIND BARS. AND SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE
BECAUSE THE CITIZENS THAT WE
REPRESENT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DESERVE TO BE SAFE
IN THE COMMUNITY THAT THEY WALK
IN AND THEY DESERVE TO BE SAFE
DEFINITELY IN THEIR OWN HOMES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE.
SENATOR WIENER. I THANK YOU-
YOU KNOW WHENEVER WE DEBATE-
CRIME AND PUNISHMENT IN PUBLIC
SAFETY- WE THEY'RE ALWAYS SO
IT'S HORRIFIC NIGHTMARE
EXAMPLES OF PEOPLE WHO COMMIT
TERRIBLE CRIMES THAT PEOPLE
COMMIT TERRIBLE CRIMES NEED TO
BE HELD CIVILLY ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THOSE CRIMES BUT WHEN WE LOOK
AT HOW WE DO SENTENCING IN
CALIFORNIA. INCLUDING OUR
ADDICTION TO OUR HUNDRED AND
FIFTY CENTS ANNOUNCEMENTS. A
SIGNIFICANT MAJORITY NIGHTMARE
SCENARIO THERE ARE PROBABLY
DOZENS OF SCENARIOS OR SCORES
OR HUNDREDS OF SCENARIOS WHERE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE COMMITTED
CRIMES AND NEED TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE. BUT ARE NOT IN
THAT NIGHTMARE SCENARIO AT ALL
AND YOU CAN BE REHABILITATED.
THEY HAVE A CERTAIN SETS TURN
FROM TWO OR THREE YEARS AND A
TEN OR FIFTEEN OR TWENTY YEARS
BECAUSE OF THE PILING ON OF
SENSE ENHANCEMENTS SO INSTEAD
OF JUST SAYING THIS CRIME IS
PUNISHABLE BY THIS AMOUNT OF
TIMES. WE PILE IT ON AND THEIR
LIVES ARE DESTROYED ANY CHANCE
OF REHABILITATING THEM AND
BRING THEM BACK INTO THE
COMMUNITY AND REUNITING THEM
WITH THEIR FAMILIES IS ENDED.
AND WE ALSO KNOW WHO IS
IMPACTED DISPROPORTIONATELY. BY
THE SONS AND HUSBANDS IT'S NOT
PEOPLE WHO LOOK LIKE ME LET'S
JUST PUT IT THAT WAY. BLACK AND
BROWN COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN
TORN APART BECAUSE OF OUR
ADDICTION TO MASS INCARCERATION
IN CALIFORNIA WHEN YOU TAKE A
MORE RATIONAL APPROACH GIVES
JUDGES THE TOOLS THEY NEED. TO
ACTUALLY EVALUATE THE FACTS OF
CASES AND TO APPLY SENSE IT
HASN'T ONLY WHEN APPROPRIATE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPO. OR
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SAYING NINE CENTER SKINNER YOU
MAY CONCLUDE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT SO I JUST WANT TO
CORRECT THE RECORD. **** ONE
DOES NOT ELIMINATE ANY SENTENCE
ENHANCEMENT NOR DOES IT REQUIRE
OR FORCE A JUDGE TO DISMISS AN
ENHANCEMENT. AND THE
PRESUMPTION LANGUAGE IT IS
FULLY AND ENTIRELY REMOVED
INSTEAD THE BILL. GIVES THE
JUDGE THE ABILITY TO. CONSIDER
WITH GREAT WEIGHT SPECIFIED
CIRCUMSTANCES WHICH ARE DEFINED
IN THOSE AMENDMENTS DEMANDED OF
GREAT WEIGHT AND THE REMOVAL OF
PRESUMPTION THE DEFINITION OF
THE CIRCUMSTANCES AND THE FACT
THAT THE THIS BILL CANNOT BE
APPLIED RETROACTIVELY WERE ALL
NEGOTIATED WITH THE FOLKS WHO I
MENTIONED HAVE NOW REMOVED
THEIR OPPOSITION WHICH IS THE-
DEPARTMENT THE CALIFORNIA DA'S
ASSOCIATION AND PORK SO WITH
THAT. I ASK FOR YOUR I. BOAT.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. WITH ALAN. ARCHULETA I.
ATKINS. EIGHT NO BACKER I
PORCHES NO BRADFORD I COME BY
ADAM. CORTEZ THREE FIVE DOLLY
NO DOT HI TORONTO I A GUNMAN
GLAZER NOPE GONZALEZ I GROW NO
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HI FURTADO
NO JONES. NO CAM AUGER. I
LAYERED I LLEVA HI THE MON HI
REQUIRE. FIVE MELINDA'S NO MAN.
NEWMAN FIVE NIELSEN NO A SHOW
OF BOTH NO TAN I FOURTEEN TINA
I BROUGHT FIVE REVIEW FIVE
SKINNER. FIVE STERN NUMBER.
WHITE HOUSE SKI I WINNER. I
WILL. NOW PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN ADKINS.
CABALLERO EGGMAN. MAN. STERN
AMBERG. FIVE TWENTY TWO KNOWS
ELEVEN THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MEMBERS ARE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY ONE SENATOR AMBER ARE
YOU PREPARED. HE IS PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL TWO FORTY ONE BY
SENATOR UMBERG AN ACT RELATING
TO CIVIL ACTIONS SENATOR UMBERG
FOURS YEARS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES OF THE
CALIFORNIA COURT EFFICIENCY ACT
IS BACK BEFORE US WITH A NUMBER
OF AMENDMENTS- WHAT THE
AMENDMENTS TO IS A LOT OF COURT
REPORTERS BOARD TO OVERSEE AND
REGULATE- COURT REPORTERS WHO
ARE- OUT OF STATE COURT
REPORTERS THEY PROVIDE FOR A
LOCAL COURT REPORTING FIRM TO
BE RESPONSIBLE AND RESPONSIVE
CONSIDERING. THE OUT OF STATE
COURT REPORTING FIRMS
ACTIVITIES IT ALSO ALLOWS A
PARTY APPEAR REMOTELY IN THE
COURTS TO CONDUCT CONFERENCES
HEARINGS PROCEEDINGS AND OTHER
CIVIL CASES WITH REMOTE
TECHNOLOGY THERE'S A SUNSET OF
JULY ONE TWENTY TWENTY THREE-
IT ALSO- IT- A REQUIRES A COURT
TO LIKE TRONIC LEE SERVED COURT
ISSUED DOCUMENTS ON PARTIES.
WHO HAVE CONSENTED TO
ELECTRONIC SERVICE AND IT-
ENSURES THAT ARBITRATION
DEADLINES ARE TIMELY AND
PREDICTABLE WHEN THE LATE HI
RICHARD FIVE VOTE. MEMBERS IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE CENTER DRAWS A- THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE TO
SUPPORT SB TWO FORTY ONE- WITH
THESE AMENDMENTS. MY BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE CONSIDERED
PROPOSALS AND HAD MANY HOURS
OF. PUBLIC COMMENT AND PANELS
AND PRESENTATIONS RELATED TO
REMOTE PROCEEDINGS WE HEARD
FROM TRIAL COURT EMPLOYEES
INCLUDING COURT REPORTERS
INTERPRETERS- REPORTED ABOUT.
THE DIFFICULTIES THEY HAD IN
HEARING AND UNDERSTANDING
TESTIMONY REMOTELY I WAS
CONCERNED ABOUT INSTITUTING
PERMANENT REMOTE PARTICIPATION-
BUT I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
AND ALL WHO SERVED ON. A SERVED
ON THESE- PANELS AND-
TESTIMONIES AND I WANT TO THANK
ALL EVERYONE WHO SERVES IN THE
JUDICIAL SYSTEM WHO ARE TRYING
TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE HAS
A EQUAL ACCESS TO THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM THANK YOU. THERE ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEVEN NINE MEMBERS THIS ITEM IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL ANY OBJECTION. SINGMAN
HIGHS THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO. I'M
SORRY THERE IS AN OBJECTION.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN ARCHULETA I ATKINS
BATES. BACKER I FOR JUST FIVE
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM HI
COURTESY I DALLY. I DONT I-
AWESOME HI ADNAN. LASER I
CONSOLIDATES I GROSS. HI HURTS
BERG I WEAR SO I HER TADO I
JONES I CAN LONGER. I LAYERED I
LLEVA I THE MON I REQUIRE. I
MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN I
NELSON I WOULD SHOW UP BOTH. HI
PAM I FORTINO I BROUGHT. FIVE
REVIEW FIVE SKINNER. HI STERN
NUMBER I LIKE HOW SKI HI WINNER.
I WILL HI PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN I AT KINS
BAIT I A COMMON WHEN DOES STERN.
FIVE THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MOVING OUT ON TO
FILE ITEM THIRTY TWO SENATOR
NEWMAN IS PREPARED PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWO FORTY TWO BY
SENATOR NEWMAN AN ACT RELATING
TO HEALTH CARE CENTER NEWMAN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS AS B. TWO FOUR TWO IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE THIS BILL
WILL REQUIRE HEALTH INSURERS TO
REIMBURSE HEALTH CARE PROVIDER
FOR THE COST OF CRITICAL SAFETY
SUPPLIES NEEDED TO PROTECT
PATIENTS. DURING FUTURE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCIES. AMENDMENTS
REMOVE THE URGENCY AND EXCLUDE
MEDI CAL MANAGED CARE PLANS.
THEY ALSO LIMIT THE BILL TO
REIMBURSEMENT FOR BUSINESS
EXPENSES STEMMING ONLY TO FOR
FUTURE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCIES SO THAT WE WILL NOT
IN THAT- LIKE THE- CRISIS THAT
WE FACE TO FACE. THE MUSIC MAN-
RECENT EVENTS HAVE MOVED
OPPOSITION IN THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH PLANS AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I'VE- THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SAYING MAN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WITH ALAN HI ARCHULETA I ADKINS
BASE. NO BACKER. I PORCHES NO
BRADFORD I HAVE A I PROTESTING
I DALLY. DOT DALLY NO DOG. I
DRAW SO HI EGGMAN LASER.
GONZALEZ HI GROVE. N HERZBERG
I WAS SO. HI HER TADO  JONES
NO CAN LONGER. I LAYERED I
LLEVA I THE MOON HI WIRE HI
MELINDA'S NO MAN HI NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. O. JOGO NO TAN I
FORTINO I BROUGHT. I RUBIO I
SKINNER. I STERN AMBERG I LIKE
HOW SKI I WINNER I WILL. NO
PLEASE CALL PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS AIKMAN.
GLAZER I NIELSEN NO STERN. FIVE
TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS NINE THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. GOING ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY THREE
SENATOR RUBIO IS PREPARED
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL TWO
SIXTY THREE BY SENATOR RUBIO AN
ACT RELATING TO REAL ESTATE
SENATOR RUBIO THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE I RISE TO PRESENT SENATE
BILL TWO SIXTY THREE. THIS BILL
WILL HELP TO CLOSE THE
HOMEOWNER SHIP GAP FOR PEOPLE
OF COLOR BY REQUIRING REAL
ESTATE PROFESSIONALS TO TAKE
IMPLICIT BIAS. TRAINING MEMBERS
IT'S LIKE A LITTLE SHOP OF
HORRORS ARE READY TRYING TO BE
A HOME OWNER. LET'S NOT ADD
MORE BARRIERS THE SMM EMMONS AT
IMPLICIT BIAS TRAINING AS PART
OF PRE LICENSING. AND DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION OF A BILL UNTIL
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY THREE. S.
B. TWENTY THREE RECEIVE NO NO
VOTES IN THE ASSEMBLY AND HAS
NO OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. THING
THEN MEMBERS THIS ITEM IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION.
THERE IS AN OBJECTION PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA
HI AT KINS. EIGHT HI BECKER.
GORGEOUS HI BRADFORD I COME BY
ADAM I PROTESTING I DALLY. GOD
I TORONTO HI ADNAN LASER I
CONSOLIDATE I GROW. NO HERZBERG
I WEAR SO I- TADO I JONES NO
CAM AUGER. I LAYERED I LLEVA I
THE MOON HI WIRE I MELINDA'S I
MEN I NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. NO A
SHOW OF BOTH HI PAM I PERSON
TINA I BROUGHT. I RUBIO I
SKINNER. I STERN AMBERG ALL
RIGHT I CAN SKI I WINNER I WILL
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ATKINS BACKER. I.
VALLEY I. EGGMAN STERN. FIVE
THIRTY FOUR KNOWS THREE THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY FOUR CENTER
GROVE SHE IS PREPARED TO THREE.
WELL I'M SO SORRY SENATE BILL
TWO EIGHTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
GROWTH AN ACT RELATING TO
VEHICLES THANK YOU FOR READING
THE RESEARCHERS. A LITTLE EAGER
SORRY THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SP TWO EIGHTY SEVEN WILL
CONSOLIDATE MOST RECREATIONAL
TRAILERS UNDER CLASSY LICENSE-
AND ALLOW RECREATIONAL IMPORTS
INTO THE US TO TELL THEIR
WEEKEND TRADERS WITHOUT HAVING
TO UNDERGO UNNECESSARY
VERIFICATION AND EXORBITANT
FEES- THAT WERE REALLY INTENDED
FOR THE INDUSTRY'S HEAVIEST
COMMERCIAL TRAILERS. RECENT
AMENDMENTS AND THE DELAY IN
IMPLEMENTATION ADDRESS THE
CHAPTER IN ISSUES AND THIS IS A
BIPARTISAN MEASURE THAT HAS
RECEIVED NO NO VOTES AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BUT- IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE SAYING MAN THIS ITEM
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION.
SAYING NO OBJECTIONS I THIRTY
SEVEN NO ZERO. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY FIVE CENTER DOT IS
PREPARED PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL THREE OH TWO BY SENATOR
DODD AN ACT RELATING TO TRIBAL
GAMING AND DECLARING THE
URGENCY BARRACKS EXPERTS
MEDIALLY CENTERED ON MANTA
PRESENT MEMBERS SP THREE OH TWO
RATIFIES THE TRIBAL STATE
COMPACT BETWEEN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE PICKY AND
RANCHERIA. CONSISTENT WITH
RECENT COMPACT DISC COMPACT
ALLOWS FOR REVENUE SHARING WITH
NON GAMING UNLIMITED GAMING
TRIBES AND ALLOW WORKERS TO
UNIONIZE IT PROVIDE FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL MITIGATION THIS
ROCK OF AGES BILL RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION RESPECTFULLY ASK.
RIVAL IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE. THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION. SAYING NO
OBJECTION I THIRTY SEVEN NO
ZERO THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. R. YES OUR
HIGHS THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS ON THE
URGENCY HIGHS THIRTY SEVEN
KNOWS ON THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENT.
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
SEVEN SENATOR GONZALEZ'S
PREPARED PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL THREE THIRTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ AN ACT
RELATING TO PRIVATE EMPLOYMENT
CENTER GONZALEZ THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS SP THREE
THREE EIGHT PROTECTS PORT TRUCK
DRIVERS BY CLOSING THE LOOPHOLE
IN IT AN EXISTING JOINT
LIABILITY LIST FOR BAD ACTOR
TRUCKING COMPANIES AND MS
CLASSIFY THEIR WORKERS.
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE
ASSEMBLY NARROW THE SCOPE OF
THE BILL TO ENSURE THAT ONLY
THE WORST BAD ACTORS ARE PUT ON
THE BAD ACTOR LIST UNDER SB
THREE THREE AND ENSURE THAT THE
DIVISION OF LABOR STANDARDS
ENFORCEMENT HAS THE CAPACITY
AND ABILITY TO IMPLEMENT THE
BILL. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE ON CONCURRENCE IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA I AT
KINS BATES NO BACKER I PORCHES
NO BRADFORD I HAVE A HI CORTESE
I DALLY NO DOG. I THEY'RE
AWESOME I EKMAN GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE FIVE GROVE. NO
HERTZBERG FIVE WEST HI HER TADO.
JONES NO CAN LONGER I LAYERED
FIVE LLEVA I THE MOON FIVE WIRE
I MELINDA'S NO MAN. I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. NO A SHOW VOGUE NO TAN
I FORTUNE TINO. I ROTH HI RUBIO
I SKINNER. FIVE STERNE AMBERG
WHY I WAS ASKIN I WINNER HI
WELL LOOK NO. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. AT KINS EGGMAN
HER TADO. STERN. FIVE TWENTY
SEVEN KNOWS NINE THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MOVING ON TO A FILE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY EIGHT SENATOR ALLEN IS
PREPARED PLEASE READ. SENATE
pSENATOR ALAN AN ACT RELATING TO
ENVIRONMENTAL ADVERTISING.
SENATOR ALLEN THE FLOOR'S YOURS
THIRTY MINUTE PRESENT SOMETIMES
I FEEL LIKE THE MAN OF LA
MANCHA. TILTING AT WINDMILLS ON
THIS ISSUE RELATING TO
PLASTICS- WE'VE UNFORTUNATELY
NOT YET GOTTEN OUR- SP FIFTY
FOUR ACROSS THE FINISH LINE
YEAH BUT WE DID MAKE
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS YESTERDAY
WITH THE ASSEMBLY'S PASSAGE OF.
SB THREE FORTY THREE WHICH IS
OUR TRUTH IN LABELING GULF
RECYCLING- MEMBERS CURRENT LAW
SAYS THAT IF YOU CAN'T YOU'RE
NOT ALLOWED TO PUT ON TRUTHFUL
ENVIRONMENTAL- CLAIMS SUCH AS-
EARTH FRIENDLY A RECYCLABLE ON
AN ITEM IF YOU CAN'T. WRITE THE
FACT THE RECYCLABLE ON YOUR
RIGHT AND YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO
PUT THE RECYCLING SYMBOL- ON ON
YOUR ITEM SO THIS. EXTENDS THIS
PROHIBITION TO THE USE OF THE
CHASING ARROW SYMBOL SO THAT IF
A PRODUCT OR PACKAGING IS NOT
TRULY RECYCLABLE THEY CAN'T PUT
THE CHEESE IN YOUR SYMBOL
THERE. THE RECYCLING IS
INCREDIBLY CONFUSING FOR PEOPLE
PEOPLE ARE CONTINUALLY PUTTING
ITEMS INTO THEIR BLUE BINS WITH
RECYCLING SYMBOL ON THEM AND
YET IT'S ACTUALLY MUDDYING THE
WATERS IT'S CONTAMINATING THE
SYSTEM IS MAKING IT MORE
DIFFICULT. FOR THE RECYCLING
SYSTEM TO WORK PROPERLY WHEN
THE REASONS WHY ALL THE MAJOR
PLAYERS IN THE WASTE HAULERS.
ARE CITIES IN CENTER ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS BILL. NOW
I'M COUPLE WHAT ONE THING I
JUST I NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
FOLKS UNDERSTAND QUESTIONS WERE
RAISED ABOUT HOW THIS BILL
HANDLES PLASTIC FILAMENT
INTERACTS WITH ARE ARE SINGLE
USE- BAG BAN REUSABLE PLASTIC
BAG LAWS LET ME BE REALLY CLEAR
THIS BILL DOES NOT SHUT DOWN
VOLUNTARY STORE TAKE BACK
PROGRAMS IT DOESN'T PREVENT
BECAUSE CONSUMERS FROM
RETURNING PLASTIC BAGS WERE
STORED DROP OFF IS AVAILABLE
BUT MUCH MORE NEES TO BE DONE
TO IMPROVE PLASTIC FILM
COLLECTION AND I AM COMMITTED
TO LEADING AND WORKING WITH.
THE FILM- SECTOR TO INCREASE
THE AMOUNT OF FILM COLLECTED
AND RECYCLED. SO WITH THAT-
THIS IS ULTIMATELY A TRUTH IN
ADVERTISING BILL- IT WILL
ENSURE THAT- THAT THEY WILL END
CONSUMER CONFUSION ABOUT WHAT
IS RECYCLABLE IMPROVE RECYCLING
EFFICIENCY REDUCE CONTAMINATION
AND ULTIMATELY COSTS. FOR OUR
RATEPAYERS. AND WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SENATOR GLACIER THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS JUST BRIEFLY
I WANT TO COMMEND- THE AUTHOR
OF AD FOR HIS LEADERSHIP AND
PERSISTENCE IN THIS SPACE- YEAH
IT IS. THERE'S A LOT MORE THAT
STILL NEEDS TO BE DONE- HE AND
I. KNOW THAT- PLASTICS HAVE
BEEN INCREDIBLE CONVENIENCE
BUT- IT'S IN IN MANY WAYS IT'S
A IT'S A- THE ROCKY HORROR
PICTURE SHOW FOR OUR
ENVIRONMENT AND FOR OUR WORLD.
SO WE HAVE TO- FIND WAYS TO
PARTNER WITH THE INDUSTRY. TO
MOVE THEM ALONG AND THE
DIRECTION- THAT WE KNOW IS
NECESSARY FOR OUR OUR PLANET
AND OUR- AND OUR GOOD HEALTH
WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY
ASTRONAUT. IS THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SAYING
MAN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS BAIT.
BACKER ALL RIGHT FORTUS
BRADFORD I HAVE A HYPERTENSIVE
I DALLY. GOD I TORONTO I ADMIN
GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE HI GROVE.
HERTZBERG HI I WAS SO. HI HER
TADO I JONES NO KEN WALKER. I
LAYERED I LLEVA I LIVE ALONE I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S NO MAN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO A SHOW OF
BOTH. NO PAN HI PERSON TINA I
ROTH FIVE RUBIO FIVE SKINNER. I
STERN I'M BURKE ALL RIGHT I
WORK OUT SKI I CLEANER I WILL
KNOW PLEASE CALL THE OB TO
MEMBERS. ATKINS. EIGHT FOR JUST.
SALLY I COMMEND GROWTH. STERN.
FIVE TWENTY EIGHT. HIGH GROWTH
NO. THE BATES NOW. ANYONE ELSE.
FIVE TWENTY EIGHT NO SEVEN
DECEMBER THE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. WE GOT A FILE
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY NINE SENATOR
DIED. HE IS PREPARED PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL THREE EIGHTY
NINE BY SENATOR DODD AN ACT
RELATING TO ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES
SENATOR DODD YES MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS AS P. THREE
EIGHTY NINE THE COCKTAILS TO GO
BILL IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
SOME MOBILE PINE THAT THIS BILL
IS ANYTHING GOES BUT I WILL
TELL YOU I WANT TO BE VERY
CLEAR NOTHING IN THIS BILL-
AFFECTS ANY CURRENT PRIVILEGES
ENJOYED BY WINE AND BEER. IN
THIS BILL IS ALSO TAKEN MANY
AMENDMENTS TO NARROW THE SCOPE
OF THE BILL ADDING ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS AS WELL AS A FIVE
YEAR SUNSET THE SCHOOLS RECEIVE
NO NO VOTES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SENATOR
ALAN. TAKE A QUESTION FOR THE
AUTHOR WILL YOU ACCEPT THE
QUESTION CENTERED ON. SURE I'M
COULD YOU JUST GIVE US A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING ABOUT HOW I KNOW
I'M I'M MORE IN THE STATE MADE
ME TURN INTO A YOU KNOW THE
KIDS OFF OF A FATHER YOU KNOW
LIKE THAT THIS COULD BECOME A
REAL A REAL PROBLEM WITH ALL
THIS ALCOHOL CONSUMPTION CAN
YOU TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE
MEASURES ARE TAKEN TO ENSURE
THAT- THIS IS GOING TO BE
RESPONSIBLY APPLIED. YEAH. UP
ALL DRESS UP MY CLOTHES VERY
GOOD THE MAIN REASON WE ASK
YOUR I HAVE A. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE- SEEING
SEEING NINE MEMBERS THIS ITEM
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION. TO
USING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
SAYINGNINE ICE THIRTY SEVEN NO
ZERO THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED AND MOVING ON TO
A FILE ITEM NUMBER FORTY
SENATOR ALAN. HE IS NOT READY
BUT HE WILL BE. MADAM SECRETAY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL FOUR
THIRTY THREE BY SENATOR ALAN AN
ACT RELATING TO COASTAL
RESOURCES. SENATOR ALAN THE
FOURS YEARS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT MEASURE
THAT WILL IMPROVE THE COASTAL
COMMISSION'S ABILITY TO
IMPLEMENT AND ENFORCE THE
COASTAL ACT- YOUR FOLKS MAY
REMEMBER THE PROTON RAN A BILL.
TO ENSURE THAT- THAT THE
COASTAL ACT CAN BE ENFORCED BY
THE COASTAL COMMISSION ON LAND
ON ON ACCESS- QUESTIONS WHERE
WE'RE NOW MAKING SURE THAT-
THAT THIS BILL BUILDS ON LIKE
ON THE COMMISSION'S EXISTING
PROVEN PROCESSES WORK SO WELL
FOR ACCESS VIOLATIONS TO ENSURE
THAT THE- COMMISSION TO PROTECT
ALL COASTAL RESOURCES INTO THE
COASTAL ACT. THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION IT'S RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND RESPECT
FOR US FROM A BOOK. IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEAMAN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA HI AT KINS
EIGHT. BACKER I PORCHES
BRADFORD I HAVE A HYPERTENSIVE
I DALLY. DOT I TORONTO HI ADNAN
GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE I GROW.
HERTZBERG I WENT SO I HER TADO
I JONES. I CAN LONGER I LAYERED
I LLEVA I THE MOON HI WIRE I
MELINDA'S I MEN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. A TROUBLED HI PAM I
FOURTEEN TINA I BROUGHT. I
REVIEW FIVE SCANNER. FIVE STERN
BERGER ALL RIGHT HI FORECASTING
I WINNER I WILL. PLEASE CALL
THE OB TO MEMBERS. ATKINS EIGHT
I FORTUS. DALLY EGGMAN GROVE.
NIELSEN STERN WELL. FIVE THIRTY
TWO KNOWS ZERO. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
FORTY ONE SENATOR WIENER IS
PREPARED PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR WIENER AN ACT RELATING
TO HOUSING CENTER WINNER THE
FIRST YEARS. I THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT CALLER JUST THREW FOR
SEVENTY EIGHT IS BACK CONSTANT
CURRENCY THE BILL ADDRESSES
ADDRESSES RESTRICTIVE- FLOOR
AREA RATIOS A LOT SIZE
REQUIREMENTS. TO ENSURE THAT
THERE IS TRUTH IN OUR ZONING
LAWS MISTAKEN IF SOMEONE WERE
TECHNICAL AND NON SUBSTANTIVE-
THE BILL RECEIVED FIFTY SIX
VOTES- AND ON THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR IT WAS A HAPPY DAY- LIKE
A PERFORMANCE OF KINKY BOOTS.
RESPECT FASTER I OR- THIS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SAYING NONE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA. ADKINS
BASE. BACKER I PORCHES NO
BRADFORD I HAVE THE OTHER BY
HYPERTENSIVE HI DOLLY. I DON I
TORONTO I EGGMAN. GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE I GROSS NO
HERTZBERG I WAS SO I HER TADO I
JONES. I CAN LONGER. I LAYERED
I LABOR I THE MON. MCGUIRE I
MELINDA'S NO MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN I A SHOW OF BOTH. NO
PAM HI FORTUNE TINO. RALPH I
RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN AMBERG
HI I LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER. I
WILL NO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ARCHULETA I AT KINS
BASE NO EGGMAN LIMONEIRA.
FORTUNE TINO. STERN. FIVE
TWENTY NINE NO SIX THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS ARE CONCURRED IN MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER FORTY
TWO SENATOR RUBIO. SHE IS
PREPARED. PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR RUBIO AN ACT RELATING
TO TEACHER CREDENTIALING
SENATOR RUBIO THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE SENATE I RISE TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT
WHICH IS BACK IN CONCURRENCE
AND THIS BILL WILL PRESERVE
CALIFORNIA'S HIGH STANDARDS FOR
TEACHER PREPARATION AND
INCREASE TEACHER DIVERSITY ALL
WHILE PREPARING EDUCATORS TO
EFFECTIVELY TEACH READING
COMPREHENSION AND MEETING THE
NEEDS OF ALL CALIFORNIANS
STUDENTS ARE SENTIMENTS MAKE
CONFORMING CHANGES TO AVOID
CAPTURING ISSUES WITH. EIGHTY
ONE THIRTY AND EIGHTY THREE
TWENTY THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND HAS NO
NOBLE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR IPHONE THANK YOU. IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. SENATOR NIELSEN. THE
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR IF I
MAY SENATOR RUBIO YOU ACCEPT
QUESTION. AND SHE WILL THE
SEARCH THEM MEANING THERE'S A
SECOND PART OF THIS THAT WOULD
GET RID OF THE RVCA READING
INSTRUCTION COMPETENCE THAT
THAT TEST WILL NO LONGER BE.
NECESSARY TO BE ASSED BY
TEACHERS POST TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE IS THAT CORRECT. CURRENTLY
WE'RE WORKING ON THE
REPLACEMENT SO IT'S NOT GOING
TO GO AWAY THERE'S ALWAYS GOING
TO BE A TEST UNTIL- THE
COMMISSION IS ABLE TO CREATE
ONE THAT'S MORE UP TO DATE THE
REASON THIS CAME ABOUT IS THAT
WE'VE TRANSITIONED FROM. WHAT
WE USED TO BE THE CALIFORNIA
STATE STANDARDS TO NOW A COMMON
CORE WHICH IS COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT- HOW WE DO THINGS IN
THE CLASSROOM SOLD A NEW
UPDATED VERSION WILL SATISFY
THE CHANGES IN THE CURRICULUM
AN ADVIL PM. AND PLEASE SO
AGAIN THE TEST DOES NOT GO AWAY
UNTIL THE NEW ONE IS CREATED SO
THERE WILL BE NO CAP AND WHAT
TEACHERS HAVE TO LEARN IMPROVE
THEIR COMPETENCY WITH. WELL I
I'M NOT GOING TO OBJECT TO THE-
SEPARATELY BUT I'M- GONNA LAY
OFF OF THIS VOTE. MY CONCERN IS
WE HAVE THE WORST MATH AND
READING SCORES IN AMERICA. IN
CALIFORNIA.AND ANYTHING WE DO
THAT WOULD DIMINISH. OUR
TEACHERS FROM BEING ABLE TO BE
THE HIGHEST. COMPETENCY THAT
COULD BE THAT I DON'T LIKE THAT
NOW I'M NOT SAYING THAT THIS
BILL ACHIEVES THAT BUT LET'S
JUST SAY I'M WORRIED. IT UP
EITHER IT IS THERE ANY OTHER
BAD DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. CNN SENATOR RUBIO
YOU MAY CONCLUDE. THANK YOU AND
I JUST WANTED TO SHARE THAT I
AGREE WITH WHAT YOU JUST STATED
AND I THINK THAT WE NEED TO
TRANSITION AWAY THAT TEACHERS
ACTUALLY HAVE REAL LIFE
EXPERIENCE IN THE CLASSROOM ARE
ABLE TO REALLY BE IN A
CLASSROOM SETTING WITH REAL
LIFE STUDENTS AND ALSO HAVE
MENTORSHIP OPPORTUNITIES. I WAS
THERE ONCE AND I KNOW THAT JUST
MEMORIZING THE TESTS ARE
LEARNING A TEST FROM THE BOOKS
DOESN'T ALWAYS HELP AND I
ALWAYS TELL THIS STORY I HAD A
TEACHER WHO WORK WITH US FOR
SIX MONTHS AFTER SPENDING FOUR
YEARS AT GETTING HER DEGREE AND
GOING THROUGH ALL HER EDUCATION
TO GET HER CREDENTIALS IT TOOK
SIX MONTHS FOR HER TO REALIZE
IT WASN'T FOR HER. AND THE WAY
WE'RE TRANSITIONING THE TEST IS
TO ALLOW TEACHERS TO ACTUALLY
STEP FOOT IN A CLASSROOM WORK
WITH STUDENTS HALF MENTOR
TEACHERS HELP ON AND THEN
DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT IT IS FOR
THEM BECAUSE WE WANT COMPETENT
TEACHERS THAT WANT TO BE IN THE
CLASSROOM WITH THAT. I ASKED
FOR IT I THANK YOU. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I
FACE I BACKER I FORGES I
BRADFORD I HAVE ITEM HI
PROTECTING. HI DALLY HI TODD.
I- AWESOME HI EGGMAN GLAZER
AIKENS OLIVES I GROSS. I HURTS
BERG HI WITH SO I HER TADO I
JONES I CAN LONGER. I LAYERED I
LLEVA I THE MON I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S I MEN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN I WILL GO. I CAN I
FORTUNE TINO. I BROUGHT. FIVE
RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN NUMBER
ALL RIGHT HI MIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER I WILL. HI. FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT NO ZERO. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
FOLLOW NUMBER FORTY THREE
SENATOR HERTZBERG IS PREPARED
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL FIVE
FIFTY TWO BY SENATOR HERTZBERG
AN ACT RELATING TO WATER.
SENATOR HERTZBERG FORGERS THANK
YOU SO MUCH. CALIFORNIA IS
EXPERIENCING THE WORST DROUGHT
ON RECORD FROM TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE TO TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
ESTIMATED TO BE THE DRIEST FOUR
YEAR PERIOD IN THE LAST FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY YEARS I DON'T
SPEND A LOT OF TIME BUT THIS IS
A BIG DEAL IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT. AND SO MORE THAN 75%
OF THE DROUGHT IMPACTED PUBLIC
WATER SYSTEMS WERE SMALL
SERVING A THOUSAND CONNECTIONS
OR FEWER I COME FROM LOS
ANGELES WHERE I HAVE A THOUSAND
CONNECTIONS AND A FEW BLOCKS OF
MY OF MY HOME. THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT ALL OF US
WHETHER WE COME FROM AN URBAN
AREA OR RURAL AREA NEED TO DEAL
WITH THAT DEALS WITH EQUITY AND
JUSTICE IN CALIFORNIA ON
SOMETHING THAT'S SO
FUNDAMENTALLY IMPORTANT. FOR
THIS MEASURE ENHANCES THIS
DROUGHT PLANNING FOR THESE
AREAS AND ALL I CAN SAY IS THAT
THE NUMEROUS CO AUTHORS AND I
WHEN WE COME TO THE CENTRAL
VALLEY WE ARE MET WITH.
ENTHUSIASM AND A SHOUT OF HERE
COMES THE FANTASTIC SCIENCE
REVIVAL. BUT IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THAT.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SAYING THAT MEMBERS ARE SENATOR
NIELSEN MY APOLOGY. MOUNT
PLEASANT LANE DOWN THE CENTER I
AM A LITTLE BIT WARY OF THIS
BILL. AS ONE WHO REPRESENTS SO
MANY SMALL JURISDICTIONS THE
INTERFACE THESE PROBLEMS. WE
UNDERSTAND WE HAVE A PROBLEM IN.
A FORM WITH THE DROUGHT. WE
LONG HAVE. BUT WE SQUANDER
OPPORTUNITIES TO PROVIDE MORE
WATER. THROUGH A BOND IT'S
ALREADY BEEN PASSED SEVEN YEARS
AGO TO BUILD LARGE SURFACE
STORAGE. BUT WE CAN'T GET THAT
DONE WHY ALL WE HAVE THESE
LITTLE REVIEWS AND PERMITTING
SORT OF IMPEDED THAT. THESE
LITTLE JURISDICTIONS. THEY'RE
IN TROUBLE. SOME OF US
REPRESENT AREAS WHERE WE'RE
HAVING TO HELP THEM FIND WATER
TO BE HAULED OUT SIMPLY THAT
THEY CAN HAVE SOMETHINGTO
DRINK IT'S NOT EVEN ABOUT
WASHING YOUR CLOTHES. YEAH WE
DO HAVE A PROBLEM HERE. BUT I'M
JUST A LITTLE BIT WARY. ABOUT
HAVING MORE GOVERNMENT CONTROL
NOW WHAT DO I MEAN BY THAT. WE
ALREADY HAVE THE SUSTAINABLE
GROUNDWATER MANAGEMENT
LEGISLATION AND EACH COUNTY HAS
TO HAVE ITS OWN SUSTAINABLE
GROUNDWATER MANAGEMENT DISTRICT
AND ITS OWN PLANTS. AND SOME OF
THE SMALL DISTRICTS. THOUSAND
OR LESS. THEY'RE GOING TO BE
REQUIRED TO COME UP WITH PLANS.
WHO'S GOING TO PAY FOR THAT.
WHO'S GOING TO BE
TECHNOLOGICALLY CAPABLE. OF
COMING UP FOR THOSE PLANS THESE
THINGS HAVE TO BE THOUGHT
THROUGH BECAUSE IT'S JUST NOT
REALLY EASY TO DO WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE CARE OF THE
SMALL. JURISDICTIONS IT NEEDS
TO BE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SAYING
NONE SENATOR HERTZBERG YOU MAY
CONCLUDE. I JUST WANTED TO
ADDRESSABLE I BELIEVE THIS
ISSUE OF COST. COLLECT STATE
IMPLEMENTATION OF- AS PART OF
THIS DEBT THE COST HAS BEEN
DEALT WITH I CAN'T DEAL WITH
THAT SPECIFICALLY WILL CIRCLE
BACK WITH SENATOR. THE
IMPORTANT POINT IS THAT. BUT
THIS IS PART OF THE LARGER TASK
FORCE GROUP THAT WE'RE INVOLVED
WITH THAT THAT WAS PART OF OUR
LEGISLATION THAT WE DID EARLIER
AND THIS WAS A RECOMMENDATION
BY THE GDPR'S COUNTY DRUG TASK
FORCE. AND THAT ALL OPPOSITION
WAS WITH THE RECENT AMENDMENTS
ALL OPPOSITIONS BEEN REMOVED SO
TO THE EXTENT OF THOSE WERE IN
DISCUSSIONS WHICH I REMEMBER
THAT THEY WORK THE OPPOSITION
REMOVED AND THIS IS CONSISTENT
WITH THAT WHAT DID YOU ARE IN
THE COUNTY SO I THINK WE
SHOULD. BE TAKING CARE OF US
RELIABLE. MEMBERS THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING THE ANONYMOUS RECALL.
SEEING NONE I THIRTY EIGHT NO%
ZERO. THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED WITH MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER FORTY FOUR
SEVEN MINUTE READ. YES SIR MY
APOLOGIES- SENATOR THANK YOU IN
A PRISON I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUBMIT A LETTER TO
THE JOURNAL ON THIS MEASURE WE
JUST TOOK UP SP FIVE FIFTY TWO
THE LETTERS BEEN APPROVED BY
BOTH CAUCUSES AND A COPY AND I
WILL PROVIDE THAT TO THE DESK
ON UNANIMOUS CONSENT. SO
ORDERED. MOVING ON TO FILE IT.
YES IS IBM'S CONSENT YES HI S.
YES THIS IS A NIGHT THIS. THIS
IS AN ITEM FOR UNANIMOUS
CONSENT IS- RULE TO ALLOW
SENATOR HERTZBERG TO- PROVIDE A
LETTER TO THE FILE. SAYING NO
OBJECTION. HIGHS THIRTY EIGHT
NO ZERO. MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER FORTY FOUR SENATOR
BRADFORD IS PREPARED PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL FIVE SIXTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR BRADFORD AN
ACT RELATING TO OF CRIMINAL
PROCEDURE SENATOR BRADFORD
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT S. B.
FIVE SIX SEVEN IS BROCK ON
CONCURRENCE. SP FIVE SIX SEVEN
CREATES A PRESUMPTION OF
SENTENCING JUDGMENT NOT TO SEAT
THE MIDDLE TERM UNLESS THERE IS
CLEAR AND SUPPORTING
AGGRAVATING CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
JUSTIFY IMPOSING THE HIGHER
TERM SP FIVE SIX SEVEN PROVIDES
THAT WHEN. HI TERMS ARE IMPOSED
THE FACTS SUPPORTING THAT
AGGRAVATING AGGRAVATION MUST BE
STIPULATED BY THE DEFENDER OR
SUBMITTED TO THE JURY AND
PROVEN BEYOND REASONABLE DOUBT
OR FOUND BY THE COURT IN A
BENCH TRIAL IN THE INSTANCE
WHERE THERE WAS NO JURY
INVOLVED. A SEMI AMENDMENTS
ADDS CONFORMING LANGUAGE TO THE
ENHANCEMENT STATUTE. WHICH IS
SUNSETTING AT THE END OF THIS
YEAR IT CLARIFIES THE
BIFURCATION STANDARDS AND
DOUBLE JOINS THIS BO WITH AB
FIFTEEN FORTY AND EIGHTY ONE
TWENTY FOUR. WITHOUT THIS
MEASURE CURRENT LAW WITH SUNSET
AT THE END OF THE YEAR. THE
PROPER PROCESS FOR SYNCING
WOULD REVERT TO A LAW THAT WAS
IN PLACE BEFORE TWENTY TWENTY
NINE FOR WHICH THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT HAS FOUND TO BE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL ON THE BASIS
THAT FACTS HAVE TO BE PRESENTED
TO A JURY IMPROVE. PROVEN AGAIN
BEYOND A REASONABLE DOUBT. THE
IS THAT JUDGES ARE LOW TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO INTERPRET
CUNNINGHAM CASE ABSENCE OUR
GUIDANCE AND THIS CAUSES A LOT
OF CONFUSION AND CHAOS WE HAVE
AN IMPROVEMENT TO THE SINCE
SINCE IT'S IN PROCESS IN THIS
BILL AND IT CONFORMS TO THE
JUDICIAL OPINION THAT. ABOUT
RIGHTS THE PEOPLE SHOULD HAVE
BEFORE WE PUT THEM IN JAIL FOR
LONG PERIODS OF TIME YOU SEE
THOSE PEOPLE AS STATED EARLIER
ARE BLACK AND BROWN AND WHEN
THESE HIGHER SINCE INSTANCE ARM
PULLS MORE SO THAN. ON OUR PART
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A VOTE FOR SP FIVE SIX SEVEN
BECAUSE- AIN'T EASY BUT
SOMEBODY HAS TO DO IT MMHM.
SENATOR NELSON. LADIES AND DOWN
THE SENATE YOU KNOW HAVE BEEN A
CRIMINALIST AND EASY BUT WE
DON'T SEEM TO HAVE ANY PROBLEM
FINDING INDIVIDUALS TO SO
INDULGE IN THEIR LIVES. AND
AGAIN THIS IS A PART OF A- THEN
ATTEMPT AND I HOPE IT'S ONLY
GOING TO BE AN ATTEMPT ON A
FULL SUCCESS. IN MAKING IT
HARDER. FOR THE POSITION A
GREATER PUNISHMENTS FOR
JUSTIFIED KIND OF BEHAVIOR
BEYOND A REASONABLE DOUBT NOW.
THAT'S A PRETTY HIGH STANDARD.
IN I DON'T KNOW THAT WE NEED TO
HAVE THAT KIND OF STANDARD.
TRULY IF YOU'RE GONNA OPPOSE
THE IMPOSITION OF A LOCAL
MIDDLE AND MAXIMUM TERM LONG
BEEN STANDING. IN OUR CODES
WELL THE YEARS AND IT DOES GIVE
THE DISCRETION. FOR THOSE IN
CRIMINAL SENTENCING. I CALL IT
PROGRESSIVE PREDICTABLE
CONSEQUENCES MEETING IF YOU DO
BETTER. THE CONSEQUENCES GET
BETTER YOU DO WORSE THE
CONSEQUENCES GET WORSE THAT'S
JUST A SIMPLE. LIFE LESSON I
BELIEVE. BUT AGAIN BACK TO THE
MERITS OR DEMERITS OF THE BILL
I WOULD URGE A NO VOTE THERE IS
NO QUESTION THAT THIS WILL BE
MAKING IT MORE DIFFICULT. FOR
THE JUDICIAL SYSTEM. TO IMPOSE
THE OPERATOR. AND I'D ARGUE
VOCIFEROUSLY. THERE ARE PLENTY
OF CRUNCH IN CRIMINAL
ACTIVITIES THAT JUSTIFY THE
UPPER TURN. WE SHOULD NOT MAKE
IT EASIER. DID NOT GET THE
PRINTER. IS THERE FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. CENTRE BRADFORD YOU MAY
CONCLUDE THANK YOU- WHEN
PRESIDENT THIS DOESN'T CHANGE
ANYTHING IT JUST REQUIRES THAT
THE CIRCUMSTANCES THE EVIDENCE
SUPPORTS THE HIGHER TERM JUDGE
DEAL CAN IMPOSE THE HIGH TERM
BUT WE'RE ASKING THAT YOU START
WITH THE MINIMUM TURN AGAIN IF
YOU EVER WERE TO VISIT- COURT
ROOM AND YOU SEE BLACK AND
BROWN PEOPLE AND THEY'RE
THEY'RE THE ONES WHO ARE
USUALLY GETTING THE HIGHER
SENTENCES. IT IS NOT OUR OTHER
BROTHERS AND SISTERS IN
INFLUENT NEIGHBORHOODS WHERE
THEY GET AWAY WITH MURDER MUCH
OF THE TIME THESE ARE BLACK AND
BROWN PEOPLE SIMPLY BECAUSE
THEY LIVE IN THE WRONG
NEIGHBORHOOD AWARE WITH THE
WRONG GROUP AND THEY WERE
IMPOSED- THEY IMPOSE A HIGHER
SENTENCE ALL THE TIME. ON TO
QUOTE A FAMOUS PHILOSOPHER JG
MADELINE WOMEN LIVE BUT FACTS
DON'T THE FACTS SPEAK FOR
ITSELF THESE HIGHER SENTENCES.
ARE ALWAYS IMPOSE ON BLACK AND
BROWN PEOPLE. A TRACTOR RIVAL.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I BASE NO
BACKER. ALL RIGHT FORGES NO
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM I
CORTESE I DALLY NO GOD. I
TORONTO I EGGMAN LASER EYE
CONSOLIDATES I GROW NO
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HI HER TADO.
JONES NO CAN LONGER I LAYERED I
LABOR I THE MON I REQUIRE HI
MELINDA'S NO MEN FIVE NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. NO A CHOKE NO PAM HI
PORTS IN CHINO I. ROSS I RUBIO.
FIVE SKINNER I STERN I'M BURKE
HI HI FORECASTING HI WINNER I
WILL. NO PLEASE CALL THE OB TO
MEMBERS. ALAN I. EGGMAN FURTADO
NO. STERN. FIVE TWENTY EIGHT
KNOWS TEN THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS ARE GONNA MOVE- YEAH.
WE WILL GO AHEAD AND TAKE UP A
FILE ITEM NUMBER FORTY FIVE
SENATOR BAKER. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL FIVE
NINETY SIX BY SENATOR BACKER IN
ACTION RELATING TO GREENHOUSE
GASES CENTER RECORD THANK YOU
MEMBERS AS DETAILED MY
FORTHCOMING MEMOIR THE KING AND
I CARBON EMISSIONS FROM CEMENT
OR TRULY A GLOBAL ISSUE IN FACT
70% OF ALL GLOBAL CARBON
EMISSIONS SORRY 7% OF ALL
GLOBAL CARBON EMISSIONS ARE
FROM CEMENT AND CONCRETE. THIS
BILL IS ABOUT GETTING THE
ESTIMATE INTRODUCE ZERO BY
TWENTY FORTY FIVE AN ASSEMBLY
METHODS MAKE IT CLEAR THE CARB
CAN ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT THE
STRATEGY NOT JUST HELPED DESIGN
IT I'M PROUD THAT WE'VE GOT
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT SO FAR AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE VOTE.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. CENTER
GROVE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE IN OPPOSITION
BECAUSE YESTERDAY IT WAS ABOUT
LAWN MOWERS AND WEED EATERS
TODAY IT'S ABOUT CONCRETE AND
CEMENT AND MARK MY WORDS
COLLIES SPECIFICALLY THE
MAJORITY LEADER AND MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTEE TOMORROW
IT'S GOING TO BE ABOUT HAIR
SPRAY. IS THERE FOR ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. THAT
WOULD BE A DISASTER SENATOR
JONES. SENATOR JONES. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT- THE AUTHORS
STATED IN IT AND IS OPENING
COMMENTS THAT 7% OF THE GLOBAL
EMISSIONS COMES FROM CEMENT-
PRODUCTION I BELIEVE IS. I WAS
GOING TO THAT HOUSE I'M
WONDERING IF I COULD ASK THE-
THE AUTHOR QUESTION PLEASE ON
THAT NUMBER QUESTION TO THE
AUTHOR. SURE THANK YOU HE SAID
TO GIVE 7% IS THE GLOBAL NUMBER.
DO WE HAVE A KIND OF A NUMBER
QUANTIFIED FOR CALIFORNIA AND-
WHAT'S CALIFORNIA'S SEMEN
PRODUCTION REGARDING THE GLOBAL
PERCENTAGE- IN TERMS OF OUR IF
YOU LOOK AT ALL OF OUR
GREENHOUSE GASES THAT CEMENT IS
DEAR 2% OF CALIFORNIA'S
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. 32%
ON THE ON THE- HI CALIFORNIA
MISSIONS AND THEN EXTRAPOLATE
THAT GLOBALLY YOU KNOW THAT
NUMBER OBVIOUSLY COMES DOWN
QUITE A BIT SMALLER- MEMBERS
WITH THE POINT I'M TRYING TO
MAKE HERE IS. CALIFORNIA HAS
DONE A REAT JOB OF LOWERING
OUR EMISSIONS WE REALLY HAVE
AND THEN I REALLY DO APPLAUD
THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD. ADVANCEMENTS OVER THE
LAST TWENTY THIRTY FORTY YEARS
I REMEMBER IN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
MOVING TO CALIFORNIA TO SAN
DIEGO SPECIFICALLY FROM
COLORADO AND- HAVING SEX NEVER
HAVING HAD A SMOG DAY IN
COLORADO I DON'T WHAT THAT WAS-
BUT WE HAD A COUPLE OF THEM.
WHEN I WAS IN ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL- YOU KNOW BACK IN THE
EIGHTIES. AND YOU KNOW WE'VE
GOT OUR AIR QUALITY INTO A
PRETTY GOOD PLACE IN CALIFORNIA
AND WHAT I'M AFRAID OF IS WE'RE
WE'RE JUST NOW ENTERING INTO
THE LAW OF DIMINISHING RETURNS.
WHERE WE'RE JUST YOU KNOW KINDA.
HACKING AT THE EDGES ON THIS
THING 2% YOU KNOW IT IS SO WHAT
THAT TELLS ME IS IF WE CUT ALL
OF CALIFORNIA'S EMISSIONS ON
CEMENT. THAT WOULD LOWER
CALIFORNIA'S EMISSIONS BY TWO
PERCENT. BUT WHAT IMPACT DOES
THAT REALLY MAKE IT GLOBALLY.
AND I THINK AT SOME POINT TIME
WE'VE GOT TO GET TO THE POINT
HERE WERE WERE PASSING COMMON
SENSE REGULATIONS ON AIR
EMISSIONS- AND AS OUR-
COLLEAGUE FROM BAKERSFIELD
POINTED OUT YESTERDAY LAWN
MOWERS AND EDGERS AND- AND
SUCH- THAT'S GONNA MAKE. NO
IMPACT GLOBALLY I BELIEVE THAT
THIS BILL ALSO GLOBALLY- WERE
WERE PASSED THE LAW OF
DIMINISHING RETURNS AND I ASK
FOR NO VOTE. SENATOR I KASKI.
RISE IN SUPPORT R. AS IN
SUPPORT OF SP FIVE FIVE NINE
SIX AND THIS IS NOT A STORY OF
MY FAIR CEMENT COMPANY OR MY
FAIR LADY OR MY FAIR MY FOR
ANYTHING IT'S REALLY A STORY
ABOUT TECHNOLOGY THE GENTLEMAN
FROM SANTEE IS RIGHT I MEAN
IT'S NOT THAT BIG OF A CHUNK OF
OUR PART OF THE GLOBAL
ADMISSIONS AND IT'S NOT THAT
BIG A CHUNK OF THE MISSIONS-
INTERNATIONALLY PUT IT IS IT IS
A CHUNK AND WHAT CALIFORNIA HAS
TO OFFER. IN THE DEBATE ON
GREENHOUSE GASES IS OUR
TECHNOLOGY CHANGES WE KNOW THE
AUTHOR HAS- THE CEMENT FACILITY
IS SORT OF AN ART BETWEEN MEYER
AND HIS HERE THAT HAS COME TO
ALTERNATIVES TO BURNING COAL IN
ORDER TO GET THE FIRE SO HOT TO
MAKE THE CEMENT AND THIS IS
WHAT WE BRING TO THE GLOBAL
STAGES BY FORCING THE CITY BY
MOVING THIS IN THIS AREA AND
THE TECHNOLOGY CHANGES WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE AN ADDITION
THAT'S COULD BE MADE TO OTHER
AREAS THROUGHOUT THE WORLD THAT
WILL HELP THEM. AND YOU KNOW 7%
27% IT ACTUALLY WORKS OUT I
URGE IN SUPPORT OF TECHNOLOGY
IN IN SUPPORT OF THIS- STEP
FORWARD WE- CONCURRENTLY
ASSEMBLY. AMENDMENTS AND SP
FIVE. NO SIX. ANY FURTHER TO
AND DEBATE YES SENATOR LAN
MEMBERS WERE TALKING
CONCURRENCE I THINK THAT THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS-
ANOTHER INMATE MAKE THIS BILL
LESS ONEROUS TO INDUSTRY. FIVE
IN WAYS THAT I THINK A DRESS
SOME OF THE CONCERNS OF BEEN
RAISED BY HER FRIENDS ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE AISLE SO I
GUESS MY QUESTION IS YOU KNOW
IT SEEMS LIKE. UNLIKE THE
CUSTOMERS IN SWEENEY TODD THERE
VIA THE BILL GOT A LITTLE HAIR
CUT BUT NOT MURDER IF THE BILL
WAS STILL KEPT INTACT HI CAN
YOU SPEAK A LITTLE BIT TO THE
AMENDMENTS- SENATOR- THAT
ADDRESS SOME OF THE CONCERNS
HAVE BEEN RAISED BY OUR FRIENDS
IN THIS AREA I'M GONNA LET HIM
DO THAT BUT BEFORE WE GET THERE
HE CAN DO IT IN HIS CLOTHES IF
YOU DON'T MIND ACTED. LIKE
CALLING A CENTER LABOR. THANK
YOU MADAM FOR. I DON'T USUALLY
SPEAK ON CONCURRENCE BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO. AND I
ALREADY SUPPORTED THE BILL I'LL
BE SUPPORTING IT AGAIN TODAY
BUT I JUST REMIND PEOPLE. THAT
EVERYTHING IS CUMULATIVE. WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT 2% FOR. CONCRETE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT LAWN MOWERS
AND THE GAS LEAF BLOWERS.
THEY'RE NOT ONE OFFS THEY'RE
CUMULATIVE AND WHEN YOU PUT
THEM ALL TOGETHER. THAT CREATES
A BIGGER PROBLEM. ONE STUDY
THAT I READ TALKED ABOUT. LAWN
MOWERS GAS FLOWS WHAT NOT. ALL
OF THEM COMBINED IN CALIFORNIA
ACTUALLY. CREATE MORE
GREENHOUSE GASES THAN CARS ON
THE ROAD. I DON'T HAVE THE
STADIUM FROM ME I APOLOGIZE FOR
THAT. AND I ALSO WANT TO SAY
THE AIR QUALITY IN CALIFORNIA
IN SOME PARTS OF CALIFORNIA IS
BETTER. PLEASE COME TO THE
INLAND EMPIRE WHERE WE HAVE THE
HIGHEST. RATES AND WHEN I WAS A
YOUNG CHILD WITH SMOG DAYS WE
COULDN'T SEE THE MOUNTAINS. WE
CAN SEE THE MOUNTAINS NOW. BUT
GUESS WHAT THE PARTICULATES ARE
SMALLER AND THE AIR QUALITY IS
JUST AS BAD. SO WE HAVE A LOT
OF WORK TO DO. BUT I'LL JUST
REMIND PEOPLE. CUMULATIVE IT'S
NOT ABOUT THIS AND THIS IT'S
ABOUT ALL OF IT. TOGETHER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE.
SENATOR DOLLY. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I JONES WAS
GOING TO SPEAK ON THIS BILL BUT
I THINK WE'RE REALLY MISSING
THE POINT WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
THE MISSIONS WE TALKED ABOUT
LAWN MOWERS AND WEED EATERS.
BUILDING ELECTRIC. SEMI TRUCKS.
WE NEED TO GO INTO THE WOODS.
THEY'RE ON FIRE RIGHT NOW. AND
THE IMPACTS THAT WE MAKE ARE
SMALL IN THIS AREA WITH WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT 2% OF
CALIFORNIA'S EMISSIONS. MAKING
CONCRETE SOMETHING WE NEED
EVERY DAY BUT WE ALSO NEED
WATERSHEDS WE ALSO NEED. TREES
THAT ACTUALLY SEQUESTER CARBON
THAT AREN'T DEAD AND SO. I
THINK THE POLICIES THAT COME
OUT HERE THE PROBLEM. WE DON'T
FOCUS ON THE AREA WHERE WE CAN
REALLY MAKE A DIFFERENCE. WHICH
IS BY REDUCING WILDFIRE. YOU
WERE TALKING ABOUT AIR QUALITY
FOR THE LAST. TWO AND A HALF
MONTHS. WE'VE SEEN IT EVEN HRE
IN SACRAMENTO THERE QUALITIES
NOT FROM CARS AND TRUCKS AND
CONCRETE PLANTS. IT'S FROM THE
FOREST BURNING DOWN. MILLIONS
ARE MILLIONS OF ACRES IT'S JUST
INCREDIBLE THAT WE CONTINUE TO
REGULATE DRIVE THE COST OF
LIVING UP IN CALIFORNIA TO HELP
OUR AIR QUALITY. SOMEWHAT I
GUESS BE BETTER WHEN WE DON'T.
TALK ABOUT THE REAL EMISSION
PROBLEM AND THE REAL EMISSION
PROBLEM IS. THE FOREST SO FOR
THOSE REASONS I'M NOT GOING TO
BE VOTING FOR THIS BILL A
MEMBER VOTING AGAINST IT AGAIN
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T DO ANYTHING
IN THE BIG PICTURE BIG PICTURE
OF ACTUALLY CHANGING. GLOBAL
WARMING. SENATOR JONES. MADAM
PRESIDENT I JUST WANTED TO
RESPOND QUICKLY BRIEFLY TO OUR
CALLING FROM THE INLAND EMPIRE
AND- BEAVER WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
CUMULATIVE A FAX IN THAT THAT
IS TRUE IN A BEATLE MANIA IS
CUMULATIVE ALSO A COLLECTION OF
PEOPLE EXCITED ABOUT- THE
BEATLES I SUPPOSE- BUT ALSO-
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM BEAVER-
REALLY REALLY AND CONTINUOUSLY
ALPINE'S. THE IMPACTS OF AIR
QUALITY FROM THESE CONTINUED
FOREST FIRES IN CALIFORNIA AND-
YOU KNOW WHAT I KNOW AND A LOT
OF OUR CONVERSATIONS PRIVATELY
OR IN YOU KNOW WHEN WE'RE
MEETING WITH FOLKS WE TALK
ABOUT THAT AND IT SEEMS TO BE A
GENERAL ATTITUDE OF THE
LEGISLATURE THAT WORKERS WERE
COGNITIVE. OF THESE FOREST
FIRES AND THE IMPACT IT. OTHER
THAN OUR OUR OUR- CALLING FROM
BEAVER AND- I DON'T HEAR THE
PASSION BEHIND THAT THAT SOME
OF US. DISPLAYED PRIVATELY IN
OFF THE FLOOR. HELLO I
REPRESENT A DISTRICT IT'S- HAS
A LOT OF FOREST AND- STATE
PARKS AND FEDERAL. PART OF
FOREST LANDS THAT ARE CLOSED AT
THE FROM THE FEDERAL. PARKS
RIGHT NOW ARE CLOSED. TO MOVE
THOSE RESOURCES FROM SAN DIEGO
TO THE PARTS IN CALIFORNIA
WHERE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
NEEDS IN THE FIGHT THESE FOREST
FIRES WE'VE GOT TO TAKE THIS
SERIOUS. AND I JUST WANT TO
STAND UP AND SUPPORT ARE
CALLING FROM BEAVERTON NOTE LET
HIM KNOW THAT THERE'S- MORE
THAN JUST HIM ON THIS FLOOR TO
CARE ABOUT THAT THANK YOU.
CENTERMAN THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I WANT TO SEARCH IT
MYSELF WITH THE COMMENTS FROM
MY COLLEAGUE FROM CHINO THIS IS
CUMULATIVE AND WE ARE AT A
UNIQUE TIME RIGHT NOW- WE ARE
FACING A CLIMATE CRISIS AND
MAMMA MIA THIS IS QUITE A
CRISIS THAT WE'RE FACING THE
FUTURE FOR OUR CHILDREN AND
BEYOND- LOOKS DISMAL AND WE
HAVE A VERY LIMITED WINDOW
RIGHT NOW TO TRY TO FIX THINGS
A VERY SHORT TIME TO TRY TO
ADDRESS THIS IS OUR SHOT. AND
WE NEED TO BE FOLLOWING EXAMPLE
OF ALEXANDER HAMILTON AND
SAYING WE'RE NOT THROWING AWAY
OUR SHOT. SIDE SUPPORT THIS
BILL AND I URGE MY COLLEAGUES
TO DO THE SAME. THANK YOU.
THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE- SAYING MAN SENATOR
BAKER YOU MAY CONCLUDE AND THIS
BILL IS ON CONCURRENCE. THANK
YOU OR DO YOU WANT TO MAKE A
FEW POINTS FIRST OF ALL TO THE
POINT BUT MY COLLEAGUE FROM
CHINO IS FIRST AT 7% IS A
MASSIVE AMOUNT. ALL BUILDINGS
IN CALIFORNIA ACCOUNT 412% OF
OUR CARBON EMISSIONS TO LIKE 7%
THAT'S A MASSIVE AMOUNT AND WE
HAVE TO FIND REALLY RESHAPE
EACH ASPECT OF OUR ECONOMY AND
CEMENT HAS BEEN ONE OF THOSE
HARD TO DECARBONISE INDUSTRIES.
AND IT'S A WEIRD PLACE TO MAKE
A STAND BECAUSE INDUSTRIES
ACTUALLY BEEN SUPPORTIVE
INDUSTRY'S BEEN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL FROM THE BEGINNING BECAUSE
THEY WANT TO BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION THEY'D RATHER BE PART
OF THE SOLUTION. IN GETTING TO
ZERO RATHER THAN HAVING
SOMETHING OPPOSED. THE IMPOSED
UPON THEM. TO THEY'VE BEEN
PARTNERS IN THIS.
INITIALIZATION CALIFORNIA IS 1%
OF THE WORLD'S. CARBON
EMISSIONS 1% SO YES EVERYTHING
WE DO HERE MATTERS. BUT WHAT
REALLY MATTERS IS WHAT WE CAN
TO PUT POLICIES IN PLACE IN
CALIFORNIA. THAT COULD BE
EXPORTABLE POLICIES A PLACE IN
CALIFORNIA. THAT ET THE MODEL
FOR THE REST OF WORLD POLICIES
IN CALIFORNIA THAT LIKE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM FREEMAN SAID.
CREATE NEW TECHNOLOGY THAT
DENNIS DEPLOYED IN OTHER AREAS
THAT'S WHEN WE HAVE AN
OUTSIZED. IMPACT AND THAT'S
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN HERE WE
ARE GOING TO CREATE THE
INDUSTRY FOR LOW CARBON
CONCRETE WILL BE BACK NEXT
YEAR. TO MAKE SURE THE
GOVERNMENT IN CALIFORNIA BUYS
THAT LOW CARBON CONCRETE. HELLO
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ALL
ABOUT CREATING SOLUTIONS THEN
THAT CAN SCALE TO THE REST THE
WORLD SO WHAT WE DO HERE.
MATTERS OUR LEADERSHIP IN
CALIFORNIA MATTERS AND THIS IS
PART OF THAT LEADERSHIP AND
IT'S AGAIN SUPPORTED BY
INDUSTRY AND BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. THROUGHOUT THE IT'S
HISTORY I TRY TO SAY LAST YEAR
ON FIRES JUST PERSONALLY I.
VERY FEEL FOR CALLING FROM FROM
BEAVER AND THEIR SHORT MEDIUM
AND LONG TERM SOLUTIONS WE DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN IN THE SHORT
TERM ON THOSE FIRES. IN THE
MEDIUM TERM EVERYTHING WE CAN
IN THE STANDING ON THE CONTROL
BURNS USING TECHNOLOGY. BUT IN
THE LONG TERM IT'S CLIMATE
CHANGE THAT'S WHAT MADE THOSE
FIRES KINDLING TO BURN AND SO
WE HAVE TO COMBAT CLIMATE
CHANGE AND SO WE HAVE TO DO.
AND PLAN FOR THE SHORT MEDIUM
AND LONG TERM AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA I. ATKINS. EIGHT NO
BACKER HI FORGES NO BRADFORD I
HAVE A ADAM I PROTESTING I
DALLY. NO DOG. I TORONTO HI A
COMMON. GLAZER I BEEN SOLID I
GROW. NO HERTZBERG I WAS SO
HYPER TANTO I JONES NO CAM
WALKER I LAYERED I LABOR. HI
THE MON I REQUIRE I MELINDA'S
NO MAN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN. NO A
SHOW OF BOTH NO HAN HI FORTUNE
TINO. I. BROUGHT I REVIEW I
SKINNER. I STERN AMBERG I LIKE
HOW SKI. I WINNER I WILL KNOW
PLEASE CALL THE OB TO MEMBERS.
ATKINS EGGMAN STERN VICE TWENTY
EIGHT KNOWS NINE THESE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO BE TAKING
A LUNCH BREAK RIGHT NOW. YOU
ARE INSTRUCTED TO PICK UP YOUR
LUNCH AND GO TO YOUR OFFICE AND
CONTINUE TO SOCIALLY DISTANCE
WE WILL PROMPTLY RETURN AT ONE
THIRTY. HE RETURNED AT ONE
THIRTY ENJOY YOUR LUNCH.
MEMBERS ARE READY TO START OUR
AFTERNOON SESSION. IF YOU
COULD- PLEASE BE PREPARED.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO-
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
MADAM PRESIDENT I AM DIRECTED
TO INFORM YOUR HONORABLE BODY
THAT THE ASSEMBLY AMENDED AND
ON THIS DAY PASSED AS AMENDED
SENATE BILLS. 1-715-516-2160
FIVE. ONE SIXTY SIX ONE SIXTY
EIGHT ONE SIXTY NINE ONE
SEVENTY ONE AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR HONORABLE BODY TO
CONCURRENCE THAT AMENDMENTS TO
PARKER CHIEF CLERK OF THE
ASSEMBLY ABOVE BILL'S ORDERED
TWO UNFINISHED BUSINESS FILE.
SO ORDERED. WE'RE MOVING BACK
TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION PURSUANT TO
JOINT RULE THIRTY THREE POINT
ONE JOINT RULE SIXTY ONE WILL
BE SUSPENDED TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN SEVENTY SIX TO BE
AMENDED AFTER THE DEADLINE THIS
REQUEST HAS BEEN APPROVED BY
THE RULES COMMITTEE. MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
RULES WILL BE SUSPENDED FOR THE
PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS FOR THE
FOLLOWING MEASURES. SENATE
BILLS. 307-696-7407 SEVEN
EIGHTY THREE AND ASSEMBLY BILL
ELEVEN SEVENTY. UNDER MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS CENTER DRAWS A
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AT
THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
PLEASE MOVE A. B. EIGHT FIVE
SEVEN TO THE INACTIVE FILE.
BANGKO ORDERED. SO ORDERED. ANY
FURTHER MOTIONS OR RESOLUTIONS.
SEEING NONE WE WILL MOVE ON TO.
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING. SENATOR
HERZBERG FOR ALL AMERICANS. HEY
TAKE THAT STARTING WITH THE
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIXTY SEVEN
SENATOR DR SO. SHE IS. WELL NO
FIVE PASS ROUTE WHERE YOU WILL
PASS THAT TEMPORARILY. AND MOVE
ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER. SEVENTY
TWO. WE'RE GONNA PASS THAT
TEMPORARILY AS WELL THAT SAYS
SENATOR SKINNER. A SENATE ARE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTY THREE SENATOR RIGHT
KOWSKI IS PREPARED. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE SIXTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK SILVA AN
ACT RELATING TO HOUSING.
SENATOR REID CASKEY. THANK YOU
MA'AM- PRESIDENT DOES HE KNOW
THE SHELTERS THAT WE'VE
ESTABLISHED FOR HOMELESS PEOPLE
WERE NEVER INTENDED TO SERVE AS
LONG TERM HOUSING UNFORTUNATELY
THE REALITY SET THE HOUSING
CRISIS- AS WE'RE ADDRESSING IT
MANY OF THE SHELTERS ARE
BASICALLY SERVING AS PRIMARY
RESIDENCE FOR UNSHELTERED
CALIFIA FARMS THIS BILL SETS
INSURERS MINIMUM HEALTH AND
SAFETY STANDARDS ARE FOLLOWED
BY SHELTER OPERATORS AND THAT
ALL THE SHELTER RESIDENTS ARE
TREATED WITH. HELLO SOME A
SENSE OF DIGNITY AND RESPECT
THE RESULT YOUR LONG STUDY BY
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ACLU
THAT FOUND SECURED- DEFICITS
AMONG EMERGENCY SHELTERS-
REPORTS OF SEXUAL ABUSE
OVERCROWDING UNHEALTHY
CONDITIONS. THE HIGHLIGHT AT
THE UNSANITARY CONDITIONS IN
THE SHELTER RODENT PROBLEMS BUG
INFESTATION. YOU KNOW BROKEN
TOILETS THE LIST GO ON THIS-
BILL IS A THREAT AS THE STATES-
RESPONSE ARE PART OF A RESPONSE
TO THE HOMELESS CRISIS SINCE
THE STEP IN CORRECTING THE
ISSUES AT THE SHELTERS I HEARD
TONIGHT FROM. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON FILE AND NUMBER SEVENTY
THREE- CENTER WHICH ARE BOTH.
THE PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I
RISE WITH CONCERNS ABOUT
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE SIXTY TWO
ESTABLISHING HOMELESS SHELTERS
IS ALREADY DIFFICULT
FINANCIALLY ADMINISTRATIVELY
AND POLITICALLY WE NEED EVERY
CITY TO TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS IN THEIR
JURISDICTION HOWEVER AT THREE
SIXTY TO CREATE ADDITIONAL
OBSTACLES THAT WILL ADD TO THE
DIFFICULTIES OF CREATING AND
MAINTAINING SHELTER. HOUSING
FOR HOMELESS PEOPLE FURTHER
MORE EIGHTY THREE SIXTY TWO
APPEARS TO COMPLETELY CONFLICT
WITH GOVERNOR CODE SECTION
EIGHTY SIX NINETY EIGHT WHICH
AUTHORIZES STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES TO DECLARE
A SHELTER CRISISIF A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF PERSONS
IN THE JURISDICTION ARE WITHOUT
THE ABILITY TO OBTAIN SHELTER
RESULTING IN A THREAT TO THEIR
HEALTH AND SAFETY. ONE OF MY
CITIES IS CURRENTLY IN THE
PROCESS OF SETTING UP A NEW
SHELTER FOR THIRTY EIGHT
RESIDENTS WERE HOMELESS AFTER
THERE WERE DISPLACED BY A FIRE.
THIS IS DIFFICULT WORK AND WE
SHOULD BE INSTEAD SUPPORTING
EFFORTS THAT MAKE IT EASIER FOR
CITIES TO SET UP THESE
IMPORTANT SERVICES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. THE CENTER NELSON. NOT
A PRIVILEGE ON THE SENATE IF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. FORCED
UPON OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THE
HOMELESS POPULATION IN NO SMALL
MEASURE THE STATE ITSELF IS
pRESPONSIBLE FOR WHAT HAS
INVADED. OUR AREAS THE HOMELESS
POPULATION. AND NOW TO HAVE THE
STATE IMPOSED. NEW RESTRICTIONS
OR DEFINITIONS OF WHAT WOULD
CONSTITUTE A HOUSING. FOR THIS
QUOTE TEMPORARY BUT NOT
PERMANENT POPULATION I THINK
THAT'S A LITTLE BIT BEYOND OUR
PURVIEW. I WOULD URGE A NO VOTE.
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SAYING
NINE CENTER A QUAKE OWSKI YOU
MAY CONCLUDE A VETERAN PRESENCE
THIS IS SERRA THESE ARE MINIMUM
STANDARDS OF HEALTH AND HOW
PEOPLE ARE- TREATED THERE RIGHT
OKAY I DON'T THINK ANYBODY
ANTICIPATED THE MUSHROOMING OF
C. ARE HOMELESS PROBLEMS IN THE
STATE THE LINK THAT IT'S GOING
ON I WOULD URGE THIS IS BASED
ON SOUND. RESEARCH AND
INFORMATION I WOULD URGE IN A
VOTE ON IT. MADAMS PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL- AREA IF I COULD JUST
TO ADVISE AS WELL WE'LL GO
THROUGH THE ROLL CALL ONCE AND
THEN WE'LL PUT IT ON CALL.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALAN.
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS. EIGHT NO
BACKER. PORCHES NO BRADFORD I
HAVE A I DON'T I PROTESTING. I
DALLY NO GOD FIVE TORONTO I
EGGMAN GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE I
DROVE NO HERTZBERG I WAS SO. I
TANTO I JONES NO CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I PLAY A- I LIVE ALONE
I REQUIRE. MELINDA'S NO MAN I
NEWMAN. NIELSEN NO A TROUBLED
NOPE PAM I PORTS AND TINA HI
ROSSFIVE RUBIO FIVE SKINNER.
HI STERN AMBERG. BY CAL SKI I
WINNER I WILL LOOK NOW. SENATOR
REID KASKI MOVES A CALL MOVING
ON TO WE WERE WE- THAT. WE SEE.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVENTY NINE
CENTER GONZALEZ IS PREPARED
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN BY A FAMILY MEMBER TO
AGAR CURRY AN ACT RELATING TO
COMMUNICATIONS AND DECLARING
THEIR INTO THEIR BARRACKS TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY CENTER IN
DALLAS WORDS HERE'S GOOD
AFTERNOON- MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO
PROBABLY PRESENT AT FOURTEEN ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYWOMAN AGUILAR
CURRY- I JUST WANT A THINKER
FIRST AND FOREMOST- FOR HER
PARTNERSHIP IN ENSURING THAT.
AS THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD THAT WE MAKE
MEANINGFUL IMPACTFUL AND BOLD
AND EQUITABLE INVESTMENTS FOR
EVERY CORNER OF OUR STATE AS
PERTAINS TO BROADBAND AT
FOURTEEN WILL DO THE FOLLOWING
IT WILL STABILIZE THE FUNDING
SOURCE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ADVANCE SERVICES FUND BY
EXTENDING THE SUNSET. DATE AND
CURRENT SUR CHARGE FOR AN
ADDITIONAL TEN YEARS AND ENSURE
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS ONGOING
FUNDING FOR THIS VITAL
INFRASTRUCTURE IN OUR STATE
THIS WILL ALSO ALLOW PC TO
PROVIDE LONG TERM FUNDING
GRANTS UNSERVED AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES TO BUILD HIGH SPEED
FIBER INTERNET. NETWORKS
INCLUDING LAST MILE CONNECTIONS
AT MINIMUM SPEEDS OF ONE
HUNDRED MEGABYTES PER SECOND
DOWNLOAD AND TWENTY FIVE
MEGABYTES PER SECOND UPLOAD. AT
FOURTEEN HAS A LARGE AND
DIVERSE COALITION OF. FOR MANY
OF THOSE ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS EDUCATION
ADVOCATES AND MANY MORE I THINK
YOU CAN ASK FOR YOU TO JOIN US
IN VOTING YES ON A. B.
FOURTEEN. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION DEBATE
SENATOR EITHER THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AS CHAIR OF THE
LATINO CAUCUS I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF MAYBE FOURTEEN WHICH IS ONE
OF OUR PRIORITY BILLS TOGETHER
LITERALLY TOGETHER WITH AS
BEFORE WHICH WE- APPROVED OF BY
OUR CENTER FROM LONG BEACH
GONZALEZ. THIS BILL WILL
PRIORITIZE THE DEPLOYMENT OF
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE AND
OUR MOST VULNERABLE AND
UNDERSERVED RURAL AND URBAN
COMMUNITIES WE ALL SAW. THE
VIRAL PICTURE OF TWO YOUNG
GIRLS AT THE- ONSET OF THE
PANDEMIC SITTING OUTSIDE OF A
TACO BELL. THEY DID THIS TO
ACCESS IT'S FREE WIFI SO THEY
COULD COMPLETE THEIR HOME THEIR
SCHOOL WORK. THIS TROUBLED ME
AND I'M SURE MANY OF YOU VERY
MUCH WHY DID THE STUDENTS. WHY
TO ANY STUDENTS HAVE TO GO TO
THESE LENGTHS TO FURTHER THEIR
EDUCATION. ONE DOES NOT ACCESS
ACCESS TO RELIABLE AND
AFFORDABLE BROADBAND IN THOSE
MEN AND WOMEN AND FAMILIES WILL
BE LEFT BEHIND AS THE REST OF
THE STATE CONTINUES TO PROGRESS
FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I VOTE FOR
A. B. FOURTEEN. THANK YOU. IS
THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE THERE IS
ALWAYS YOU MAY CONCLUDE THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS
ANGELES AS WELL AS MANY
COLLEAGUES AS WELL AS YOURSELF
FROM SALINAS- THE SENATOR FROM
HELZBERG AS WELL AS FROM SAN
DIEGO OUR SENATE LEADERSHIP
TEAM ENERGY CONSULTANT SO MANY
FOLKS WERE INVOLVED IN OF THE
PROGRESS THAT WE'VE MADE FOR
BROADBAND FOR ALL AND VERY VERY
PROUD TO- TO SUPPORT THIS TODAY
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASPIRIN I
BUILT. FOR MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA HI ATKINS
EIGHT NO BACKER HI FORGES NO
BRADFORD. I COME BY ADAM I
PROTESTING HI DALLY NO DOT. I
TORONTO I A COMMON GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE HI GROSS NO HURTS
BERG I WEAR SO. I HER TADO.
JONES NO CAN LONGER. I LAYERED
I LLEVA HI THE MON I REQUIRE. I
MELINDA'S NO MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN NO THE TROUBLE. I CAN
HI FORTUNE TINO HI ROTH I RUBIO.
I SKINNER I STERN ON BURKE. BY
CAL SKI FIVE WINNER I WILL. NO.
WE'RE GONNA GO THROUGH THIS-
BILL ONE MORE TIME IT APPEARS
AS IF WE HAVE A HAVE A HAVE A
FULL HOUSE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THE OPTION MEMBERS. ATKINS I. I
COMMEND HER TADO. STERN AMBERG.
PLEASE CALL THE OB TO MEMBERS.
EGGMAN HER TADO STERN AMBERG.
TWENTY EIGHT I KNOW I HAD
TWENTY DIES EIGHT. KNOWS ON THE
URGENCY TWENTY EIGHT ICE NO
EIGHT KNOWS. ON THE MEASURE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS ARE
GONNA MOVE ONTO FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHTY SENATOR LAYERED
IS READY MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL. ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE TWENTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER TO AN
ACTUAL RELATING TO ENERGY.
CENTER A LARGE MAY PROCEED
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY FIVE
LAUNCHES A NEW ENERGY INDUSTRY
IN CALIFORNIA BY DIRECTING THE
STATE TO PREPARE A STRATEGIC
PLAN FOR OFFSHORE WIND. TO
ADDRESS THE CLIMATE CRISIS AND
PUT PEOPLE BACK TO WORK WE HAVE
A ONCE IN A GENERATION
OPPORTUNITY IT SITS TWENTY TO
THIRTY MILES OFF OURCOAST AND
OF THE FIRST TWO SITES ONE OF
THEM IS OFF MY DISTRICT. THIS
IS A SIGNIFICANT BUILD THEIR
SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES I WOULD
ASK FOR YOUR I. PHONE. IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SINGMAN MEMBERS THIS
ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SAYING
NINE FIVE EIGHTY NO ZERO. I'M
I'M SORRY HIGHS THIRTY EIGHT
ZERO- THAT MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY ONE. WE
WILL PAST THAT TEMPORARILY MOVE
ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY
THREE CENTER WEST SO IS READY
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE EIGHTY FOUR
BIAS ON THEM LAEM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LUIS RIVAS AND
ACT RELATING TO VEHICLES
SENATOR WAS SO THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. I THANK YOU MOHAMED
PRESIDENT MEMBERS SAY BE NINE
EIGHTY FOUR IMPLEMENTS THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE DMV FOR
THE VEHICLE REGISTRATION
ALTERNATIVE PILOT PROGRAM BY
AUTHORIZING THE DMV. IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE CHP TO
DEVELOP REGULATIONS AND MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF ELECTRONIC REGISTRATION
CARDS DIGITAL LICENSE PLATES.
AND LICENSE PLATE WRAPS THE
BILL HAS BEEN AMENDED IN THE
SENATE TO ADDRESS A VARIETY OF
ISSUES. THE DMV IN THE SIEGE
PROVIDED TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS
TO THE AUTHOR TO PAVE THE WAY
FOR THEIR- IMPLEMENTATION
PROGRAM- THE BILL RECEIVE LAST
MINUTE OPPOSITION CONCERNS FROM
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ORGANIZATIONS
SO THEY- I WANNA MAKE IT CLEAR
THAT THE AUTHOR- TAKES DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SERIOUSLY IN AN EFFORT
TO ADDRESS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
CONCERNED THE AUTHOR. INSERTED
AMENDMENTS TO REQUIRE THE DMV
TO WORK WITH VENDORS TO ENSURE
DRIVERS ARE AWARE THAT THE
VEHICLE IS EQUIPPED WITH GPS.
WHEN IT'S ACTIVE AND CREATE A
WAY FOR THE GPS TO BE TURNED
OFF. THE GPS TECHNOLOGY AND
DEVICES IS NOT NEW. YOUR PHONE
SMART DEVICES APPS ON YOUR
SMART DEVICES SMART WATCHES
ETCETERA HAVE GPS TRICK
TRACKING CAPABILITIES. THE
AMENDMENT FROM THE AUTHOR GOES
FURTHER THAN WHAT IS CURRENT
GPS TECHNOLOGY BY EXPLORING
DIFFERENT WAYS FOR THE DRIVER
TO TURN OFF. A GP- TURN OFF THE
GPS FINALLY AMENDMENTS WERE
ADDED TO ENSURE EXISTING
COMMUNICATIONS BETWEEN TOLD
AUTHORITIES. AND THE DMV ARE
UNAFFECTED- ESSENTIALLY
OPPOSITIONS TO REMOVED A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIVAL. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA I ADKINS FIVE BASE HI
BECKER HI FORGES HI BRADFORD I
COME BY ADAM HI PROTESTING HI
DALLY. DOT FIVE TORONTO I A
COMMON LASER EYE CONSOLIDATES I
GROSS HI HURTS BERG I WAS SO
HYPER TANTO. I JONES. I CAN
LONGER. I LAYERED HI LABOUR I
THE MOON. I REQUIRE HI
MELINDA'S I MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. BUT YOUR VOTE I PAM I
FORTUNE TINO. HI RALPH I RUBIO
I SKINNER. I STERN AMBERG HI
CASKEY I WINNER I WILL HI
PLEASE CALL THE OB TO MEMBERS.
DALLY. EGLIN NIELSEN. STERN.
FIVE THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS ARE
GONNA MOVE BACK TO ITEM NUMBER
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVENTY EIGHT
SENATOR UMBERG IS PREPARED
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT SIXTY ONE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BENNETT AN
ACT RELATING TO MOBILE HOME
PARKS. SENATOR UMBERG. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES.
EIGHTY EIGHT SIX ONE SIMPLY
CLOSES A LOOPHOLE- WITH RESPECT
TO ADHERENCE TO RENT
STABILIZATION ORDINANCES IN-
UNITS THAT ARE OWNED BY THE
PARK OWNERS ORIGINAL VOTE. IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
HI ARCHULETA BY ATKINS I FACE
NO BACKER HI PORGES NO BRADFORD
I HAVE MY OTHER LINE I
PROTESTING FIVE DALLY NO DOG. I
DRAW SO I ADMIN GLAZER.
GONZALEZ I DROVE. NO HERTZBERG.
I WENT SO I HER TADO HI JONES
NO CAN MONITOR. I LAYERED I
LAVER I THE MOON HI WIRE I
MELINDA'S NO MAN I NEWMAN. I
NIELSEN NO A SHOW OF BOTH. HI
PAM I PERSON TINA I BROTH FIVE
RUBIO HI SKINNER. I STERN I'M
BERG HI I LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER
I WILL NOW. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. EGGMAN GLAZER.
STERN. FIVE TWENTY NINE KNOWS
EIGHT THE MEASURE PASSES
NUMBERS WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVENTY TWO
SENATOR SKINNER. SHE IS
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE FIFTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TRUE AN ACT
RELATING TO CRIMINAL PROCEDURE
SANDERS CAN- THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS. AB TWELVE
FIFTY NINE ALLOWANCE THE
CURRENT POST CONVICTION RELIEF
PROCESS THAT IS ALREADY IN
CURRENT LAW TO INCLUDE
INDIVIDUALS CONVICTED BY TRIAL
THE CONSEQUENCES OF INVALID
CONVICTIONS CAN BE DEVASTATING
FOR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES AND
RESULTED CAN RESULT IN CASES IN
MANDATORY IMPRISONMENT AND IN
SOME CASES DEPORTATION. THE
SAME PEOPLE. ARE BLOCKED FROM
THEIR PATHWAY TO CITIZENSHIP
BASED ON AS I POINTED OUT WHAT
UNDER CURRENT LAW IS IN IN IN
THE VALLON CONVICTION. SO WHAT
AB TWELVE FIFTY NINE DOES IS
PREVENTS SUCH DEEP TENSIONS IN
DEPORTATIONS BASED ON INVALID
CONVICTIONS IN WITH THAT I ASK
FOR YOUR REGULAR. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA FIVE
ATKINS I FACE NO BACKER HI
FORGES NO BRADFORD. I HAVE A
HYPERTENSIVE I DALLY NO DOG
FIVE TORONTO I ADNAN GLAZER
ARKANSAS AS I GROW. NO
HERTZBERG HI WEST SO HI HER
TADO NO JONES NO CAN LONGER.
LAYERED I LLEVA I THE MOON I
REQUIRE. HI MELINDA'S NO MEN I
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN NO THE
TROUBLE NO. I PERSON TINO HI
RALPH FIVE RUBIO I SKINNER. I
STERN AMBERG. WHITE HOUSE SKI I
WINNER I WILL KNOW PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. EGGMAN CAN
LONGER I STERN NUMBERED. PRICE
TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS TEN THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS ARE
GONNA MOVE ONTO FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHTY FOUR SENATOR ROTH
IS PREPARED PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN THIRTY
FOUR BY THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS AN
ACT RELATING TO HEALING ARTS
CENTER OFF THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT THIS IS
A SUNSET BILL FOR THE BOARD OF
OPTOMETRY AMONG OTHER THINGS
THE BILL CLOSES A SIGNIFICANT
LOOPHOLE IN THE CURRENT LAW.
WHICH ALLOWS OPTICAL RETAILERS
TO AVOID OVERSIGHT BY THE BOARD
THEREBY JEOPARDIZING PATIENT
SAFETY RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU
ARRIVE A- MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SAYING NINE MEMBERS THIS-
MEASURE IS ELIGIBLE FOR YOU THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION. SEEING NO
OBJECTIONS I THIRTY THIRTY
EIGHT. NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ONTO FILE ITEM
EIGHTY FIVE CENTER LETTERS
PREPARED PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SOLACE AN ACT
RELATING TO BENEFITS SENATOR
LOWER THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK
YOU A MADAM PRESIDENT THIS IS
ONE OF THE MAJOR BILLS TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUES RAISED BY
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE E. D. D.
DEPARTMENT IT'S A BIPARTISAN
BILL WITH TWENTY THREE CO
AUTHORS. A. B. FIFTY SIX
IMPLEMENTS MANY OF THE STATE
ORDERS ORDERS RECOMMENDATIONS
SUCH AS DESIGNATING ONE UNIT
WITH AN ADD TO OVERSEE AND
STREAMLINE FRAUD PREVENTION AND
DETECTION CREATING A
CENTRALIZED TRACKING TOOL THAT
ALLOWS YOU TO DO TO QUICKLY
REVIEW AND STOP PAYMENT ON
FRAUDULENT CLAIMS. REQUIRING
YOU TO DO TO ASSESS THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE
DEPARTMENT'S CROSS MATCHING
CLAIMS AGAINST INFORMATION OF
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS AND
REQUIRING EDT TO STOP SENDING
MAIL WITH FULL SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBERS AND REQUIRING EDG TO
PAY FOR IDENTITY THEFT
MONITORING SERVICES IF IT FAILS
TO DO SO. THEIR SUPPORT ON BOTH
SIDES I WOULD ASK FOR IN A ROW.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. HE'S
SAYING NINE MEMBERS THIS ITEM
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION.
SAYING NO OBJECTION FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS ARE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY
SIX. SENATOR ALLEN IS PREPARED
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE OH ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
TING AN ACT RELATING TO SOLID
WASTE CINDERELLA AND THE FOUR
HERE'S PRESIDENT- THIS BILL
REQUIRES PRODUCTS TO MEET
HIGHER QUALITY STANDARDS IN
ORDER TO BE LABELED AS
COMPOSTABLE. MANY OF TODAY'S
PRODUCTS ARE LABELED AS
COMPOSABLE BUT CAN'T ACTUALLY
BE COMPOSTED BECAUSE THEY DON'T
MEET APPROPRIATE STANDARDS
BECAUSE THEY INCLUDE HARMFUL
CHEMICALS. SO THE BILL REQUIRES
THE PRODUCTS THAT ARE LABELED
COMPOSTABLE HAVE TO MEET
ESTABLISHED INTERNATIONAL
FEDERAL AND STATE STANDARDS
HAVE TO BE CERTIFIED BY A THIRD
PARTY CERTIFICATION ENTITY HI
THE BILL ALSO PREVENTS PRODUCTS
WITH INTENTIONALLY ADDED P.
FILES. FROM BEING LABELED AS
COMPOSTABLE BECAUSE IT WOULD
CONTAMINATE THE COMPOST
REMAINED UP IN OUR FOOD CHAIN
OBVIOUSLY WE DON'T WANT P.
FILES- IN THE COMPOST RAPE SO
NOW WE TALKED ABOUT. A P. FIVE.
THE LAST THING I SHOULD MENTION
IS THAT THE BILL REQUIRES A
COMPOSABLE ABLE BE CLEAR
ALLOWING CUSTOMERS AND
CONSUMERS TO. EASILY
DISTINGUISH THE PRODUCTS THAT
ARE COMPOSED OF ALL THOSE THAT
ARE NOT. THE OTHERS WORKED
EXTENSIVELY WITH OPPOSITION
AND- I'M- PLEASED TO SAY THAT
CMT A PROCTOR GAMBLE. AND OTHER
MANUFACTURERS ARE NON NEUTRAL
ON THE BILL. AND WITH THE LAST
SET OF AMENDMENTS- CONCERNS
WERE RAISED BY THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES IN THE AUTHOR.
HAS COMMITTED TO ADDRESS THESE
CONCERNS NEXT YEAR THEY'VE BEEN
IN CONVERSATION OBVIOUSLY THIS
IS. HOW THESE BILLS ARE VERY
STRONGLY SUPPORTED BY- BY- THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TYPICALLY-
BUT YOU KNOW THE AUTHORS ALSO
BEEN REALLY WORKING HARD TO TRY
TO. YOU KNOW ADDRESS ALL THE
CONCERNS OF INDUSTRY SO THERE'S
NOW NO INDUSTRY OPPOSITION
THERE ARE. EXISTING CONCERNS OF
THE RC RC. AND BEAR IN
CONVERSATION AND YEAH AND THE
OTHERS VERY STRONGLY COMMITTED.
TO GETTING THE- CONCERNS
ADDRESSED. IN THE COMING YEAR
SO- AND CERTAINLY THE
INCREDIBLE CALL THE COMMITTEE
WILL BE HOLDING ON TO THAT.
WITH THAT I RESPECT YESTERDAY
ABOUT. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SAYING
MAN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
I ARCHULETA FIVE ADKINS FIVE
EIGHTHS. BACKER I PORCHES NO
BRADFORD I HAVE MY OTHER ONE
CORTESE HI DALLY. DOT ARE YOU
DRAW SO I A COMMON GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE I DROVE. HERTZBERG
HI WEST SO I HER TADO I JONES I
CAN LONGER. LAYERED I LLEVA I
THE MOON HI WIRE I MELINDA'S.
MAN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN. NO
CHOKE I PAM I POURED INTO YOU
KNOW. I. ROSS. I RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN I'M BURKE I
LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER. I WILL
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BATES BY ADAM. I DALLY.
EGGMAN GROWTH. CAN LONGER. I
MELINDA'S. STERN. FIVE THIRTY
TWO NOSE TO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS ARE GONNA MOVE ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY SEVEN.
SENATOR TO LEAD AND HE IS
PREPARED PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL LEVIN THIRTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO AN ACT
RELATING TO CANNABIS AND MAKING
AN APPROPRIATION THEREFORE
CENTER TO LETTER. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYWOMAN BLANCA
RUBIO. ASSEMBLY BILL OF ELEVEN
THIRTY PROVIDES AN ADDITIONAL
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM AGAINST
UNLICENSED CANNABIS ACTIVITIES
BY ESTABLISHING A CIVIL PENALTY
FOR HIGH LEVEL CONTROL PERSONS
WHO KNOWINGLY AID AND ABET
UNLICENSED CANNABIS ACTIVITIES.
CURRENT ESTIMATES PUT THE VALUE
OF ILLEGAL CANNABIS MARKET AT
AROUND EIGHT POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR
ACCOUNTING FOR ALMOST 80% OF
TOTAL CANNABIS SALES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. ALL OF
THIS ECONOMIC ACTIVITY IS BOTH
ATTACKS IN UNREGULATED. IN
ADDITION TO DRAWING. TAX
REVENUES THE UNDERGROUND MARKET
PRESENTS A SERIOUS THREAT TO
PUBLIC HEALTH AND PRODUCTS SOLD
AT THESE LOCATIONS WHICH EVADE
STATE TESTING AND PUBLIC
REQUIREMENTS. THE MEASUREMENTS
TAKEN DURING THE COMMITTEE
PROCESS CLEARLY AND EXPLICITLY
PROTECT LOW LEVEL EMPLOYEES IN
THE TEXT OF THE BILL RESULTING
IN THE BILL RECEIVING UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THROUGHOUT
BOTH HOUSES. THE BILL ENJOYS
SUPPORT OF LABOR NIONS WHO
REPRESENT THESE EMPLOYEES THE
LEGITIMATE BUSINESS COMMUNITY
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT ALL TOGETHER
SUPPORT THIS BILL I THANK YOU
RESPECTFULLY AFTER I BOUGHT. IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SAYING NON MEMBERS
THIS- IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. C. NINE
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS ARE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO ITEM FIVE
ITEM NUMBER NINETY. SENATOR
HURTADO IS PREPARED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE SEVENTEEN BY FAMILY
MEMBER PATTERSON AN ACT
RELATING TO FOSTER CARE CENTER
HER DAUGHTER THE FLOOR'S YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT A B.
THREE SEVENTY NOT BE HAVE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PATTERSON THE
BILL WILL STRENGTHEN THE OFFICE
OF THE STATE FOSTER CARE
APARTMENT THE OFFICE EXISTS TO
SERVE YOUTH IN OUR FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM AND TO PROTECT THEM
FROM. PROBLEMATIC PLACEMENTS OR
SITUATIONS AS WELL TO INFORM
THEM OF SERVICES AVAILABLE TO
THEM AND THEIR RIGHTS THIS BILL
HAS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND HAS NO OPPOSITION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY BOAT.
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SAYING
NINE THIS IS ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR
THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO APPLYING
THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SAYING
NINE ICE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS ARE
GONNA MOVE ON TO. FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINETY ONE SENATOR RUBIO
IS PREPARED PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN SIXTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY
AN ACT RELATING TO REAL POP
PROPERTY SENATOR RUBIO THE
FLOOR'S YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE SENATE TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT AT FOURTEEN SIXTY SIX
ON BEHALF OF THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. FROM SACRAMENTO WHICH
WILL TAKE PRO ACTIVE STEPS TO
REMOVING JIM CROW ERA RACIST
LANGUAGE FROM HOUSING DOCUMENTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SPECIFICALLY THIS
BILL WILL CREATE A SYSTEMATIC
APPROACH TO IDENTIFYING. A
REDACTING RACIALLY RESTRICTIVE
LANGUAGE THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SAYING
MAN THIS ALSO IS ELIGIBLE FOR
YOU THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO APPLYING
THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING
NONE ICE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. OVER THEM
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER NINETY TWO SENATOR
LEON IS PREPARED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WOOD AN ACT RELATING TO FIRE
SAFETY CENTER LIMB ON THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. THE MADAM PRESIDENT
EIGHTY NINE BY SUMMER WOOD HAS
TWO KEY COMPONENTS THE FIRST IS
CONFINED TO REGIONAL FOREST IN
FACT PASS THE PROGRAM AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION THE
PROGRAM PROVIDES FLEXIBLE BLOCK
GRANTS TO CREATE REGIONAL PLANS
AND DEVELOP A PIPELINE OF FIRE
PREPAREDNESS PROJECTS THAT
MEET. THE SPECIFIC NEEDS OF THE
REGION THE SECOND COMPONENT IS
IDENTIFYING THE PREPAREDNESS
AND PREVENTION ACTIVITIES CAL
FIRE SHOULD BE DOING IN
COMMUNITIES. AND PUTS THEM IN A
NEW BRANCH OF THE FIRE
MARSHAL'S OFFICE THE GOAL THIS
PROPOSAL IS TO CREATE URGENCY
AND FOCUS ON PREVENTION AND
PREPAREDNESS ACTIVITIES THIS
BILL HAS ENJOYED STRONG
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. AND THERE
IS NO LISTED OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I HAVE
A- IS THERE. DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM MEMBERS.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SAYING
MAN THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ANY
OBJECTION TO APPLYING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING
NONE ICE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. WE MOVE ON
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER NINETY
THREE SENATOR RUBIO'S PREPARED
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TEN
FORTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
JOHN SAWYER AN ACT RELATING TO
LONG TERM HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES SENATOR RUBIO THE
FLOOR'S YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE SENATE TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT AT TEN FORTY TWO. HOW
TO ENSURE SEATING CRITICAL CARE
FOR OUR MOST VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS RECENT AMENDMENTS
ARE TECHNICAL IN CAME FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES THESE AMENDMENTS TO
LAY THAT NOTIFICATION TO
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. AND OUT SPECIFICATIONS
ON WHEN A PARTY IS NOT
FINANCIALLY VIABLE AND RECOVERY
ABOUT PAY PENALTIES IS UNLIKELY
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION
THANKYOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION- DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS I FACE NO FACTOR HI
PORCHES NO BRADFORD I COME BY
OTHER. HI PROTESTING I DALLY NO
DOG. I TORONTO FIVE A COMMON
GLAZER. GLAZER. GONZALEZ I
GROVE NO HERTZBERG HI WITH SO I
HER TADO I JONES NO CAME UNDER.
I LAYERED I LLEVA I THE MON HI
WIRE. HI MELINDA'S NO MAN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. NO- CHARTER
OAK. NO PAM I FOURTEEN TINA I
BROUGHT. I REVIEW FIVE SKINNER.
FIVE STERNE AMBERG NINE FIVE
FOUR CASKEY FIVE WINNER I WILL.
NO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. EGGMAN LASER I STERN.
FIVE TWENTY NINE KNOWS NINE THE
MEASURE PASSES. NEVER GONNA
TAKE UP FILE ITEM NUMBER NINETY
FIVE CENTER RIGHT CASKEY HE IS
PREPARED PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX SIXTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHAN AN ACT
RELATING TO BUSINESS CENTER A
CASKET FORGERS MEN PRESENT THIS
MEASURE- PERMITS EACH AWAY
BORDER DIRECTORS TO TECHNICS
NECESSARY ACTIONS DURING THE
EMERGENCY AND ELIMINATE
CONTENT- IN THE TICKET WHICH IS
TYPICALLY OUTSIDE THE
CORPORATION'S ORDINARY COURSE
OF BUSINESS I WOULD URGE AN
IPHONE. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE MEMBERS THIS MEASURE IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
APPLYING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SEEING NO OBJECTION-
THERE IS AN OBJECTION MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I
FACE I BACKER. HI FORGES I
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM HI
CORTEZ. HI DOLLY. GOD I DRAW SO
I EGGMAN BLAZER ICONS ALL AS I
GROW. HI HURTS BURKE I WAS SO.
I HER TADO. HI JONES I CAN
LONGER. I LAYERED I. LEIVA I
THE MOON I REQUIRE I MELINDA'S
NO MAN I NEWMAN I NELSON. HI
UNTIL THE. I CAN I FORTUNE TINO
I BROUGHT. I REVIEW HI SKINNER.
I STERN AMBERG ALL RIGHT ALL
RIGHT BYE CASKEY I WINNER. FIVE
WELL NO PLEASE CALL THE OB TO
MEMBERS. DALLY ADMIN. STERN.
FIVE THIRTY FIVE NOSE TO THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS ARE
GONNA MOVE ONTO FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINETY SIX SENATOR
HERTZBERG. BUT HE IS PREPARED
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE EIGHTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GROUP MEMBER
GRAYSON AN ACT RELATING TO
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
SENATOR HERZBERG FOR SEARS
THANK YOU LADIES TO MEMBERS
REFLECT A COLLABORATIVE EFFORTS
BY STAKEHOLDERS REMOVE ALL
OPPOSITION ASTRONOMICAL. IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NONE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI
ATTENDEES. HI BABES HI BECKER
HI PORCHES HI BRADFORD I COME
BY ADAM I PROTECTING FIVE DALLY.
DOT I TORONTO. HI EGGMAN GLAZER.
I CONSOLIDATE HI GROVE. HI
KURTZ BURKE I WEAR SO. HI HER
TADO I JONES I CAN LONGER.
LAYERED I LABOR. I THE MOON HI
WIRE HI MELINDA'S. I'VE BEEN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. A TROUBLED. I
CAN HI WATSON TINO. HI RALPH. I
RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN AMBERG
ALL RIGHT HI MY CASTING I
WINNER. I WILL. PLEASE CALL THE
OTHER MEMBERS. DALLY I. EGGMAN
CAN LONGER I NIELSEN I STERN
WELL. I THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS
WORKING WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO THE TO THE BUDGET SO IF YOU
JUST TAKE A MINUTE WE'RE GOING
TO BE MOVING ON TO THE SENATE
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE NUMBER.
ONE
YEAH.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
OF SENATOR WESSEL. I THANK THE
PRESIDENT I JUST GOT WORD FROM
THE AUTHOR ON EIGHTY NINE
EIGHTY FOUR FINAL ITEM THREE.
THAT SHE WOULD LIKE TO- I GUESS
MOTION TO RECONSIDER TO ADD THE
BILL TO CONNECT THE FILE. IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION SAYING
SAYING NO OBJECTION TO THAT-
THE MOTION IF. YEAH READ IT
RESET RECONSIDERATION IS
GRANTED ICE THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO AND- BILL IS MOVED TO THE
INACTIVE FILE AND SENATOR
UMBERG. YOU HAVE AN ISSUE AS
WELL- YES ON THE MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUBMIT A LETTER IN
THE JOURNAL ON SP FORTY ONE
THAT HAS BEEN APPROVED BY BOTH
CAUCUSES. WITHOUT OBJECTION SO
ORDERED. HIGHS THIRTY EIGHT NO.
ZERO SENATOR WIENER UNDER MOSES
RESOLUTIONS- I REQUEST THAT- AT
TEN FORTY ONE FILE NUMBER
EIGHTY TWO BY SOME MEMBER
WORKS- BE MOVED AN ACTIVE FILE
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SO ORDERED
SENATOR I THIRTY MIN PRESIDENT
REQUESTED ITEM NUMBER SIXTY
FOUR ASSEMBLY BILL THREE NINETY
TWO. HE MOVED TO THE INACTIVE
FILE OTHER CUTS TO THE AUTHOR
WITHOUT OBJECTION SO ORDERED.
ANY FURTHER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. THING THEN WE WILL
MOVE ON TO THE UNFINISHED
BUSINESS WHICH IS THE- STATE A
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE NUMBER WHEN
THE BUDGET. SENATOR SKINNER
MADAM SECRETARY WE WILL TAKE
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE FORTY FIVE
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL ONE
SEVENTY BY SENATOR SKINNER AN
ACT RELATING TO THE STATE
BUDGET AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE CITRIX
MEDIALLY BUILT BUDGET BILL.
SENATOR SKINNER THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS. S. B. ONE
SEVENTY IS BUDGET BILL JUNIOR
IT CONTAINS BUDGET BILL
ADJUSTMENTS PRIMARILY RELATED
TO THE JUNE BUDGET AGREEMENT WE
ADOPTED IN JUNE. MOST
SIGNIFICANTLY THIS BILL
APPROPRIATES FUNDING FOR
VARIOUS RESOURCES PACKAGES WHEN
WITH TODAY'S ACTION WILL BE
AUTHORIZING SIXTEEN BILLION.
NEW SPENDING DEDICATED TO FIGHT
OUR CLIMATE CRISIS WILDFIRES
DROUGHT AND IMPROVE OUR NATURAL
ENVIRONMENT. BUT I WILL GO INTO
SOME OF THE DETAILS IN JUST A
MOMENT. IT ALSO. AUTHORIZES
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION OF THE TWO
BILLION THAT WE SET ASIDE. FOR
STUDENT HOUSING A CAMPUS
EXPANSION EXPANSION DR RICE IS
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION. FOR THIS
FISCAL YEAR TWO. OR HIGHER ED
CAMPUSES. TO BUILD MUCH NEEDED
STUDENT HOUSING. TELL ME GO
BACK TO RESOURCES THE SIXTEEN
BILLION I MENTION IS A HISTORIC
LEVEL OF FUNDING FOR NATURAL
RESOURCES AND ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION. WHEN THE BILLS ALL
BE PRESENTING AND THAT WILL BE
VOTING ON INCLUDE. THREE POINT
SEVEN BILLION OVER THREE YEARS
FOR CLIMATE RESILIENCY. ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION IF WE ADD UP
TODAY AND WHAT WE DID IN EARLY
ACTION FOR WILDFIRES. FOUR
POINT SIX BILLION OVER THREE
YEARS TO ADDRESS OUR DROUGHTS
AND WATER QUALITY ANOTHER WATER
PROBLEMS. ONE POINT ONE BILLION
FOR AGRICULTURE. A HUNDRED AND
FORTY MILLION IN WHAT WE NOW
CALL THE CIRCULAR ECONOMY BUT
TO IMPROVE OUR WASTE RECYCLING
AND REDUCTION. THREE POINT NINE
BILLION OVER THREE YEARS. TO
HELP US GET TO ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES. SO THAT WE ARE NOT
EIGHTEEN AIR POLLUTION THAT
CAUSES SO MANY OF US TO HAVE
ASTHMA OR CARDIO PULMONARY OR
OTHER PROBLEMS FOR FUELS OUR
CLIMATE CRISIS. AT&T ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION FOR CAP AND TRADE
SPENDING PLAN WHICH HAS SOME
OVERLAP WITH THE ITEMS I
MENTIONED ABOVE. FOR
PERSPECTIVE THE TOTAL RESOURCES
INVESTMENT IN TWENTY ONE IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WAS ABOUT
NINE POINT NINE BILLION. AND IF
WE ADD THE FUNDING TO DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS AND ONGOING
PROGRAMS THAT WE DID PREVIOUSLY
MEETING IN JUNE. PLUS THAT
WHICH WE ARE OPERATING TODAY WE
ARE MORE THAN DOUBLING. THE
INVESTMENT IN RESOURCES AS
COMPARED TO LAST YEAR. AND THE
STATE SENATE ALL OF US HERE.
PLAYED A STRONG ROLE IN
PROVIDING THIS UNPRECEDENTED
AMOUNT OF FOCUSED FUNDING. TO
ADDRESS OUR CLIMATE CRISIS OR
DROUGHT OR WILDFIRES AND MORE.
AMONG THE SENATE WINS INCLUDE.
THE CLIMATE RESILIENCY PACKAGE
THE ADMINISTRATION PROPOSED TO
US ONLY ONE POINT SHIFT SEVEN
BILLION OVER THREE YEARS. BUT
WE THOUGHT THAT WAS NOT
ADEQUATE. LOOK WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN THE CRISIS RIGHT NOW. WE SEE
THE IMPACTS RIGHT NOW SO WE
BROUGHT THAT FUNDING UP TO
THREE POINT SEVEN BILLION OVER
THREE YEARS. THE BUDGET AND
ACCOMPANYING TRAILER BILL
PRESERVE THE SENATE PRIORITIES
THAT WORK CAN CHANGE IN SP
FORTY FIVE WHICH WAS A CLIMATE
BONDS THAT WAS CIRCULATING HERE.
INSTEAD WE'RE DOING IT
INITIALLY THESE AUTHORIZATIONS
AND DIRECTS HOW THOSE FUNDS ARE
TO BE SPENT IN THE OUT YEARS.
AND FOR ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES
THE SENATE PUSHED FOR A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE TO THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSED. ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE FINDING. SO
THAT WE'VE NOW ACHIEVED THREE
POINT NINE BILLION OVER THREE
YEARS INCLUDING TWO POINT SEVEN
BILLION JUSTIN THIS FISCAL
YEAR. AND THAT THOSE FUNDS ARE
FOR CHARGING AND FUELING
INFRASTRUCTURE PASSENGER CARS
AND LIGHT DUTY TRUCKS DEDICATED
INVESTMENTS TO ZERO EMISSION
TRANSIT BUSES HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS
IN OUR SCHOOL BUSES. IN THE
WILDFIRE PACKAGE THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSED SEVEN
HUNDRED AND EIGHT MILLION. THE
SENATE WANTED A BILLION
ANNUALLY FOR THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS BECAUSE WE KNOW WILDFIRES
ARE NOT GOING AWAY. AND THE
OUTCOME THAT WE'RE ACHIEVING
TODAY IS ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
FOR THIS YEAR. WHICH IS TODAY'S
ACTION PLUS OUR EARLIER ACTION
AND OF COURSE AS WE ALL KNOW
OUR DEDICATION TO CONTINUING.
SIMILAR APPROPRIATIONS AS YEARS
GO FORWARD. AND IN
CONSERVANCIES THE SENATE FOUGHT
HARD TO PROVIDE FUNDING
DIRECTLY TO THE CONSERVANCY'S
IN OUR DIFFERENT REGIONS
CORPORATE WHO ARE FIGHTING OUR
WILDFIRES INVESTING TO PREVENT
OR WILDFIRES AND ADDRESSING
CLIMATE RESILIENCE. AND THE
FINAL OUTCOME IS TWO HUNDRED
EIGHT MILLION TO CONSERVANCIES
FOR WILDFIRE PREVENTION AT A
MINIMUM OF SIXTY MILLION
ANNUALLY FOR ALL STATE
CONSERVANCY'S OVER THREE YEARS.
SO EACH YEAR FOR THREE YEARS
FOR CLIMATE RESILIENCE. S. B.
NINE OH ONE EXTENSION THAT'S
FOREST HEALTH NEED MINISTRATION
WANTED TO KEEP TWO HUNDRED
MILLION FUNDING IN OUR FREE
HELP FROM OUR GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND. ANNUALLY FOR
FOREST HEALTH. AND THAT WOULD
HAVE COME TO ABOUT A BILLION
OVER FIVE YEARS. THE SENATE
EXTENDED THAT FOR SELF FUNDING.
FOR A TOTAL OF SEVEN HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY MILLION OVER SIX
YEARS PRESERVING A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY MILLION OF OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
REDUCTION FUND. THAT WE HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO USE FOR. DIFFERENT
PURPOSES AS WE UNDERSTAND AND
APPRECIATE EITHER NEW
TECHNOLOGIES OR NEW TOOLS TO
FIGHT THE CLIMATE CRISIS SO WE
ARE PRESERVING A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY MILLION. IN FUNDING
THAT'S NOT. LOCKED IN IN TERMS
OF SPENDING IN OUR GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS REDUCTION FUND
AND YET STILL DEDICATING
SIGNIFICANT MONEY STORE FOREST
HEALTH. FOR CONTRACT COUNTIES
WE'VE INCLUDED FOURTEEN MILLION
FOR CONTRACT COUNTIES TO
PERFORM WELL FIRE FUEL
REDUCTION WORK. AND THAT
APPROPRIATION WAS INCLUDED IN
THE BUDGET. ON AGRICULTURAL
BURNING. WE HAVE FOUGHT TO
INCLUDE ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
MILLION. SO THAT WE COULD HELP
MOVE OFF OF AGRICULTURE BURNING.
ENTROPY AND PROVIDE FUNDING FOR
ALTERNATIVES SO THAT THE AIR IN
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY. WOULD
BE CLEANER. ORGANIC WASTE
ORGANIC WASTE REMAINS FOR A
LARGE PERCENTAGE OF THE WAYS
THE CENTAUR LANDFILLS IN ONE
SENSE THERE. IT PRODUCES
METHANE EMISSIONS METHANE A
VERY POWERFUL BUT SHORT LIVED
CLIMATE GAS. BEYOND IF WE CAN
DIVERT ORGANIC WASTE COMPOSTED
AND OTHER THINGS THAT WE DO NT
HAVE THAT RESULTING METHANE GAS
SO THERE IS A HUNDRED AND
NINETY FIVE MILLION IN OUR CAP
AND TRADE SPENDING PLAN AND THE
CIRCULAR ECONOMY PACKAGE FOR
THAT PURPOSE AND IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE.
THE SENATE PROPOSED AUTHORITY
FOR DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE TO HAVE NEW STAFF TO
DEAL WITH THE IMPLICATIONS OF
ILLEGAL CANNABIS GROWS SUCH AS
WATER THEFT AND CONTAMINATION
OF OUR- RIVERS AND STREAMS
WHICH OF COURSE IS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT DURING THE STRETCH.
AND THE FINAL OUTCOME WITH
WHAT'S BEFORE US TODAY IS
TWENTY NINE NEW STAFF POSITIONS.
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF. FISH AND
WILDLIFE USING EXISTING
FUNDING. THE ACTIONS BEFORE US
TODAY ALSO INCLUDE MAJOR
INVESTMENT. IN PREVENTING OUR
DIMENSION METHANE BUT OTHER
POWERFUL AND SHORT LIVED
CLIMATE POLLUTANTS BECAUSE
GETTING THOSE PREVENTING THOSE
FOR HITTING OUR ATMOSPHERE
RIGHT NOW. IMMEDIATELY
ADDRESSES THE CLIMATE CRISIS
BECAUSE THEY ARE SO MUCH MORE
POWERFUL THAN JUST CO TWO AND
THOSE INCLUDE ARE HSCS FROM
REFRIGERANTS AND BLACK CARBON
FROM VEHICLES AND OTHERS.
MEMBERS ARE YOU KNOW THAT. WE
ARE FULLY AWARE THAT CALIFORNIA
THE NATION ON OUR GLOBE IS IN
THE MIDST OF A CLIMATE CRISIS
OUR FORCE ARMED FIRE DROUGHT IS
OCCURRING THROUGHOUT THE LAND.
OUR MAJORITY LEADER MENTION THE
FACT THAT OVER THE LAST FOUR
YEARS HAVE BEEN THE DRIEST IN
pOVER FOUR HUNDRED YEARS.
EXTREME HEAT HAS LITERALLY BEEN
KILLING PEOPLE SEA LEVEL RISE
AS WE'VE SEEN FROM HURRICANE
IDA IS DESTROYING CITIES AND
OUR COASTS. IN CALIFORNIA LED
THE NATION IN GOAL SETTING AND
PLANNING TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS AND HALT CLIMATE
CHANGE. IN WITH THIS BUDGET
THESE ACTIONS WERE TAKING WE
ARE PUTTING OUR MONEY WHERE OUR
MOUTH IS AND SUPPORTING THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THOSE GOALS
WITH REAL INVESTMENTS SO MAKE
NO MISTAKE. THIS BUDGET IS THE
LARGEST SINGLE INVESTMENT IN
ENVIRONMENTAL AND CLIMATE
RESILIENCY IN CALIFORNIA
HISTORY. AND TO BE SURE WE NEED
STRONG LAWS AND TARGETS TO MEET
OUR CLIMATE GOALS BUT THE
CRISIS IS HERE AND NOW IN THIS
BUDGET PUTS THE MONEY DIRECTLY
INTO THE PROGRAMS THAT ACHIEVE.
OUR GOALS. WITH INVESTMENTS IN.
OUR OUR OUR COMMUNITIES OUR
FORESTS OUR PORTS ARE GOODS
MOVEMENT OUR WASTE AND
RECYCLING SYSTEMS AND SO MUCH
MORE. IT IS A SITE SAID THE
HISTORICAL COMMITMENT TO
ADDRESSING OUR CLIMATE CRISIS
AND VERY MUCH IN LINE WITH THE
PROPOSALS MADE BY THE BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. MEMBERS THIS
BUDGET DOES MORE FOR CLIMATE
THAN ANY SINGLE BILL IT WILL
SAVE LIVES PROTECT OUR COASTS
IN FORESTS CONSERVED LANDS
INSURE PROPERTY IS PROTECTED.
AND HELP THOSE SUFFERING FROM
THE SCORCH OF EXTREME HEAT WITH
THAT MEMBERS I ASK FOR YOUR I.
VOTE. SENATOR HERTZBERG. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I WANT TO
JOIN IN WITH THE INTENSITY AND-
STRESSING THE EXTRAORDINARY
NATURE OF. THIS MEASURE THAT
WAS EXPRESSED BY THE BUDGET
CHAIR. SOME DECADES AGO. WHEN
WE TALKED ABOUT RENEWABLE
PORTFOLIO STANDARDS AND WE
PASSED A B. THIRTY TWO AND WE
CHANGE TAIL PIPE EMISSIONS. WE
CHARACTERIZE THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE FACED AS CLIMATE CHANGE.
I WOULD SUGGEST. AS THE CHAIR
OF THE BUDGET JUST SUGGESTED
THAT WE CHARACTERIZE THIS IT'S
NO LONGER CLIMATE CHANGE ITS
CLIMATE CHANGED. AS A
CONSEQUENCE IT REQUIRES US AS A
LEGISLATURE AND AS THE GOVERNOR
TO FIGHT ON A TWO FRONT WAR. TO
DEAL WITH THE VARIOUS ISSUES
THAT WE HAVE TO FACE THAT ARE
CAUSING EXTRAORDINARY IMPACTS.
IN OUR LIVES IN IN ANY ACROSS
THE ENVIRONMENT AT THE SAME
TIME WE HAVE TO PROVOKE PROVOKE
POLICIES THAT SEEK TO PREVENT
FURTHER ENDS OF CLIMATE BEING
CHANGED. THE COMMUNITY IS THE
FIRST OF ALL LET ME START BY
SAYING I THINK I WANT TO STRESS
A COUPLE THESE POINTS INTO
IMPORTANT. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCED ITS
HOTTEST AUGUST ON RECORD IN
TWENTY TWENTY JUST A YEAR AGO.
WITH TEMPERATURES REACHING A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY DEGREES
FAHRENHEIT IN THE VALLEY IN THE
COMMUNITIES THAT I REPRESENT
THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY WHICH
IS GROUND ZERO FOR THIS EXTREME
HEAT. WOODEN HILLS HIT A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE DEGREES
CENTER JONES. ARM LAST
SEPTEMBER AND THAT'S THE SINGLE
HOTTEST TEMPERATURE EVER
RECORDED IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
MEMBERS. THE STAKES COULD NOT
BE HIGHER ON AVERAGE EXTREME
HEAT KILLS MORE PEOPLE IN THE
U. S. THAN EVERY OTHER NATURAL
DISASTER COMBINED I REPEAT THE
EXTREME HEAT KILLS MORE PEOPLE
IN UNITED STATES THAN TORNADOES
AND FIRES AND FLOODS AND
HURRICANES THAT WE'RE SEEING ON
THE FRONT PAGES OF THE
NEWSPAPER. EVEN THIS MORNING IN
THE US IN THE LA TIMES. ALONG
WITH RECORD BREAKING HEAT
MEMBERS BECAME A RECORD
BREAKING FIRST SEASONS AS WE
NOTE THE TWENTY TWENTY FIRST
SEASON WAS THE LARGEST IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY BURNING MORE
THAN FOUR POINT TWO MILLION
ACRES. AND SHATTERING ANY
PREVIOUS RECORD WHICH WAS JUST
SET TWO YEARS EARLIER IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. THE
DEVASTATING FIRE SEASON TOOK
THIRTY THREE LIVES AND MORE
THAN TEN THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED
STRUCTURES WERE DESTROYED. IT
ALSO MOST IMPORTANTLY SPEWED
HAS BEEN TALKED ABOUT THIS FOR
THE LAST FEW DAYS. OF CARBON
DIOXIDE IN THE YEAR TO EQUAL
THE EMISSIONS OF MILLIONS OF
PASSENGER VEHICLES OVER THE
COURSE OF THE YEAR. WITH MORE
THAN TWO MILLION ACRES BURNED
SO FAR JUST IN THIS YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. FIRE SEASON IS
PROVING TO KEEP PACE AND MAY BE
EXCEEDING WHAT HAPPENS IN A
RECORD BREAKING TWENTY TWENTY.
AND HE ALREADY DESTRUCTIVE FIRE
SEASON WILL WORSEN THIS FALL
WITH LONG TERM FORECAST
SHOWING. LITTLE SIGNS OF RELIEF.
CALIFORNIA ALSO FINDS ITSELF
STARING DOWN ANOTHER CRIPPLING
DROUGHT HARDLY FIVE YEARS AFTER
THE LAST HISTORIC DROUGHT THAT
I MENTIONED. IT WITH RESPECT TO
AN EARLIER BILL HERE TODAY AND
AS THE BUDGET YEAR REFERENCE.
ALL OF CALIFORNIA IS ALREADY
EXPERIENCING AT LEAST A
MODERATE DROUGHT CONDITIONS
WHILE 46% MEMBERS 46% OF THE
STATE IS EXPIRING. EXCEPTIONAL
DROUGHT CONDITIONS AT THE START
OF THE CALENDAR YEAR ONLY 1%
WAS IN THIS EXCEPTIONAL
CONDITION. STATE AND FEDERAL
AGENCIES ACROSS OUR GOVERNMENT.
CONTINUED USE WATER ALLOCATIONS
RESPONSE TO DROUGHT CONDITIONS.
THESEALLOCATIONS ARE LOW AS WE
KNOW AS LOW AS WE'VE NOT SEEN
IN THEIR HISTORIC LEVELS.
EXTREME HEAT WILDFIRES DROUGHT
SEA RISE A SEA LEVEL RISE IS
THE CHAIR INDICATED WERE WHERE
WE WERE ALL IN THE MIDST OF
THIS NEW CLIMATE REALITY AS I
SUGGESTED NOT CLIMATE CHANGE.
THIS IS OUR NEW UNFORTUNATE
NORMAL. WITHOUT DRASTIC
MITIGATION MEASURES THESE
CLIMATE EVENTS WILL CONTINUE TO
BECOME MORE FREQUENT
CATASTROPHIC AND COSTLY. NOW
THIS BUDGET I WANT TO STAND
TALL AND STAND WITH THE BUDGET
CHAIR AND SAY THAT THIS IS THE
SINGLE LARGEST INVESTMENT
CLIMATE RESILIENCY IN THE
HISTORY OF THE STATE I REPEAT
THIS IS THE SINGLE LARGEST
INVESTMENT IN CLIMATE
RESILIENCY IN THE HISTORY OF
THE CITY CALIFORNIA. AS THE
CHAIR INDICATED INCLUDES
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS WITH
THE BILLION DOLLARS IN NEW
SPENDING DEDICATED TO FIGHT
CLIMATE CHANGE WHILE FIRES
DROUGHT AND IMPROVE OUR NATURAL
ENVIRONMENT. THIS BUDGET IS
INDICATED INCLUDES THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO TAKE
PEOPLE FROM EXTREME HEALTH.
THROUGH TREE PLANTING COOL
STRUCTURES AND CUTTING EDGE
TECHNOLOGIES ONE POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS WILL BE
INVESTED IN- IN IN PROPERLY
MANAGING AND REINFORCING.
CALIFORNIA'S MAJESTIC FORCED
MILLIONS OF ACRES. HAVE BURNED
AND NOW NEED TO BE TO BRING
CALIFORNIA TOGETHER TO
REFOREST. OVER THREE HUNDRED
PARTNERS THROUGHOUT THE CITY
CALIFORNIA FROM ALL CORNERS OF
THE STATE. CAME TOGETHER TO
SECURE TWO HUNDRED NINETY
MILLION DOLLARS. TO MAKE OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS AND COMMUNITIES
GREENER COOLER AND MORE CLIMATE
RESILIENCE WITH INVESTMENTS IN
TREES AND URBAN GREENING. SO
MUCH OF WHAT WE DO ONE POLICY
WITH RESPECT TO CLIMATE CHANGE
DEALS WITH AGENCIES AND
GOVERNMENT LANGUAGE THAT FOLKS
DON'T UNDERSTAND. I REMEMBER I
USED TO TALK ABOUT CLIMATE
CHANGE YEARS AGO IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY CLIMATE CHANGE MAKE THE
YOUR CONDITIONING STOPPED
WORKING. THE STANDARDS OF THE
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE TO FOCUS ON
OUR NEIGHBORHOODS REAL PEOPLE
REAL PEOPLE'S LIVES. AND TREES
ARE THE BEST FRONTLINE DEFENSE
AGAINST EXTREME HEAT. TREES ARE
MULTIPLE BENEFICIAL AND COST
EFFICIENT GREEN INFRASTRUCTURE
IN FACT TREES BUT THE ONLY
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT GROWS IN
VALUE. OVER TIME. IN ONE YEAR A
MATURE TREE WILL ABSORB MORE
THAN FORTY EIGHT POUNDS OF
CARBON DIOXIDE. FROM THE
ATMOSPHERE IN A GROUP FOREST
CAN ABSORB TWICE THE CO TWO
PRODUCED BY THE AVERAGE CARS
ANNUAL MILEAGE. WE FOUGHT HARD
TO MAKE THIS HISTORIC
INVESTMENT FLOWS DIRECTLY TO
CALIFORNIA NEIGHBORHOODS FROM
REDWOOD FORESTS TO THE SOUTHERN
BORDER TO PROTECT PEOPLE. FROM
THE THREATS OF WILDFIRES
EXTREME HEAT AND DROUGHTS THAT
IS WHAT SO FUNDAMENTAL AND
IMPORTANT ABOUT THIS BUDGET AND
JUST DOESN'T. ADDRESS OUR
CLIMATE REALITY IT IMPROVES THE
QUALITY OF LIFE FOR OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS I KNOW I'M GOING
ON A LONG BODIES ONCE A COUPLE
MORE QUICK POINTS. THIS BUDGET
IS ABOUT TAKING ACTION. IT'S
ABOUT TAKING ACTION. THOUGHT
ABOUT LONG TERM PLANS TWENTY OR
THIRTY OR FORTY YEARS AGO FROM
NOW PEOPLES LIVES ARE BEING
IMPACTED TODAY SCREEN HE IS
IMPACTING PEOPLE'S LIVES TODAY.
FORESTS ARE BURNING TODAY WE
NEED TO MARRY THE LONG TERM
VIEW BUT ALSO TAKE A VIEW IN
TERMS OF IMPACTS ON PEOPLE'S
LIVES AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
BUDGET DOES AT HISTORICALLY
HIGH LEVELS I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE. SENATOR.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT- I
RISE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
ONE SEVENTY- BUT WITH SOME
CONCERNS ARE DISPELLED DOES
MUCH TO SUPPORT OUR OR WILDFIRE
WATER RESILIENCE IT LEAVES OUT
FUNDING TO PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR
VECTOR TO AFGHAN CITIZENS AND
SUPPORT COMFORTABLE MET BY
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE STUDENTS IT
ALSO PROVIDES MUCH NEEDED FUNDS
FOR PUBLIC SAFETY EQUIPMENT FOR
CITIES. HOWEVER THIS BILL ALSO
INCLUDES PROVISIONS THAT
ESTABLISH A GRANT PROGRAM FOR
MULTI BENEFIT LAND RE PURPOSING
FOR GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
PROJECTS THAT REDUCE
GROUNDWATER USE. REPURPOSED
IRRIGATED AGRICULTURAL LAND AND
PROVIDE WILDLIFE HABITAT. THESE
ARE ALL WORTHY CAUSES DON'T GET
ME WRONG BUT I AM CONCERNED
THAT BY INCENTIVIZING THE
CONVERSION OF AGRICULTURAL LAND
WE MAY BE PUTTING FARM. AS THIS
PROGRAM IS FOR WE SHOULD DO ALL
WE CAN TO ENSURE THAT THIS
POTENTIAL UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE DOES NOT BECOME A
REALITY AND MY CONCERN IS THAT
I DON'T SEE ITS SUPPORT TO PUT
YOU KNOW FURTHER SUPPORT FOR
FARM WORKERS IF THAT IS THE
CASE. I ALSO- AND WE COULD DO A
LOT MORE WHEN IT COMES TO WATER
AND PROVIDING WATER AND WE ARE
EXPECTING THIS WATER SHORTAGE
IN EIGHTY THREE OF THE TWO
HUNDRED FOUR BASINS ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES AND- IT'S ONLY
GOING TO INCREASE IN THE
SITUATIONS GOING TO ONLY GET
WORSE AND I KNOW THERE'S THIS
BUDGET HAS A LOT TO DO TO
ADDRESS THE NOW BUT WE REALLY
NEED TO ALSO START ADDRESSING
THE NEAR FUTURE- LIKE I SAID
THERE'S A LOT OF GOOD THINGS IN
THIS IN THIS BUDGET TRAILER
BILL- THERE'S SOME CONCERN THAT
I HAVE AND I HOPE THAT YOU'LL
KEEP THEM IN MIND AS- YOU KNOW
WE- WE MOVED THE- LEGISLATIVE
YOU'RE- ALONG AND- BUT I.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AIBO.
SENATOR AKOWSKI. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF- AB OR SB ONE
SEVENTY I WOULD LIKE TO START
OFF WITH THANKING THE BUDGET
CHAIR IN THE MAJORITY LEADER
FOR THEIR ELOQUENT-
PRESENTATION AND OUR EVERYTHING
THEY SAID I'VE CHECKED THE
FACTS THAT ARE TRUE- BUT ALSO.
GIVING US A PERSPECTIVE OF
WHAT'S HAPPENING AND ALSO-
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE- PRO
TEM AND HER STAFF CHRIS
WOULDN'T KICK LEOPARD IS WELL
AS THE- STAFF WITH- A SEPT TWO
JAMES HACKER IN CHILE AND ROY
HAVE BEEN INSTRUMENTAL IN
SHAPING THE SENATE'S VIEWS THAT
ARE BRACED GUY HERE IN SP- ONE
SEVENTY. THERE'S A LOT MORE
WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE I
THINK EVERYBODY HAS A SENSE MY
ANXIOUSNESS- WITH THIS BUT I
WAS RECALLING- IN. TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WHEN- THAT PROTEIN
KEVIN DE ON ASK ME SERVE ON
BUDGET SET TWO AND AT THAT TIME
WE WERE SPENDING NO MONEY
RELATIVELY SPEAKING ON FOREST
HEALTH THERE WAS A SIMPLE FIVE
YEARS AGO AND THEN. AT THAT
YEAR WE PUT IN TWO HUNDRED
FORTY MILLION FORTY FOUR SOUTH
WAS A BIG. STATEMENT TO SAY THE
SENATE AND IT GOT IT ONE AND IN
THE FINAL CAPTAIN TREE BUDGET
THAT WE WOULD BE SPENDING THAT
MONEY ON FOREST HEALTH WE
REPEATED THAT IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND MY GOOD FRIEND
FROM NAPA. SEEING THE WISDOM
AND WHAT THE SENATE BUDGET
ACTION INCORPORATED INTO S.
BEAT NINE OH ONE AND NOW WE'RE
HERE TO DATE EXTENDING THAT
MINIMUM INVESTMENT. BUT AS THE-
CHAIR BUDGET. IS SET. WE'RE
SPENDING. ONE POINT SEVEN
BILLION BILLION DOLLARS AN HOUR
WILDFIRES YOU KNOW THERE'S SOME
PROGRAMS THAT WE LIKE TO HAVE-
SPENT SPENT BUT THAT IS. AND
UNPROFESSIONAL ONE POINT SEVEN
BILLION IN ONE YEAR. SO
EVERYBODY KNOWS THE SENATE'S
GOAL HERE IS TO SPEND A MINIMUM
OF A BILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS I'M HERE TO ASK
PEOPLE TO VOTE FOR THIS BUT YOU
HAVE MY COMMITMENT WHEN THE
DISCUSSIONS GO ON MOVING
FORWARD WITH IT. AT LEAST I FOR
ONE IS GETTING A GOOD USE ALL
THE EFFORTS THAT I HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT BECOMES A
REALITY IF NOT MORE- THE
HISTORIC IMPLICATIONS OF THIS
OF THE OF THE OF THE ATTENTION
WE'RE PUTTING INTO CLIMATE AND
DROUGHT IN. THE FOREST IS
REALLY- SOMETHING TO BE TO TAKE
PAUSE WITHIN TECH AND TO
REALIZE THAT THE ARCHITECTURE
HAS REALLY BEEN THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE EACH AND EVERYONE
OF YOU SHOULD BE. PROUD OF THE
WORK THAT HAS BEEN DONE THE
GROUNDWORK THAT WAS LAID OUT IN
S. P. FORTY FIVE FROM THE
GENTLEMAN FROM- BUT LACKING
YADA FLINT. WOULD END THAT WE
USE TO. TO DESIGN THE PACKAGE-
THAT IS NOW THE CLIMATE AND
INITIATIVE- I WANT TO BE
OPTIMISTIC I WANT TO BE FORWARD
LOOKING AND I WANTED TO- IS.
UNDERSCORE EVERYTHING THAT'S
BEEN SAID HERE N. N. REMIND
FOLKS THAT THE FRAMEWORK IS SET
WE HAVE LOTS OF WORK TO GO
FORWARD AND I'M LOOKING FORWARD
TO THE NEXT BUDGET SESSION AND
SOME MORE VICTORIES FOR THE
PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HER TO HAVE A-
SENATOR PERDUE KENO. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AND THE
SENATORS OBVIOUSLY I RISE TODAY
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB ONE
SEVENTY AND I WANT TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF APPRECIATION TO OUR
BUDGET CHAIR ARE PRO TEM IN OUR
BUDGET STAFF IN OUR BUDGET THE
SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIRS AS WELL- AS
IT'S BEEN SAID THIS BUDGET
REPRESENTS THE SENATE'S
FRAMEWORK THIS BUDGET
PRIORITIES AND OUR NEGOTIATORS
HELD FIRM AND MADE SURE THAT
THE PRIORITIES THAT WE
DISCUSSED EARLIER IN THE
SESSION- WERE INCLUDED. IN THIS
BUDGET BILL JUNIOR- EARLIER
THIS YEAR HAS BEEN NOTED
SENATOR ALAN HERZBERG HER TADO
RUBIO AND STERN AND I AUTHORED
THE CLIMATE RESILIENCY BOND SP
FORTY FIVE AND FOR SEVERAL
YEARS THE SENATE HAS WORKED ON
DEVELOPING THIS FRAMEWORK AND
TO INCORPORATE THIS INTO A
BUDGET BILL JUNIOR IS A IS A
REMARKABLE ACCOMPLISHMENT FOR
OUR TEAM TO TAKE OUR FRAMEWORK
THAT'S BEEN GOING ON FOR YEARS
AND MAKE SURE IT HAPPENED THIS
YEAR WHEN FUNDS WERE AVAILABLE.
TO MAKE IT HAPPEN AS THE BUDGET
YEAR NOTED THE CLIMATE
RESILIENCY PACKAGE PROVIDES
THREE HUNDRED SIXTY NINE
MILLION FOR TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
ONE AN ADDITIONAL TWO POINT
NINE BILLION FOR TWENTY TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE AND ONE POINT
TWO BIT THREE BILLION IN TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR WHICH TOTALS
THREE POINT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS OVER THREE FISCAL YEARS.
WE'VE SEEN. THAT THIS YEAR'S
DEADLY WILDFIRES ON THE HEELS
OF LAST YEAR'S CATASTROPHIC
EVENTS AND DEVASTATING MULTI
YEAR DROUGHT CLEARLY
DEMONSTRATE. THAT THE IMPACTS
OF OUR CLIMATE CRISIS ARE
HEARING NOW. AND ARE ALREADY
COSTING CALIFORNIANS THEIR
PROPERTY THEIR LIVES AND
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS EVERY YEAR.
EVEN WITH OUR RECENT
INVESTMENTS TO REDUCE FIRE RISK
THE STATE IS BEHIND THE CURVE.
WE MUST TAKE AGGRESSIVE STEPS
TO ENSURE COMMUNITIES AND
NATURAL RESOURCES CAN ADAPT. TO
THE CHANGING CLIMATE AND TO
INCREASE RESILIENCY IN THE FACE
OF MOUNTING CLIMATE IMPACTS.
TODAY WITH SP ONE SEVENTY WE
ARE DOING JUST THAT. THIS
BUDGET BILL IS THAT AS THE
MAJORITY LEADER MENTION IS THE
SINGLE LARGEST INVESTMENT IN
CLIMATE RESILIENCY. IN THE
HISTORY OF THE STATE AS IT
FOCUSES ON CLIMATE CHANGE WHILE
FIRES DROUGHT EXTREME HEAT. AND
COASTAL SEA LEVEL RISE AGAIN
THE LARGEST INVESTMENT IN THOSE
AREAS IN HISTORY. BUDGET BILL
JUNIOR SETS FORTH IMMEDIATE
RESPONSES TO THE CLIMATE CRISIS
AND UNDERSCORES THE SENATE
STRONG LEADERSHIP. AND
COMMITMENT TO ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION FIRE RESILIENCY AND
OUR OPEN SPACE MANAGEMENT. IT'S
BEEN MENTIONED THAT THE
CONSERVANCY'S WHICH ARE LOCALLY
DRIVEN. RESOURCE FOR THE STATE
HAVE BEEN EMBRACED IN THIS
BUDGET THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
THE SENATE INSISTED AND MADE
SURE WAS INCLUDED IN EIGHT SP
ONE SEVENTY. THAT RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THE STATE LOCAL
CONSERVANCIES AND LOCAL ELECTED
OFFICIALS IS BOTH BOTTOM UP AND
TOP DOWN IN THAT WE PROVIDE THE
RESOURCES THEY PROVIDE THE
LOCAL. MANAGEMENT AND FOCUS ON
PRIORITIES ON THE LOCAL LEVEL
THIS IS A RARE AND TERRIFIC
FEAT THAT WAS PULLED OFF. BY
THE STATE SENATE THROUGH THIS
BUDGET PROCESS AND AGAIN I WANT
TO GIVE A SHOUT OUT TO OUR
BUDGET TEAM THAT WAS WORKING
DILIGENTLY AND THE BUDGET CAIR
AND THE PRO TEM. TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR PRIORITIES WERE THE
FRAMEWORK OF THIS BUDGET AND
THAT CLIMATE THE CLIMATE CRISIS
IS BEING IMMEDIATELY ADDRESSED
THROUGH THE BUDGET ALLOCATION
THAT ONCE THIS IS SIGNED. THE
MONEY AND THE RESOURCES BECOME
AVAILABLE TO ADDRESS WELL WE
HAVE ALL BEEN SEEING ON THE
NEWS. THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND
AGAIN RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
STRONG I VOTE ON SB ONE
SEVENTY. SENATOR DOLLY. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS I.
HELLO TO RECAP A LITTLE BIT OF
THIS THIS LAST YEAR WHAT WE'VE-
ATTEMPTED TO DO IT SAID ON. SUB
TWO AND I OF THAT COMMITTEE
GREAT MEMBERS THERE TO WORK
WITH. IN JANUARY WE TALKED
ABOUT THIRTY ACTION MONIES
WHICH WE PUT INTO THE BUDGET
BECAUSE WE KNEW. GOING INTO
THIS DROUGHT THAT WE WERE GONNA
HAVE. FIRES AND- IT WAS TRUE
BUT WHAT HAPPENED IN THAT
PROCESS IS THAT THE MONEY GOT
TAKEN AWAY. AND IT GETS SPENT.
SO WE CAME BACK IT WAS A NO
WE'RE GOING TO DO IT SO WE DID
IT BUDGET. THE BUDGET. AND WE
PUT THE MONEY AND IF YOU RECALL.
I STOOD ON THE FLOOR SAID WE'RE
GONNA HAVE A CLEANUP BILL WHICH
THAT'S THIS BILL TO ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENT HOW WE'RE GONNA SPEND
THE MONEY. S. FIRES WERE
BURNING WHEN WE WERE IN RECESS.
I DID SOME HOMEWORK ACTUALLY
ONE OUT AND IN RESEARCH AND
FOUND THAT I HAVE THE LIST
RIGHT HERE IN MY HAND. OF FOUR
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THOUSAND.
REPORTER SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS
WITH THE PROJECTS. A CROSS THE
STATE THESE ARE YOUR DISTRICTS.
BETTER SHOVEL READY SYKORA AND
NEPA PROJECTS THAT WOULD DO
BETTER TATIAN MANAGEMENT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. I BROUGHT
THIS LIST BACK AND I SUBMITTED
IT TO THE BUDGET CHAIR. TO THE
BUDGET SHARE IN THE SIMILE. I
WORK WITH MY COLLEAGUES ON SUB
TO TRY TO GET. THIS EMPLOYMENT.
AND IT DIDN'T HAPPEN. SO I CAME
TO OUR BUDGET HEARING A COUPLE
NIGHTS AGO AND I ASKED WHY
AREN'T THESE PUT IN. EITHER
SHOVEL READY JOBS DOES MY
DISTRICT BURNING DOWN. AND I
DID A MOTION TO PUT THESE-
PROJECTS ACTUALLY IN THE BUDGET.
NOW I'M GONNA SAY THANK YOU TO
THE BUDGET CHAIR AND ALL OF ALL
OF YOU WHO SIT ON BUDGET. AND
HAVE LISTENED TO THE
FRUSTRATIONS I HAVE IT'S NOT
THE MONEY WE HAVE. TONS OF
MONEY IT'S HOW WE GET THE MONEY
OUT THE DOOR. THAT'S BEEN MY
FRUSTRATION IS THAT. CAL FIRE
CHIEF TOM PORTER SAID E'RE
WE'RE NOT EQUIPPED TO SPEND
MONEY IN THE TWENTY FIVE YEARS
I'VE BEEN ELECTED I'VE ALWAYS
BEEN TRYING TO FIND MONEY.
NEVER HAD MUCH OF A PROBLEM
SPINNING. THESE FIRE SAFE
COUNCILS ARE CD'S AND COUNTIES
HAVE THE ABILITY TO GET THIS
MONEY OUT. YES I WILL CONCEDE
THAT MONEY'S GOING TO
CONSERVATIVES THEY WILL BE ABLE
TO GET SOME THIS MONEY OUT. BUT
WE NEED TO FAST TRACK THIS. MY
BUDGET AMENDMENT SAID WE WILL
PUT THESE PROJECTS ON THE
GROUND BY JANUARY ONE. IN THIS
PROCESS WE HAVE RIGHT NOW. IT'S
NOT GONNA HAPPEN. AS WE BURN
THE FIRE THAT BURNED INTO THE
CALDOR FIRE THAT BURNED INTO
LAKE TAHOE WHICH IS STILL
BURNING. THERE'S A FUEL BREAK
AS IT IS A FIRE CAME OVER THE
RIDGE IT WE BACKFIRED- THE CAL
FIRE WAS ABLE TO BACKFIRE AND
SAVE THE COMMUNITY. THESE
WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE FUEL
BREAKS SAVE YOUR COMMUNITIES IF
WE WERE TO HAVE ONE AROUND
GREENVILLE THERE WOULD STILL BE
A TOWN THERE. SO FOR ME IT'S
NOT ABOUT I WANT TO COMMEND
THAT IS YOUR TRUE EVERYTHING
THAT WAS SAID IS TRUE THIS IS
MORE MONEY THAN EVER BUT IT'S
HOW WE SPEND THE MONEY. IT'S MY
ARGUMENT WHETHER WE SHOULD FUND
TO. READ OR REGULATE. YOU KNOW
WEEDERS LAWN MOWERS VERSUS
PLANTING TREES AND SAVING TREES.
THE SENATOR FROM SAN FERNANDO
MADE MY CASE WE TALKED ABOUT
TREES. MILLION ACRES. IN MY
DISTRICT ALONE THIS YEAR. IS
BURNING. YOU KNOW ME TREES THAT
IS THAT'S A LOT OF TREES TO
PLANT COSTS A LOT OF MONEY IF
WE COULD SAVE THOSE TREES WILL
SEQUESTER CARBON. WE CHANGE.
OUR CLIMATE CHANGE MODEL FASTER
THAN ANYTHING ELSE. THAT'S MY
FRUSTRATION MEMBERS AND I. AND
I SAID DURING THE BUDGET. I'M
NOT GOING TO GO AWAY I'M GONNA
KEEP COTINUE TO HOUND AND WORK
UNTIL WE GET. THESE PROJECTS
IMPLEMENTED IN ON THE GROUND
THAT'S WHAT'S GOING TO MAKE THE
DIFFERENCE FOR THOSE REASONS
I'M NOT GOING TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL TODAY. UNTIL WE ACTUALLY
PRIORITIZE AND GET THE MONEY TO
GO AROUND AND DO THE JOBS THAT
ARE NOT JUST IN MY DISTRICT
THEY'RE YOUR DISTRICTS AS WELL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. SENATOR
KAMMERER. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I TOO. RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB ONE SEVENTY- AND
I TOO WANT TO THANK THE BUDGET
CHAIR IN THE BUDGET STAFF FOR
WORKING INCREDIBLY HARD THIS
BUDGET SEASON WHICH FOR THEM I
AM SURE HAS BEEN NEVER ENDING-
IT IS TRUE. CLIMATE PROTECTION
IS INCREDIBLY REAL- AND IT IS
HAPPENING AT A FASTER AND
FASTER PACE- YOU KNOW THIS YEAR
IT HAS BEEN THE HOTTEST
NATIONALLY IN THIS COUNTRY
SINCE THE DUST BOWL IN NINETEEN
THIRTY SIX AND THAT THOSE
TEMPERATURES ARE GOING UP AND
UP AND UP. INTO THE POINTS MADE
BY THE BUDGET CHAIR AND THE
MAJORITY LEADER AND I CHERISH
APPROPRIATIONS THE GOOD SENATOR
FROM PASADENA- WE HAVE GOT TO
GET THIS UNDER CONTROL. AND TO
THE MAJORITY LEADER'S POINT
THIS MAY BE IN FACT THE SINGLE
LARGEST CLIMATE INVESTMENT IN
OUR STATE'S HISTORY BUT I DO
JUST WANT TO SHARE THAT WE ARE
CONTINUING TO LEAVE SOUTH LA
OUT A COMMUNITY POPULATED BY
BLACK AND BROWN FAMILIES. ON A
NON CLIMATE RELATED NOTE THAT
IS ALSO IN THIS BUDGET I DO
WANT TO SHARE THAT I THINK TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
THE COURT APPOINTED SPECIAL
ADVOCATES IS A WALL FULL AMOUNT
GIVEN THE WORKLOAD AND THE
NUMBER OF YOUTH THAT ARE IN OUR
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM IN LOS
ANGELES. THESE ARE CHILDREN WHO
ARE ABUSED AND NEGLECTED AND
ARE UNDER THE CARE OF THE
DEPENDENCY COURT- CHILD WELFARE
CASES IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY OR
AT A FOURTEEN YEAR HIGH IN LOS
ANGELES AND WE WANT TO CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT- CASA OR COURT
APPOINTED SPECIAL ADVOCATES IN
THE INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT WORK
THAT THEY DO TO PROTECT OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE IN THE SYSTEM. SO
HOPEFULLY THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO WORK ON
AND THE BUDGET YEARS IN THE
FUTURE. YOU KNOW I ALSO WANT TO
SAY I KNOW THAT OUR MAJORITY
LEADER ENUMERATED A NUMBER OF
GOOD THINGS THAT ARE IN THIS
BILL I WANT TO ADD TO THAT-
FUNDING FOR HYDROGEN REFUELLING
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND ALSO
FUNDING FOR ZERO EMISSION
FLEETS. AND I ALSO WANT TO ADD
THAT OF ALL OF THE
CONSERVANCY'S THAT ARE IN THIS
STATE THE BALDWIN HILLS
CONSERVANCY GOT THE LEAST
AMOUNT OF MONEY- AND SO I ALSO
FEEL COMPELLED TO REGISTER MY
DISCONTENT. WITH THAT
ALLOCATION AGAIN- YOU KNOW THE
FISH IN SANTA MONICA ARE
ACTUALLY GETTING MORE MONEY
THAN THE BALDWIN HILLS
CONSERVANCY. AND THIS
CONSERVANCY SERVICES
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT ARE
IDENTIFIED AS DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. BASED ON THEIR
MEDIAN INCOME. AND HIS LOCATION
FALLS UNDER THE TOP 20% OF THE
MOST ENVIRONMENTALLY POLLUTED.
AND SOCIALLY VULNERABLE AREAS
IN CALIFORNIA AS MEASURED BY
THE CAL ENVIRO SCAM. YOU KNOW
THIS CONSERVANCY HAS AQUATIC
MIGRATORY BIRDS AND WETLAND
ECOSYSTEMS IS WORKING ON FUEL
TREATMENT PROJECTS TO REDUCE
WILDFIRE RISK. AND TO PROMOTE
WATERSHED HEALTH AND TO PROTECT
OUR WATERSHED TRIBUTARIES. AND
DAY HERE- DEPARTMENT SAY THAT
SOUTH LA IS NOT A PRIORITY IT'S
NOT CONSIDERED A HIGH RISK IS
REALLY INSULTING TO ME. AND MY
THE NEIGHBORS AND THE
CONSTITUENCIES AND THE
RESIDENTS OF THE BALL HOWARD
HILLS AND SURROUNDING AREAS
THAT I REPRESENT- JUST BECAUSE
WE ARE NOT ON FIRE AT THIS
MOMENT. DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE'RE
NOT AT RISK AND IT ALSO DOESN'T
MEAN THAT WE DON'T HAVE THE
ONLY URBAN CONSERVANCY IN THIS
STATE. THAT SERVICES THE KINDS
OF COMMUNITIES THAT WE
ROUTINELY TALK ABOUT MAKING
THIS GREAT STATE MORE
ACCESSIBLE TO. SO WHILE I STAND
IN COMPLETE SUPPORT FOR SB ONE
SEVENTY I WOULD JUST CONTINUE
WHAT TO URGE US TO CONSIDER.
COMMUNITIES LIKE SOUTH LA IN
THE URBAN CENTERS OF LOS
ANGELES THAT WILL CONTINUE TO
DESERVE AN EQUITABLE SHARE OF
THESE KINDS OF BUDGET DOLLARS
THANK YOU. SENATOR PENN. HE MET
PRESIDENT- CENTERS- I TO
SURPRISE IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE
SEVENTY AND- ONE TWO A FIRST OF
ALL OF COURSE- I APPRECIATE
THAT TREMENDOUS WORK BY THE-
BUDGET STAFF OR BUDGET CHAIR-
AND BUDGETS OF CHAIRS AND DOES
WELLS ARE- PRO TEM AS WELL AND-
YOU KNOW CERTAINLY- THIS BUDGET
PRESENTED A TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY TO DEAL WITH- SOME
VERY SERIOUS ISSUES FACING OUR
STATE AND ACTUALLY THE WORLD SO
I KNOW THAT MUCH HAS BEEN
TALKED ABOUT IN TERMS OF THE
WORK ON CLIMATE CHANGE I DID
WANT. TO ALSO JUST BRIEFLY MAKE
REFERENCES WERE I TALKING ABOUT
THE WORLD- DESCENDED CREDIT
CLIMATE CRISIS WE'RE SILL
DOING IT BECAUSE OF IT SO IN IN
IN THIS- BUDGET JUNIOR BILL WE
ARE GOING TO BE- PUTTING IN
HALF A BILLION DOLLARS OF
FUNDING TO THE DEPARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH TO ADDRESS- COVE
IN TERMS LAB CAPACITY SO FORTH
ANOTHER EIGHT HUNDRED ACTS ON
THIS NINE HUNDRED- MILLION ARE
ALMOST A BILLION DOLLARS TO TRY
TO KEEP OUR SCHOOLS OPENING
KEEPER KIDS SAFE. AS WELL AS-
SOME ADDITIONAL- FUNDING TO
PUBLIC HEALTH TO TRY TO
ADDRESS. DISPARITIES AND
ADVERSITY COVE IN NINETEEN
RESPONSE ACTIVITIES TO ADDRESS
RACIAL ETHNIC DISPARITIES AND
OTHER DISPARITIES FOR
UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS SO I DO
APPRECIATE THAT THOSE ARE
MAINLY FEDERAL FUNDS I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE CONTINUE
TO EXERCISE OVERSIGHT- AND- THE
EASE OF THOSE FUNDS AS A
LEGISLATURE- BUT DO APPRECIATE
THAT- WE ARE MAKING SOME
SERIOUS INVESTMENTS HERE
THEY'RE GONNA BE VERY IMPORTANT
AND- AND THAT- YEAH. WE NEED TO
HAVE A OF WORK TO DO REGARDING-
COVETED AND- AND ENOUGH OF IT
ALSO MAKE NOTE THE- THE
PRESIDENT AS WELL AS SAYS
TAKING SOME ADDITIONAL STEPS-
TODAY WITH HIS OWN AUTHORITY
AND- AND- WE NEED TO. BE SURE
WE FOLLOW UP ON THOSE AS WELL
AND FINALLY- IS- THE SENATOR
WHO REPRESENTS- PERHAPS THE
DISTRICT WITH- THE LARGEST
NUMBER OF AFGHAN REFUGEES- AND-
AND- AFGHAN AMERICANS- HERE AND
IN THIS STATE ACTUALLY WON THE
LARGEST TUBS IN THE- IN THE
COUNTRY. I DO APPRECIATE THAT-
THE STATE HAS ALSO- STEPPING UP
AND WE'VE INCLUDED THIS BUDGET.
FUNDING TO HELP THOSE REFUGEES
AND- OTHER PEOPLE HAVE HELPED
SUPPORTED OUR OUR TROOPS IN
AFGHANISTAN AND- AND THAT- WE
WILL- TRY TO WELCOME THEM AND
PROVIDE THEM THE SUPPORT THEY
NEED- STATE AND TRY TO SALVAGE
AND YOU LIVE HERE IN. OUR
COUNTRY AND PARTICULARLY HERE
IN CALIFORNIA CERTAINLY MANY
OTHER EXCELLENT THINGS AND
THIS- BUDGET AS WELL BUT I DID
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THESE
PARTICULAR ITEMS SO I URGE AN I.
VOTED ON SB ONE SEVENTY THANK
YOU. SENATOR I. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT WE SHOULD HAVE A
CLEAR UNDERSTANDING OF THE
IMPACTS ECONOMIC IMPACTS AS
WELL AS THE CLIMATE IMPACTS OF
WHAT WE'RE GOING TO RIGHT NOW.
I WANT TO THANK THE STAFF FOR
ALL THE- THE CHAIRS IN THE BAY
HI- FOR A GREEN TO HOW ROAD LAW
IN ECONOMIC RESILIENCE PROGRAM
I THINK THAT'S A BIG STEP FOR.
AND THIS IS ABOUT PRIORITY HIGH
QUALITY JOBS AND EQUITABLE
ACCESS TO THEM- WE WILL HAVE A
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE ARE%
RELATED TO HIGH ROAD METRICS
MEANING EQUITY JOB QUALITY AND
SUSTAINABILITY JOB CREATION
WAGES AND JOB RETENTION AND
FRANKLY THAT'S WHAT WE SHOULD
HAVE IN ALL OF OUR SPENDING AND
GRANT PROGRAMS IF WE REALLY.
ARE COMMITTED. TO A SUSTAINABLE
INCLUSIVE WORKER CENTER. FAMILY
CENTERED ECONOMY THAT WORKS FOR
EVERYONE. LAST YEAR'S REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE ENTITLED
PUTTING CALIFORNIA ON THE HIGH
ROAD A JOBS AND CLIMATE ACTION
PLAN FOR TWENTY THIRTY.
EMPHASIZE THAT INVESTMENTS IN
INFRASTRUCTURE ALONE. ALONE
WILL NOT CREATE HIGH QUALITY
QUALITY JOBS WE NEED TO
INCENTIVIZE BOTH THE SUPPLY AND
THE DEMAND SIDE. IN ORDER TO
CREATE HIGH ROAD FAMILY
SUSTAINED SUSTAINING JOBS AND
MAKING SURE THAT THERE IS THE
TRAINING NECESSARY FOR THESE
MEN AND WOMEN TO BE SUCCESSFUL
ON THE JOB SO. THE
COMPLEMENTING COLLUSION OF THE
HIGH ROAD LANGUAGE AND- I THINK
AS WE MOVE FORWARD ON THIS
INVESTMENT IN THE CLIMATE
CRISIS. THAT WE NEED TO BE MORE
EXPLICIT ABOUT THE CONNECTION
BETWEEN JOBS AND THAT CLIMATE
ACTION PLAN THANK YOU. IS THERE
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SENATOR NELSON. NOT A
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMAN
SAID THAT WE DO NEED TO MOVE
ALONG WITH THE BUDGET I AM
GONNA LAY OFF ON THIS ONE AS
WELL IN PART BECAUSE OF
PROCESS. AND THE FACT THAT
WE'RE NOT I'M NOT REALLY CLEAR
AS MUCH AS I'D LIKE TO BE AS
WHAT IS GOING TO BE IN IT AND
WHAT THE LONG TERM OBLIGATIONS
ARE I WILL NOTE THAT. THE
BUDGET DOES. THE EXPANDED LONG
TERM OBLIGATIONS OF NATION
BUILDING OF THE BUDGET WHICH
WILL AFFECT US IN THE FUTURE.
BUT THAT'S NOT THE ITEM AT HAND
RIGHT NOW I'M JUST SAYING THAT
I AM NOT TO. SUFFICIENTLY
CONVINCED THAT IT'S THIS IS THE
RIGHT BILL THERE WILL BE SOME
OF THE BUDGET BILLS THAT I WILL
SUPPORT THERE WILL BE SOME THAT
I DO NOT SUPPORT. THIS ONE I'M
GOING TO STAND FOR NOW. SENATOR
BATES. QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR
PLEASE WOULD YOU ACCEPT A
QUESTION SHE WAS. HI IN OUR
ANALYSIS IS NOT A REAL
SPECIFICITY ON WHAT OF THE
CLEARLY CLOSE TO ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IT'S GOING FOR FROM
WILDFIRES AND I THINK THAT THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT YOU KNOW
WE'VE ALL EXPERIENCED REMOTELY
EXCEPT THE GOOD SENATOR FROM
SENATOR SENATOR FROM BEAVER.
AND WHAT HAMPERED SOME OF THE
EFFORTS ARE A LOT OF THE
EFFORTS IS THAT THE HELICOPTERS
COULD NOT FLY WITH THE INTENT
OF SMOKE SO THIS IS A SPECIFIC
ASKED IN TERMS OF THE ROMANIAN
THERE FOR- PURCHASING
HELICOPTERS THAT ARE ADVANCING
CAN ACTUALLY DO THAT JOHN.
THOSE ARE THINGS THAT I KNOW
WHEN WE GET TO OUR DISTRICT
WILL BE SPECIFIC QUESTIONS JUST
WHAT IS GOING FOR ON THAT
PARTICULAR PROBLEM AND
CERTAINLY ALL THE PROJECTS THAT
THE SENATOR FROM. BEAVER
MANSIONS DO WE HAVE A TIME LINE
ON ALL WHEN THEY'RE GOING TO
BECOME. YEAH. IN THE JUNE
BUDGET ACTION THAT WAS
UNRELATED TO. WE DID MONEY FOR
HELLO YOU HAVE SO THERE WERE A
IS MONEY IN- IN THAT BUDGET NOW
IN THE WILDFIRE ADDITIONAL
WILDFIRE MONIES WE HAVE BEFORE
US TODAY WHICH AUGMENTS THE
EARLY ACTION ONES. WHILE DATE
IN MOST CASES DO NOT SPECIFY
THE PARTICULAR PROJECTS FOR
EXAMPLE THAT OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM- A BEAVER REFERENCED ON IT
THEY FIND THE CONSERVANCY'S WHO
CAN IN TURN FUND THOSE
PROJECTS. ARENDT IT ALSO OF
COURSE FINDS CAL FIRE AND THE-
OTHER CONSERVATION CORES AND
SUCH THAT ARE EITHER DOING THE
WORK OF THE- CREATING A BUFFER
ZONES AND SUCH OR FIGHTING THE
FIRES RIGHT NOW. THANK YOU FOR
THAT ON MY OWN TIME MEMBERS I
THINK THE DIFFICULTY THAT WE
HAVE IN EXPLAINING WHAT WE'RE
DOING HERE. WITH THE MONEY THAT
THE PROCREATIVE NEEDS VERY VERY
IMPORTANT AREAS BEING ABLE TO
SAY WE'RE GOING TO DO X. Y. AND
Z. AND IT'S GOING TO BE
DELIVERED ON A CERTAIN TIME.
BECAUSE OFTEN NOW- WE HAVE
DONALD HILL SO MUCH WORK DONE
APPRECIATE THAT BUT FOR US
INDIVIDUALLY SINCE WE HAVE NOT
BEEN DIRECTLY INVOLVED IN THE
NEGOTIATIONS ARE PUT THIS ALL
TOGETHER IT'S DIFFICULT TO
ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS THAT WE
GET FROM PEOPLE WHO HAVE
SUFFERED THE SEVERE DAMAGE SO
I'M JUST SAYING GOING FORWARD.
IT WOULD BE HELPFUL IF WE GET
MORE OF LINE ITEMS THAT ARE
UNDER CONSIDERATION THOSE ARE
THINGS THAT WE CAN BE
DISCUSSING ENOUGH. IN THE
FUTURE SESSIONS BUT I THINK
WE'RE EXTREMELY IMPORTANT IN
ACCOUNTABILITY- TO THE PEOPLE
OF OUR STATE WHO HAVE REALLY
SUFFERED SO MANY OF THESE
HORRIBLE ON CLIMATE CHANGE
IMPACTS SO THANK YOU BUT TANK
YOU FOR YOUR- WORK I KNOW IT'S
BEEN A- LONG HARD. JOURNEY. TO
TODAY AND WE DO APPRECIATE THAT.
SENATOR MCGUIRE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH BETTER PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS- FIRST AND FOREMOST I
DON'T RISE OFTEN TO BE ABLE TO
TALK ON THE FLOOR BUT I WANTED
TO BE ABLE TO TALK SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT CLIMATE. IN WILDFIRE.
ALONG WITH THE GOOD SENATOR
FROM BEAVER. AND SO MANY IN
THIS CHAMBER. WE'VE BEEN HIT
INCREDIBLY HARD. BY A SEVERITY
WILDFIRES. LAKE COUNTY FOR
EXAMPLE IN THE GREAT NORTH
COAST IS THE FIRST COUNTY WHERE
NEARLY TWO THIRDS OF ITS ENTIRE
LANDMASS IS NOW BURNED SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN. THE ALARM
IN THE STATE COULD NOT BE
LOUDER. THE CLIMATE CRISIS IS
NOT HYPOTHETICAL IT'S HERE. AND
WE SEE EVIDENCE ALL AROUND US.
HUNDREDS OF SCIENTISTS WITH THE
UNITED NATIONS
INTERGOVERNMENTAL PANEL ON
CLIMATE CHANGE AGREE. WE WILL
SEE AN AVERAGE TEMPERATURE
INCREASE OF ONE AND A HALF
DEGREES CELSIUS UNLESS WE TAKE
IMMEDIATE ACTION. AND IN FACT
CALIFORNIA IS THAT CANARY IN
THE COAL MINE FOR NORTH AMERICA.
HERE IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA FORESTS
WERE ALREADY SEEN AN INCREASE.
IN TEMPERATURES. IN THE HOTTEST
MONTHS AND INTO THE FALL YOU
TALK WITH GRIZZLED CAL FIRE
VETERANS WHO'VE BEEN ON THE
FIRE LINES FOR THIRTY FORTY
YEARS. THEY'RE SEEING A CHANGE
IN FIRE BEHAVIOR WHAT IS WORKED
OVER THE PAST FEW DECADES IN
CALIFORNIA IN THE WEST NO
LONGER WORKS BECAUSE OF THE
SEVERITY OF THE CRISIS AT HAND.
CALIFORNIA'S FIRE SEASON HAS
EXPLODED IN THE LAST DECADE.
MORE THAN FOUR MILLION ACRES 4%
OF THE ENTIRE LAND MASS OF THE
GOLDEN STATE HAS BURNED IN JUST
ONE RECORD SETTING YEAR AND
THAT WAS LAST YEAR. THE NUMBER
OF DRY WARM AND WINDY DAYS IN
THE FALL IN CALIFORNIA DOUBLED
SINCE THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES AND
WELL WE HAVE TAKEN SIGNIFICANT
STEPS WE KNOW THAT THERE IS
MORE TO DO. BUT SOMETIMES I
FEEL LIKE IN THIS BUILDING IN
PARTICULAR. WE TALK ABOUT WHAT
HAVE YOU DONE FOR ME LATELY.
BUT I JUST WANT TO BRING
ATTENTION TO WHAT. THIS CHAMBER
ON A BIPARTISAN BASIS ALONG
WITH THE GOVERNOR HAS DONE.
TODAY THIS THREE POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS IT'S BEEN LED
BY THE STATE SENATE. WITH
LEADERS IN THESE CHAMBERS. AND
IT'S THE NEXT THREE YEARS ARE
GOING TO HELP US CONTINUE TO
LEAD NORTH AMERICA ON THE ISSUE
OF THE CLIMATE CRISIS IN IT'S
BEEN ED WITH FOLKS LIKE
PROTEIN MACHEN'S. THIS
LEGISLATION IS GOING TO CHANGE
THE WAY THAT WE APPROACH. THE
CLIMATE CRISIS HOW WE FIGHT IT
HOW WE ADAPT HOW WE WORK. AND
HOW WE MOVE OUR COMMUNITIES
FORWARD. THIS BUDGET IS WE'VE
HEARD OTHER MEMBERS SAY
REPRESENTS THE SINGLE LARGEST
INVESTMENT IN CLIMATE
RESILIENCY IN THE HISTORY OF
THE GOLDEN STATE. ANY INCLUDES
DOZENS OF PRIORITIES THAT
WORKING FAMILIES UP AND DOWN
THIS COAST DESPERATELY NEED. I
WANT TO TALK FINALLY THE
PRESIDENT ON THE ISSUE OF
SCIENCE. IF YOU LOOK AT THE
AVERAGE ACRES BURNED OVER THE
LAST TWENTY YEARS IT WAS ABOUT
EIGHT HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THOUSAND. PER YEAR. IF YOU LOOK
AT JUST THE LAST FIVE YEARS IN
CALIFORNIA WE'VE GONE FROM
EIGHT HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THOUSAND ACRES PER YEAR TO
NEARLY ONE POINT SIX MILLION
ACRES PER YEAR. WHAT WE DID
THIS YEAR. IT'S HISTORIC BUT WE
KNOW IT NEEDS TO BECOME THE
NORM. WE HAVE INVESTED A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIVE MILLION
FOR FOREST HEALTH FOR FOREST
THINNING DEAD AND DYING TREE
MOVE ON WILDFIRE FUEL BREAKS A
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILLION FOR
A WHILE FOR ME TO GREET
MITIGATION GRANTS. AT NEARLY
FOURTEEN ADDITIONAL CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CREWS ARE NOW ON
THE LINE STARTING FIRING
THINNING FORESTS FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS HAS BEEN
ALLOCATED TO THE NATIONAL GUARD
TO BE ABLE TO ESTABLISH MORE
HAND CREWS TO BRING THEM FROM
SIX MONTHS TO TEN MONTHS. WE
HAVE PURCHASED SEVEN C. ONE
THIRTY CARGO PLANES FROM THE
COAST GUARD THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
DEPLOYING IN ALL CORNERS OF
THIS GREAT STATE IN THE YEARS
TO COME. TWELVE BLACK HAWK
HELICOPTERS HAVE NOW BEEN
PURCHASED BY THE STATE BY THE
WAY FIVER NOW IN STATE FIGHTING
FIRES NOT JUST DURING THE DAY
BUT FINALLY FIGHTING FIRES AT
NIGHT. WHETHER IT'S THE
CALENDAR FIRE. OR THE FIRES IN
THE NORTH BAY. I JUST WANT TO
END IT RIGHT HERE. THIS WOULD
NOT HAVE HAPPENED WITHOUT THE
BUDGET SET TO CHAIR NO ONE
ACKNOWLEDGED HIM. FROM FREMONT
FOR ALL THIS WORK. THE GREAT
BUDGET YEAR THAT WE HAVE. AND
HONESTLY WITHOUT REPUBLICANS
AND DEMOCRATS WORKING TOGETHER.
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT WE CAN
ALL AGREE UPON. BUT WE GOT A
LOT OF WORK TO DO. AND I KNOW
WHETHER YOU ARE LIVING IN
BEAVER OR YOU'RE LIVING IN LAKE
COUNTY. WE HAVE TO FOCUS ON THE
CRISIS AT HAND. WE HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO INVEST IN THIS
ISN'T JUST A STATE PROBLEM
WHETHER IT'S A REPUBLICAN
ADMINISTRATION OR DEMOCRATIC
ADMINISTRATIONTHE WHITE HOUSE
THE FOREST SERVICE HAS TO GET
THEIR ACT TOGETHER. AND START
FOR KENTUCKY SEEN ON THE 57% OF
THE LAND IN THIS NATION IN THIS
STATE THAT IS OWNED AND MANAGED
BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. AND
THAT'S AN ISSUE FOR DONALD
TRUMP IN JOE BIDEN COMBINED. I
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU TO JOIN ROY. THANK YOU
JAMES HACKER THANK YOU TO KEEP
LIVER THESE THREE IN OUR ALL
SENATE STAFF AND THEY'VE BEEN
WORKING DAY AND NIGHT TO BE
ABLE TO HELP DELIVER THIS
PACKAGE ALONG WITH THE CARD I
MEAN OF COURSE IS WELL FROM THE
PROTEINS F. AS IN OF COURSE
PROTEIN MACHEN'S I DO I THINK
WE OWE THEM A DEBT OF GRATITUDE
AND A THANK YOU AND MADAM
PRESIDENT I'M SORRY TO GO ON SO
LONG BUT LOOK FOR THIS. SEGMENT
CONTINUED TO LEAD THE NATION
WHEN IT COMES TO INVESTING TO
COMBAT OUR CLIMATE CRISIS.
SENATOR SKINNER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO ADOPT THAT IS YOUR CLOSING.
ACTUALLY NO BUT I DO APPRECIATE
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
I'M CALLING FROM HEALDSBURG
GAVE THAT THANKS TO THE STAFF
AND THEIR OTHER STUFF YOU
DIDN'T MENTION BUT THEY DO I
MEAN THIS AS OUR US SENATOR
FROM- AN APOLOGY- HIS FATE AND
I'M NOT RECALLING EXACTLY THE
CITY THAT YOU REPRESENT LIKE
UNITY GAL. REFERENCED THIS. YOU
KNOW WHAT I HAVE MENTIONED THAT
THIS IS THE LARGEST INVESTMENT.
IN IT'S ARGUABLY THE LARGEST
INVESTMENT IN OUR- GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS REDUCTION
PROGRAMS BUT IT DEFINITELY IN
OUR CLIMATERESILIENCY IS ALSO
KNOWN AS CLIMATE ADAPTATION
PROGRAMS BUT IT'S ALSO THE
LARGEST BUDGET THIS IS STATE IS
EVER EVER ADOPTED. AND IT'S
COMPLEX IT'S A LOT OF MONEY AND
THE STAFF HAVE BEEN WORKING
THEIR TAILS OFF SINCE BEFORE
JANUARY AND YOU CAN THINK WELL
WHY BEFORE JANUARY SINCE THE
GOVERNOR ONLY INTRODUCED THAT
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO BE PREPARED
THE- L. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND OTHERS GIVE YOU THE REVENUE
PROJECTIONS AND SUCH BACK THEN
AND SO YOU START WORKING THEN
AND THEN YOU WORK FURTHER. ONCE
THE GOVERNOR IN TRADUCIDA
JANUARY BUDGET AND THEN YOU
WORK EVEN FURTHER AS WE HOLD
ALL OUR HEARINGS AND DEVELOP IT
AND THE REST OF IT SO THEY DO
DESERVE INCREDIBLE THANKS
BECAUSE THEY HAVE WORKED VERY
HARD AND I WILL NOT TRY TO SAY
ALL OF THEIR NAMES BECAUSE I DO
NOT WANT TO MISS ANYONE BUT
THERE ARE MANY NOT ONLY IN
BUDGET STUFF BUT- POLICY
COMMITTEES THE PROTEIN STAFF
MANY OF YOUR PERSONAL STAFF AND
OF COURSE ALL THE MEMBERS WHO
WORKED ON IT. BUT WHAT I WOULD
LIKE TO JUST COME IN ON VERY
BRIEFLY IS THAT. THAT'S MEMBERS
AS WE AS OUR COLLEAGUES HAVE
MADE REALLY GOOD. FLOOR REMARKS
ON WHAT'S BEFORE US. MY
DAUGHTER SENT ME A PHOTO. OF MY
NEW GRAND BABY WAS THREE MONTHS
TODAY. THAT GRAND BABY. LIVES
IN AN AREA. THAT IS HIGHLY
IMPACTED. BY AIR AND CLIMATE
POLLUTING EMISSIONS FROM GOODS
MOVEMENT. TRUCK SANTA TRAIN.
FROM A REFINERY. SHE ALSO LIVES
IN CALIFORNIA SO THAT MEANS
LIKE ALL OF US SHOULD BE
SUBJECTED TO FIRE ANY DAY. HE
ALSO LIVES. IN A GLOBE THAT WE
HAVE POLLUTED TO THE POINT
WHERE WE ARE IN THE CLIMATE
CRISIS WARRANTS. AND I THINK
ALL OF US NOT JUST FOR HER BUT
FOR ALL OF OUR CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN. AND THEIR
CHILDREN AND GRANDCHILDREN WANT
TO DO OUR BEST TO REVERSE THE
DAMAGE THAT WE'VE DONE. AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
WITH THIS BUDGET AND NO IT DOES
NOT ADDRESS EVERYTHING NOR WILL
IT REVERSE EVERYTHING. BUT IT
IS SIGNIFICANT AND SIZEABLE AND
WE SHOULD BE PROUD OF IT AND WE
SHOULD RESIST ANYONE WHO TRIES
TO TELL US THAT WE ARE NOT
PUTTING OUR MONEY WHERE OUR
MOUTH IS. YES WE COULD DO MORE
AND NO IT WILL NOT REVERSE
EVERYTHING AND WE HAVE TO
CLOSELY FOLLOW THAT WHICH- IS
IN WHAT WE'VE DIRECTED IF IT IS
NOT. ACCOMPLISHING OUR
INTENTIONS THAT WE MAKE
REVISIONS NEXT YEAR AND ON THE
ISSUES OF DO WE HAVE THE
DETAILS OF HOW EACH OF THESE
THINGS ARE GOING TO BE SPENT
YET MANY OF THIS IS GRANT
PROGRAMS AND WE HAVE THE RIGHT
AND WE WILL RECEIVE. DETAILED
BACK FROM THOSE GRANT PROGRAMS
AS TO WHO THEY FIND IT ONWHAT
THEY FIND IT. AND IF WE FEEL
THAT IT WAS NOT DIRECTED IN THE
WAYS THAT WE FEEL ARE
APPROPRIATE THEN WE CAN ADD NEW
CRITERIA A NEW- PARAMETERS
BLIPS IN IN OUR FUTURE YEARS.
SO I. FEEL I CAN NEVER DO
ENOUGH FOR OUR MY GRAND BABY
AND ARE ALL OF OUR CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN BUT I CERTAINLY
FEEL THAT WE'RE DOING A LOT AND
I CAN SLEEP BETTER AND WITH
THAT I SP RIGHT. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I
FACE. BACKER I FORGES. BRADFORD
I KERR BY OTHER HIGH COURTS HAS
HE HI DALLY NO DOG. I TORONTO
HI EGGMAN BLAZER I CONSOLIDATE
FIVE GROVE. HERTZBERG HI WITH
SO HI HER TADO I JONES NO
CAMCORDER I LAYERED HI LLEVA I
LIVE ALONE. I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN FIVE
NIELSEN. BUT SHOW A VOGUE. PAM
HI PERSON TINA I BROUGHT FIVE
RUBIO FIVE SKINNER I STERN
NUMBERHI MIKE HOW SKI I WINNER.
I WILL. PLEASE CALL THE OB TO
MEMBERS. FAITH PORCHES. EGGMAN
GROVE. MELINDA'S NIELSEN BUT
SHOW UP BOTH STERN WELL I THINK.
NO PRICE TWENTY NINE KNOWS
THREE THE MEASURE PASSES REMOVE
ONTO FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE FORTY
SIX. SENATOR SKINNER. OKAY
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ONE FIFTY FIVE BY
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
AND FISCAL REVIEW AND ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC RESOURCES IN
MAKING APPROPRIATIONS AIRPORTS
EXPECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET SENATOR SKINNER
FORAGERS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS SP ONE FIFTY
FIVE IS THE TRAILER BILL TO
IMPLEMENT THE RESOURCES THINGS
WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING IT
REQUIRES AN AGENCY TO ANNUALLY
REPORT AND THIS IS WHERE WE
WILL GET THE DATA AN EARLY
REPORT ON ALL PROGRAMS RELATED.
TO WILDFIRES IN FLORENCE
RESILIENCE THAT THEY FUNDED
PURSUANT TO OUR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET ACT. UNTIL TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE IT EXEMPTS FROM
SEAPORT BIODIVERSITY PROJECTS
THAT CONSERVE RESTORE FOR
CHAPPED OR ASSIST IN THE
RECOVERY OF CALIFORNIA NATIVE
WHICH FISH SORRY DATE OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE OR THEIR HABITATS
UPON WHICH THEY DEPEND. NOW
THIS EXEMPTION IS EXTREMELY
LIMITED IN ITS APPLICATION IT
DOES NOT APPLY TO THE DELTA
CONVEYANCE PROJECT AND THERE IS
NO LEGITIMACY TO THE CLAIM THAT
THE DELTA CONVEYANCE PROJECT
CAN USE THIS EXEMPTION THE
DELTA CONVEYANCE IS ABOUT
MOVING WATER IT IS NOT ABOUT
RESTORING HABITAT AND IT DOES
NOT MEET ANY OF THE CRITERIA.
THAT IS SET FORTH IN THIS
EXEMPTION. BUT BILL ALL EXTEND
THE PROHIBITION OF COMMUNITY
WATER SYSTEMS FROM CUTTING OFF
THE WATER SERVICE TO CUSTOMERS.
SO THAT- WHO WERE UNABLE TO PAY
THEIR BILLS IT EXTENDS THAT TO
THE END OF THIS YEAR. AND
MEMBERS I ASK YOUR RIVALS.
SENATOR NELSON. MADAM PRESIDENT
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THE SENATE
THIS. THEY'LL HAVE A
PARTICULARLY ONEROUS PROVISION
IN IT. IT HAS A HISTORY AND I
WON'T GO INTO IT AND TOO AWFUL
MUCH DEPTH SEVERAL YEARS AGO A
FORMER ADMINISTRATION. GAVE TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS OF OUR BUDGET FOR THE
REMOVAL OF FOUR DAMS ON THE
KLAMATH RIVER. NOW SOME OF US
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH JUST
REMOVING DAMS PERIOD. BUT THERE
ARE IMPLICATIONS TO THIS THAT
ARE SIGNIFICANT. AND IT WOULD
BE RELATED IN FACT TO THIS
PARTICULAR BILL. NOW THAT
OBLIGATION. IS EVEN GREATER.
WHAT DO I NEED. I HAVE A
LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL OPINION
FROM EARLY SPRING THAT I
REQUESTED. AND IF THESE DAMS
ARE REMOVED THE ENORMOUS FED
IMITATION BEHIND THOSE DAMS IS
GONNA WORK. DOWNSTREAM. THEN
OUT OF THE HUMBLE DAY
PARTICULARLY. AND WHAT IS THAT
GOING TO DO. TO THE FISH
HABITAT. DISASTROUS THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS WHO DEMANDED THAT
WE REMOVE THOSE DAMS. I WONDER
WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO SAY. WHEN
ALL OF THAT HABITAT. FOR THE
FISH BREEDING. AND SPAWNING IS
DESTROYED. I GUESS I'LL
PROBABLY SAY NOTHING. BUT IT IS
VERY IMPORTANT TO NOTE THE
LEDGE COUNCIL OPINION FURTHER
EMPHASIZED THAT THE CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA. IF THERE ARE ANY
LAWSUITS PURSUANT TO THE MOVIES
AND DANCE AND THE IMPACT THERE
FROM. TEXAS CALIFORNIA ARE
GOING TO BE RESPONSIBLE. FOR
THAT. NOW WE ALREADY HAVE. CASE
LAW. THE- BLIGE'S STATE
OBLIGATION FOR LANDS THAT ARE
FLOODED. THAT'S BEEN A QUIET
ISSUE MOST PEOPLE DON'T TALK
ABOUT THAT IT'S VERY REAL AND
VERY REAL IN WHAT WE'RE DEALING
WITH HERE. IN THIS LEGISLATION
THE REMOVAL OF THE VAN. I STILL
ARGUE WITH BAD POLICY. AND I
WANTED TO GIVE YOU THE CONTEXT
OF THIS SEGMENTATION. TWENTY
MILLION CUBIC YARDS. NO THAT
WOULD BE A PRODUCT OF ONE DUMP
TRUCK. EVERY MINUTE. EVERY DAY
FOR SIX YEARS. THAT'S WHAT
WOULD BE EXPECTED AND THAT'S
NOT EVEN THE HIGH PROJECTION.
THE SEDIMENTATION ACCUMULATED
OVER DECADES BEHIND THOSE. SO
THAT IS GOING TO AFFECT. OUR
NORTHERN COUNTIES. WHAT DOES
THIS HELP WELL ONE PARTICULAR.
VERY WEALTHY GENTLEMAN. IN HIS
CORPORATION ACQUIRED THESE DAMS
FOR POWER YEARS AGO. PROVED TO
NOT LEAD TO THE INVESTMENT. BUT
NOW THAT ENDED IS GOING TO TRY
GREAT. FROM WHAT WE'RE DOING
HERE WITH BILL. SO I WILL BE NO
ON THIS LEGISLATION HAS A
STATEMENT. NUMBER ONE ABOUT
POLICY REMOVING THEM WE DON'T
NEED TO BE REMOVING THE NEED TO
BE CONSTRUCTING AT LEAST ONE
THAT WE'VE GOT MONEY IN THE-
BUDGETED FOR BY THE VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA SEVERAL YEARS AGO.
THAT HASN'T GONE ANYWHERE IN
SEVEN YEARS. AND MAY NOT IN
ANOTHER SIX YEARS BEFORE WILL
STORE ANY WATER. IN THAT ONE
DAY. SO FOR THIS PARTICULAR
BILL I WOULD URGE AND I A NOBLE.
SENATOR DOLLY. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I. ALL RIGHTS
TO TALK ABOUT THE SAME ISSUE AS
MY FRIEND FROM TO HIM I
ACTUALLY REPRESENT. SISKIYOU
COUNTY AND THE DAMS THAT ARE
GONNA BE REMOVED I'M GONNA GO A
LITTLE MORE DEPTH SO YOU'LL
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S BEING
PROPOSED HERE. WHAT'S BEING
PROPOSED IS THAT. FIRST OF ALL
I WANT YOU DON'T KNOW WARREN
BUFFETT OWNS THESE DAMS HE'S
WEALTHY. GOT PLENTY OF MONEY.
AND BEHIND THESE DAMS AS
MERCURY THERE'S ARSENIC THERE'S
ALL KINDS OF THINGS IS GOING TO
BE RELEASED AS WE TEAR THESE
DAMS DOWN NOW THE FEDERAL
ENERGY REGULATORY COMMISSION
HAS DONE A STUDY TO HEAR THESE
DAMS DOWN. OUR TAX DOLLARS IN
THE STATE HAVE BEEN. ALLOCATED
SOME OF THEM FOR THIS PROJECT
AND THE RATE PAYERS HAVE PUT UP
SOME OF THE MONEY AS WELL. HEY
REGARDLESS IF YOU ARE FOR DAMS
ARE NOT DAMS MAKES NO
DIFFERENCE IN THIS CASE
BECAUSE- WHAT WE'RE DOING IS
WE'RE GIVING THEM A SEQUEL A-
EXEMPTION. FOR ALL OF YOU WHO.
CARE ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENT. AND
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ABIDE
BY OUR LAWS IN CALIFORNIA WHICH
IS THE SEQUEL LAW WHICH ALLOWS
YOU TO ENGAGE. WHEN SOMETHING'S
GOING TO HAPPEN AND IF IT'S NOT
MITIGATED PROPERLY YOU HAVE A
STAKE IN THE GAME THIS BILL.
WILL ALLOW SECRET TO BE WAIVED
JUST LIKE WE WOULD DO. FOR
SOMEBODY WANTS A SPORTS ARENA
IN SACRAMENTO. MIND YOU THERE
ARE HUNDREDS OF MILES OF RIVER
BELOW THESE DAMS THAT. NOBODY'S
GONNA BE ABLE TO COMMENT ON.
OTHER THAN THE PROCESS THEY
WENT THROUGH AT THE FEDERAL
ENERGY REGULATORY COMMISSION.
SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE
RESISTANCE THERE WERE SOME.
TALK ABOUT YOU KNOW ONE PARTY
HELPING OUT BIG BUSINESS OR THE
OTHER PARTY HELPING OUT BIG
BUSINESS WELL IN THIS CASE IF
YOU VOTE FOR THIS BILL YOUR
HELP IN WARREN BUFFET OUT AND
YOU'RE PENALIZING. EVERYBODY IN
SISKIYOU COUNTY THAT WANTS TO
HAVE A STAKE. ENGINE FIGURING
OUT WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN WHEN
THEY TEAR THESE DAMS DOWN THE
COUNTY DOESN'T DEAR YOU'RE
WAVING THEIR RIGHT. BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT GONNA HAVE THE
SEQUEL OPTION. TO PROTEST HOW
OR SEE A PLAN FOR HOW THESE
GAMES ARE GOING TO COME DOWN.
SO I JUST WANT YOU TO BE AWARE
I KNOW MOST PEOPLE PROBABLY
DON'T KNOW THAT'S IN THIS PIECE
OF LEGISLATION BUT IT'S IN
THERE. AND IT'S GONNA MAKE A
BIG DIFFERENCE. TO MY DISTRICT
AND IT'S ALSO GOING TO MAKE A
HUGE DISTRICT. TO THE CENTER
FOR HILLSBOROUGH. WHICH THE
RIVER RUNS THROUGH. AND INTO.
THE HUMBOLDT BAY. SO FOR THOSE
REASONS I'LL BE OPPOSING THIS
BILL THEY SHOULD NOT EVEN BE IN
THIS. A PIECE OF LEGISLATION
BUT IT IS SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
A NO VOTE ON SB ONE FIVE FIVE.
SENATOR HER DAUGHTER. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY
WITH SOME CONCERNS REGARDING AB
ONE FIFTY FIVE WELL THIS
TRAILER BILL DOES INCLUDE
IMPORTANT FUNDING TO ADDRESS
EXTREME HE AND COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE ISSUES I HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON TO ADDRESS IN MY
COMMUNITY AND OTHERS SINCE I
STARTED HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE
CONCERT WITH THE PAY INCREASE
THE BILL PROVIDES TO PUBLIC
UTILITY. COMMISSION MEMBERS UP
AT A TIME WHEN SIGNIFICANT
POTENTIAL RATE INCREASES ARE
BEING CONSIDERED UPWARDS OF 26%
AND WHEN PEOPLE ARE ALREADY
STRUGGLING TO MEET SKYROCKETING
ENERGY COSTS I'M NOT SURE WE
SHOULD BE PROVIDING THE PC
COMMISSION MEMBERS WITH THE
SALARY INCREASE OUTLINED IN
THIS BILL- BUT- STILL. FOR THIS
REASON I. WILL RELUCTANTLY-
SUPPORT SUPPORT THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION TODAY OR BY THE
TRAILER BILL THANK YOU. THERE
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE YES SENATOR JOHNSON.
AMERICA WANTED TO RISE A
DISCUSS ONE PARTICULAR PART OF
SP ONE FIFTY FIVE THAT I HAVE
SOME CONCERNS OVER AND IT'S THE
ALAMEDA TESLA EXPANSION AREA
FOR THE- H. V. PARK OF
CARNEGIE- HV PARK AND- YOU KNOW
I DON'T. I UNDERSTAND AND TRUST
THE SINCERITY OF THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND THE SENATOR THAT
REPRESENT THIS AREA. IN TRYING
TO FIND A SOLUTION FOR- THEIR
DISTRICTS ON- SOME OF THEIR
CONSTITUENTS THEY DON'T WANT
THIS SO H. V. PARK- TO BE
EXPANDED AND OR OPENED. BUT THE
BOTTOM LINE IS- THIS LAND WAS
PURCHASED IN NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT FOR NINE MILLION DOLLARS.
FOR THE PURPOSE OF BECOMING AN
O. H. V. PARK AND TO EXPAND
CARNEGIE- SIRVA. AND I DO
APPRECIATE I'M NOTICING HERE
THAT THERE'S OVER THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS BEING
TRANSFERRED FROM THE GENERAL
FUND TO. THE PARKS DEPARTMENT
ONE MILLION DOLLARS OF THAT
FROM THE GENERAL FUND OF PARKS
FOR THE PURPOSE OF.
DESIGNATING- THE BILL WOULD
PROHIBIT THE LAND FROM BECOMING
DOESN'T IT IS A STATE VEHICLE
RECREATION PARK BUT THEN ALSO
FIND YOU KNOW THE BEST USE FOR
IT. AND THEN TWENTY NINE POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
GENERAL FUND J. O. H. B. TRUST
FUND FOR PARKS TO ACQUIRE AND
DEVELOP PROPERTIES TO EXPAND
OHB RESTORATION WHICH HAS BEEN.
PRESENTED AS A AS A POTENTIAL
SOLUTION TO THIS PROBLEM AND I
WOULD AGREE THAT THAT WOULD BE
A POTENTIAL SOLUTIONS PROBLEM
IF. WE COULD TRUST THAT THERE
WOULD BE APPROPRIATE LAND
FOUND. AND ACQUIRED BY THE
STATE AND THEN ALLOWED TO
ACTUALLY BE BUILT AS AN O. H.
V. PARK I WOULD RECKON I WOULD
WELCOME THAT MY AREA OR
SOMEWHERE ELSE. IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA BUT I THINK IT WOULD
BE VERY NAIVE OF ANY OF US TO
THINK HERE ON THIS FLOOR TODAY.
THAT WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL
PRESSURES THAT ARE PUT ON THE
LEGISLATORS HERE IN SACRAMENTO
THAT WE WOULD EVER GET.
ENVIRONMENTAL CLEARANCE TO
EXPAND ANOTHER ALWAYS V. PARK
SOMEWHERE ELSE IN THE STATE- SO
WHAT THOSE CONCERNS I WILL BE
VOTING NO TODAY ON THIS BILL-
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
FEDERICO MAN YES MA'AM YES
MA'AM PRESENT THANK YOU I. RISE
IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE FIFTY FIVE
I WANT TO SHARE SOME COMMON.
SOME OR RESPOND TO SOME OF THE
COMMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN BEEN
MADE ENOUGH THAT I GET UP AND
TALK ABOUT. A SEQUEL EXEMPTION
THERE'S ALREADY BEEN A FINAL
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REPORT FOR
THE LOWER. KLAMATH RIVER WE'RE
JUST SAYING THAT IT SATISFIES
SEQUEL REQUIREMENTS SO THAT.
ALL THE NERVOUS NOW HE'S IN THE
ROOM WILL UNDERSTAND IT IT'S
THE ENVIRONMENTAL WORK HAS BEEN
DONE AND HAS BEEN. STEADY FOR A
LONG TIME. YOU KNOW IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT CALIFORNIA
GOVERNOR BROWN HOSTED A CLIMATE
GLOBAL CLIMATE CONFERENCE IN
SAN FRANCISCO AND I ATTENDED
THAT. AND THEY HAD AN EXHIBIT-
THAT INVOLVE THE ALAMEDA CREEK
AND THAT'S THE LARGEST
TRIBUTARY THAT FEEDS INTO- THE
SAN FRANCISCO BAY AND THEY HAVE
A PLAN THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
REMOVE THE CEMENT IN THE- END
THAT WAS PUT IN BY THE- ARMY
CORPS OF ENGINEERS TO ALLOW THE
NATIONAL. NATURAL FLUSHING OF
THE CREEK THE RIVER INTO SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AM I HAVING AND
THIS OCCURS DURING EXTREME.
STORM CONDITIONS AND THEY'RE
SAYING THAT HISTORICALLY THE
WATER WITH THE SENTIMENT WOULD
RUSH INTO THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AND NATURALLY SETTLE IN THE LOW
PLANTS AND THEY'RE-
ANTICIPATING THE DEATH THE
CONSEQUENCE WOULD BE THAT ONE
FOOT OF SEA LEVEL RISE WOULD BE
MITIGATED. BY THE BY RETURNING
THE NATURAL FLOW OF THE
SETTLEMENT. YOU KNOW THE
ENVIRONMENTALISTS AND THE FOLKS
HYDROLOGISTS HAVE HAVE STUDIED
THE UPPER KLAMATH RIVER AND I
THINK THE SCIENCE IS STILL OUT.
YES WHEN YOU HAVE AN EXTREME
WEATHER CONDITION ALL THE
LEGACY OF MERCURY TO TEN
EVERYWHERE FOR KIDS. MOVES
AROUND AND IT RE SETTLES BUT
THE HOPE IS THAT THE NATURAL
FLUSH WILL GO OUT TO THE
HUMBOLDT BAY AND LIKE IT DOES%
IN THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
RESETTLED THERE NATURALLY AND
HELP DESK AREA WHEN THEY HAVE
C. LEVEL RISE. SO THOSE REPORTS
WILL BECOME THAT INFORMATIONAL
BECOMING COMING FORWARD THERE'S
A LOT OF GOOD THINGS HERE
AND- THE TESLA PARK IS THE
SIERRA CLUB'S NUMBER ONE ASK
FOLKS TO SIT HERE THROUGH ALL
THE BUDGET STUFF ALL THE STUFF
WE DID ON CLIMATE. THEY'RE
ASKING FOR TESLA PARK IN ALL
RIGHT MY STAFF HAS RECEIVED
INFORMATION OR REQUESTS FROM
EXISTING OFF ROAD VEHICLE PARTS
THAT WANT TO DO EXPANSIONS THEY
WANT TO TAKE THAT TWENTY NINE
MILLION DOLLARS INTO THE
EXPANSION. SO LET'S NOT FORGET
THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION THIS
BILL FOR COASTAL CONSERVANCY
LET'S NOT FORGET THE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION FOR EXTREME
HEAT. LET'S NOT IN THE END-
FORGET THE I. CARPET IS GOING
TO DO A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
AND COMMUNITY RESILIENCY AND
ALSO THE- CARBON NEGATIVES IN
ABOUT- THE FUNDING THAT SIT
THERE. I HEARD TONIGHT PHOTO
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH EVERYBODY NEXT YEAR ON
IMPROVING AND OTHER RESOURCES
BUILT. SENATOR ALAN. MEMBERS I
WANT TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB
ONE FIFTY FIVE AS WELL- YOU
KNOW I WANT TO I DO WANT TO
ALSO JUST SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
SUPPORT FOR CONSERVANCIES- IN
THE END OF THE DAY THERE IS
DEDICATED FUND OF CONSERVANCIES
IN THERE'S LOTS OF THINGS THAT.
THAT- YEAH I HEAR I HEAR WHAT
PEOPLE BEEN SAYING I WILL SAY
THE CONSERVATIVES ARE PROVEN
PROGRAMS THAT SHOWN TIME AND
TIME AGAIN. THAT THEY CAN GET
THE MONEY OUT QUICKLY AND
EFFICIENTLY- YOU KNOW WE FROM
MY PERSPECTIVE I ABSOLUTELY
WANT TO SEE MORE MONEY- FOR
CONSERVATIVES IN THE OUT YEARS
I THINK WE ALSO. HAVE ONE OF
THEIR ISSUES COME UP. AS WE
LIKE TO SEE SOME DEDICATED
FUNDING TO ENSURE THAT MUSEUMS
AND CULTURAL CENTERS. CAN
CONTINUE TO BE EFFECTIVE
PARTNERS. IN OUR CLIMATE
EFFORTS AND THEY CAN ALSO GET
THE SUPPORT THEY NEED TO
HARDEN. THEIR BUILDINGS HAVE
BECOME MORE RESILIENT. AS I
CERTAINLY HOPE TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH OUR PARTNERS IN THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE TO SEE IF WE
CAN GET THOSE THE SOURCES
FUNDED BUT THERE'S- THIS IS A-
THIS IS. THIS THIS BILL
REPRESENTS A REALLY STORAGE
INVESTMENT- AND THERE'S MUCH TO
BE PROUD OF AND I URGE I HAVE A-
IS THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SAYING NONE. SENATOR SKINNER
YOU MAY CONCLUDE. THE ARRIVAL.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS I FACE NO CRACKER. HI
PORCHES NO BRADFORD I COME BY
IT- I PROTESTING HI DALLY NO
DODD I TORONTO I AGREE IN.
LASER I CONSOLIDATE HIGH GROWTH
NO HERTZBERG I WEAR SO HI HER
TADO I JONES NO CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I LLEVA HI THE MOON. I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S. MAN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. NO A TROUBLED
NO PAM HI FORTUNE TINA FIVE
ROTH I RUBIO I SKINNER. I TURN
ON BERG. BY CASKEY I WINNER I
WILL NO PLEASE CALL THE OB TO
MEMBERS. EGGMAN MELINDA'S NO
STERN AMBERG. PRICE TWENTY
EIGHT KNOWS NINE THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON TO ITEM ONE
FORTY SEVEN MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL ONE
SIXTY TWO BY THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AN ACT RELATING TO
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND MAKING
AN APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. SENATOR SKINNER
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS EIGHTY ONE SIXTY TWO-
SWEATER THAT'S B. ONE SIX TO
PREACH THE COMMUNITY ECONOMIC
RESILIENCE FINDS. AS INCLUDED
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
ACTUALLY DOCKED IN JUNE THE
PROGRAM PROVIDES COMPETITIVE
GRANTS TO REGIONAL
COLLABORATIVES TO DESIGN AND
IMPLEMENT ECONOMIC
DIVERSIFICATION RECOVERY AND
TRANSITION STRATEGIES. THIS
WILL BE MANAGED BY THE LABOR
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY. PR IN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND IT PROVIDES SIX
HUNDRED MILLION ONE TIME
FEDERAL FUNDS FOR THIS PROGRAM
AND I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SENATOR NELSON. THAT
PRESERVATION GERMAN CENTER I'M
GONNA URGENT NOBLE ON THIS
PARTICULAR EVENT SENATOR NELSON
I THINK THAT WE NEED TO GET
YOUR MIKE ON I WAS VERY GOOD
DOWN I WOULD URGE A NO VOTE ON
THIS BILL- IN THE CONSTRUCT OF
THE BILL. IT'S PICKING WINNERS
AND LOSERS. AND INDEED THERE
WILL BE SOME LOSERS. AND ONE OF
THE MOST FAILED AGENCIES IN THE
HISTORY OF CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT IS BEING RESPONSIBLE
NOW. FOR A NEW PROGRAM HERE.
THE PRIVATE DEVELOPED APARTMENT
HOW MANY COMPLAINTS ARE YOU
STILL GETTING FROM YOUR
CONSTITUENTS ABOUT DDD AND HAS
IT BEEN FIXED NOW THAT HAS NOT
BEEN FIXED MAYBE SOME OF THE
LEGISLATION THAT WILL FINALLY
GET OUT OF THIS LEGISLATURE
WILL DO A LITTLE BIT. BUT I
FEAR IT'S NOT GOING TO BE VERY
SIGNIFICANT. THAT SAID. THEN
I'M AFRAID THAT THIS IS GONNA
BE A FAR TOO CENTRALIZED
APPROACH FOR DEALING WITH THE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY. AND THERE
THERE THERE IS MONEY IN HERE
BUT AGAIN. I'M OBJECTING TO HOW
WE ARE PICKING WINNERS AND
LOSERS. I AM GOING TO URGE THE
NOBLE. IS THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SINGMAN
CENTERS CAN REMAKE INCLUDE.
ASPIRO MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA
HI ATKINS I FACE NO BACKER. HI-FORGES NOPE BRADFORD I COME BY
OTHER I. PROTESTING HI DOLLY.
NO DOG I DRAW SO I EGGMAN
GLAZER ARKANSAS AS I GROW. NO
HERTZBERG. WEST SO I HER TADO I
JONES NO CAN LONGER I LAYERED.
HI LLEVA I THE MOON I WIRE I
MELINDA'S NO MEN I NEWMAN I
NELSON. NO A TURBO NOW CAN I
PERSON TINA. I ROTH FIVE RUBIO
I SKINNER I STERN I'M BURKE HI
FOR CASKEY. I WINNER I WILL
KNOW PLEASE CALL THE OB TO
MEMBERS. EGGMAN ERTZ BERG I
STERN. FIVE TWENTY NINE KNOWS
NINE THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING
ON TO ONE FORTY EIGHT PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL ONE SIXTY
FIVE BY THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW AN ACT
RELATING TO STATE EMPLOYMENT
AND MAKE MAKING IT A
PERFORATION THEREFORE TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY DELIVERS THE
BUDGET. CENTER SKINNER THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS SP
ONE SIX FIVE RATIFIES TWO IMHO
YOU SIDE LETTER AGREEMENTS
BETWEEN THE STATE AND
BARGAINING UNIT SEVEN WHICH IS
REPRESENTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE LAW ENFORCEMENT
ASSOCIATION. AND BARGAINING
UIT EIGHT REPRESENTED BY CAL
FIRE LOCAL TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY
ONE FIX TECHNICAL IN CLARIFYING
CHANGES DEMO USED THAT WE
RATIFIED IN JUNE AND I ASKED
FOR I GO. THROUGH ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SAYING MAN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA I AT KINS I
BASE. BACKER HI FOR JUST HI
BRADFORD I HAVE A HI PROTESTING
I DALLY I DONT. I TORONTO I
EGGMAN LASER. HI CONSOLIDATES I
GROSS HI HURTS BERG I WAS SO. I
HER TADO HI JONES I CAN LONGER
I LAYERED. I LLEVA I THE MON I
REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S I MEAN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN I A TOTAL VOTE
I CAN I PORTS AND TINA I. ROSS.
I REVERE I SKINNER I STERN
NUMBER ALL RIGHT HI FOR CASKEY
I WINNER. I WILL HI PLEASE CALL
THE OB TO MEMBERS. BATES I
ADMIN STERN I THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING
ON TO FILE NUMBER ONE FORTY
NINE PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL
ONE SIXTY SIX BY THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AN ACT RELATING TO
CANNABIS AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL
RELIEVES THE BUDGET. CENTER
SKINNER THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS EIGHT SP ONE
SIXTY SIX IS OUR CANNABIS
BUDGET TRAILER BILL. AND IT- WE
ACTED IN JUNE AND PROVIDED
THIRTY MILLION TO IMPLEMENT
CANNABIS LICENSING FEE WAIVERS
AND DEFERRALS CONTINGENT UPON
THE ADOPTION OF FUTURE LANGUAGE
AND THIS IS THE LANGUAGE THAT
WE WOULD NEED TO SPEND THAT
MONEY. SO IT SET THE PARAMETERS
FOR LICENSING FEE WAIVERS AND
DEFERRALS BY CREATING A
STATEWIDE DEFINITION FOR EQUITY
APPLICANTS AND LICENSEES THAT
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR THE
LICENSE THING BE WAIVERS AND
DEFERRALS. AND WITH THAT I ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM SENATOR BRADFORD. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR ON PRESIDENT I
WANT TO THINK OF THE PROTIUM
STAFF CREDIBLE. BUDGET STAFF
ARE PUT TO CHEER. IN ALL THEIR
RESPECTIVE STAFF FOR WORKING ON
A B. ONE SIX SIX. IT'S BEEN
REALLY ENCOURAGING AND- A
REASSURING. TO WORK WITH THIS
TEAM AND TO WORK ON THE
CONTENTS OF THIS CAMPUS EQUITY
FEE WAIVER AND DEFERRAL PROGRAM
AS WE ALL KNOW THIS IS A
PROGRAM THAT IS NOW. WE ARE ALL
THIRTY FIVE NINE FIVE TWO YEARS
AGO BUT THERE WAS NO MONEY IN
THE PROGRAM AND THE ONE THING
THAT WE'VE SEEN OVER THE LAST
YEAR AND A HALF YEARS SINCE HIS
CANNABIS MARKET IS. TAKEN
FLIGHT IS THE LACK OF WOMEN.
MINORITIES ARE DISABLED
VETERANS IN THE SPACE AND
THEY'RE- WANTING TO BE HERE
EVERY DAY SO I WANT TO THANK
THEM FOR WORKING WITH ME AND
SHOW ME THAT YOU. REALLY HEARD
THE CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN
EXPRESSED- BY ME BY
CONSTITUENTS IN MY DISTRICT BY
PEOPLE WHO LOOK LIKE ME IN
NINETEEN. NOT ONLY ARE HEARD ME
BUT YOU WERE TRULY LISTENING.
THIS TRAILER BILL CREATES
ADDITIONAL GUARDRAILS TO
IMPLEMENT AS FEET FIVE NINE
FIVE. AGAIN WHICH WE PASSED IN
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. AND TWO
YEARS LATER- WITH AFTER WE PASS
WE FINALLY A FINAL VOTE HAVE
FUNDING. AND I'VE TALKED TO A
FEW FUN THIS FEE WAIVER PROGRAM
IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET SO I
APPRECIATE THIS- THIS TRAILER
BILL SPECIFIES THE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE BEEN CONVICTED OR ARRESTED
WITH CANNABIS VIOLATIONS CAN
QUALIFY FOR FEE WAIVERS AND
DEFERRALS THE REASONS ARE
OBVIOUS TO ANYONE WHO KNOWS THE
REAL HISTORY ON THE WAR ON
DRUGS WHY THIS IS SO IMPORTANT.
PEOPLE'S HOUSEHOLD INCOME IS
60% OR BELOW AREA MEDIAN INCOME
CAN ALSO QUALIFY THEIR INCOME
WOULD BE OF INCOME WITH OTHER.
WISE WE TOO MUCH. OR TOO HARD
TO SAY FOR THEM TO COMPETE IN
THIS RICH MAN'S BUSINESS
WHETHER ANY HELP THIS IS
CRITICALLY NEEDED. PEOPLE LIVE
IN AN AREA THAT HAS BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
PAST CRIMINAL JUSTICE POLICIES.
ALSO QUALIFY RECOGNIZE THAT THE
WAR ON WEED INFLICTED BOTH
INDIVIDUALS AND COMMUNITIES AS
A WHOLE TO HARM BOTH. HANNAH
I'M REMINDED THAT BLACK PEOPLE
IN THE COMMUNITIES. CALL WERE
MADE TO FEEL THE BURN THE HARM
AND THE DAMAGE INFLICTED AS A
RESULT OF THE WAR WAR ON DRUGS
AGAIN SO I APPRECIATE THIS
MINISTRATIONS WORKED IN THIS
ENGAGEMENT. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING NO
FURTHER DEBATE SENATOR SKINNER
YOU MAY CONCLUDE. THANK YOU
ASKED FOR- I VOTE. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI
AT KINS I BASICS NO BACKER. HI
FORGES NO BRADFORD I COME BY
ADAM HI PROTESTING. I DALLY.
DOT I TORONTO HI ADNAN GLASER
ALRIGHT GONZALEZ HI GROVE.
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. I HER TADO
I JONES NO CAN LONGER I LAYERED
I. LEIVA. HI THE MOON I REQUIRE
I MELINDA'S NO MEN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN NO A SHOW OF BOTH KNOW
PAM. HI FORTUNE TINO. ROTH FIVE
RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN AMBERG
ALL RIGHT I LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER. I WILL I. PLEASE CALL
THE OB TO MEMBERS VALLEY NO.
EGGMAN GROVE NO. FORTINO STERN.
FIVE TWENTY FIVE TWENTY NINE
KNOWS EIGHT THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE
FIFTY PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL
ONE SIXTY EIGHT BY THE SENATE%
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AN ACT RELATING TO CHILD
CHILD CARE AND MAKING
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TAKEN
TO MEDIATE LEE BUT BELIEVES THE
BUDGET. SENATOR SKINNER THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS SP
ONE SIXTY EIGHT. IS THE CLEAN
UP TRAILER BILL FOR CHILDCARE
ACTIONS. IT ENSURES THE
EMERGENCY FOSTER BRIDGE. YOUR
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS IN THE
MIGRANT ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
PROGRAMS ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
VARIOUS PANDEMIC RELIEF
PROVISIONS AND CHILD CARE
FUNDING. IT ALSO UPDATES
ALLOCATIONS FOR FEDERAL
STIMULUS FUNDS AMONG OTHER
TECHNICAL CHANGES AND I ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SINGMAN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA I ADKINS I
FACE I BACKER. FIVE PORCHES HI
BRADFORD I HAVE A BETTER LIFE
COURTESY I DALLY I DOG. HI
TORONTO I EDMUND GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE I GROWTH. I HURTS
BERG I WAS SO HYPER TANTO HI
JONES I CAN LONGER. I LAYERED I
PLAY A HI THE MOON HI WIRE. HI
MELINDA'S FIVE MEN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. I A SHOW OF BOTH I CAN
HI PERSON TINA. ROTH FIVE RUBIO
FIVE SKINNER I STERN I'M BERG
ALL RIGHT HI MIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER. I WILL HI PLEASE CALL
THE UPS. THE PERSON TINO I. I
THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE
FIFTY ONE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL ONE
SIXTY NINE BY THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AN ACT RELATING TO POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION AND MAKING
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TAKE TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL
RELATED TO THE BUDGET. SENATOR
SKINNER THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS SP ONE SIXTY
NINE IS OUR HIGHER EDUCATION
TRAILER BILLING AS I REFERENCED
EARLIER THIS CREATES OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION STUDENT HOUSING GRANT
PROGRAM. AND CAPACITY EXPANSION
PROGRAM TO SUPPORT AFFORDABLE
STUDENT HOUSING AT RCS YOU
USING COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEMS
AND CAMPUS EXPANSION AT UC AND
CSU. NOW INITIALLY THIS FUNDS
ARE GOING TO BE USED FOR
STUDENT HOUSING AND FOR THIS
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO IT PUTS FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION. INTO STUDENT HOUSING
PROJECTS- 50% OF THIS FUNDING
FOR OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES 30%
CS USING 20% FOR YOU SIS IT
ALSO MAKES CLARIFYING TECHNICAL
CHANGES TO BE IMPLEMENTED. THE
UPDATED MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM OR CHILD
SAVINGS ACCOUNTS AND THE CRADLE
TO CAREER DATA SYSTEM WITH THAT
I ASK YOUR ABOUT. MEMBERS IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NONE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI
ACTON'S HIGH BASE I BACKER HI
FORGES HI BRADFORD I HAVE A
HYPERTENSIVE. HI SALLY I DON HI
THERE ALSO I THANK MEN GLAZER
HI GONZALEZ I GROW. HI HURTS
BURKE HI WEST SO. HI HER TADO.
HI JONES I CAN LONGER I LAYERED
I FLAVOR I THE MOON HI WIRE. HI
MELINDA'S FIVE MIN FIVE NEWMAN
HI NIELSEN HI A SHOW OF BOTH HI
PAM I FORTUNE TINO I ROCKED I
REVIEW I SKINNER. I STERN ON
BERG I LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER I
WILL. I. FIVE THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES. MOVING
UNDERWENT A FILE NUMBER ONE
FIFTY TWO MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE THREE. SENATE BILL ONE
SEVENTY ONE BY THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALTH AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TAKE
FIRST IMMEDIATELY BUILT INTO
THE BUDGET. SENATOR SKINNER
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS THE HEALTH TRAILER BILL
AUTHORIZES THE EXPENDITURE OF
THE FEDERAL AMERICAN RESCUE
PLAN FUNDING TO EXPAND AND
STRENGTHEN HOME AND COMMUNITY
BASED HEALTH SERVICES IT ALSO
EXTENDS FOR ONE YEAR THE SUNSET
ON TIME AND DISTANCE STANDARDS.
THAT ENSURE OUR MEDICARE
MANAGED CARE BUT THAT
BENEFICIARIES HAVE ACCESS TO
NECESSARY CARE AND REQUIRES AN
EVALUATION BY TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR TO DETERMINE IF THE STATE
IS SUFFICIENT PROVIDERS TO
OFFER A STATEWIDE HOUSING
SUPPORT SERVICES BENEFIT IN OUR
MEDICARE PROGRAM. WITH THAT I
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SAYING THEN PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA I HAD
KITTENS I BASE I BECKER I
PORCHES I BRADFORD I COME
BEARING HI CORTESE I DALLY I
DONT. THEY'RE ALSO HI AIKMAN
GLAZER. GONZALEZ I GROW I HEARD
SPURS I WAS SO. HER TADO. JONES.
CAN LONGER I LAYERED I LLEVA I
THE MOON I REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S.
I MAN I NEWMAN. I NIELSEN I
TOLD BOTH I CAN I FORTUNE TINO
I. ROSS. I RUBIO I SKINNER HI
STERN AMBERG I LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER I WILL HI PLEASE CALL
THE OB TO MEMBERS. DODD I
EGGMAN LASER I. WEST SO I
HURTADO I JONES I. STERN. FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS ARE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE THIRTY. BOB MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE SIXTY THREE BY THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AN
ACT RELATING TO STATE
GOVERNMENT AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BUILT INTO
THE BUDGET. SENATOR SKINNER
THANKS MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS
EIGHTY ONE SIXTY THREE IS THE
GENERAL GOVERNMENT BUDGET
TRAILER BILL THAT MAKES
TECHNICAL IN CLARIFYING CHANGES
TO PROPOSALS THAT WE AGREED
UPON IN JUNE AND THESE CHANGES
ARE NECESSARY TO IMPLEMENT OUR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT.
AND I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. FOR
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. MEMBERS THIS THIS ITEM
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
ANY OBJECTION TO USING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. I SEE NO
NO OBJECTION I SEE THIRTY EIGHT
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ITEM ONE THIRTY THREE. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE SIXTY SEVEN BY THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AN
ACT RELATING TO EDUCATION
FINANCE AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL
RELIEVES THE BUDGET CENTER
SCANNER THE FLOOR'S YOURS.
THANK YOU- YEAH. MAN OF COURSE
THAT IS THE ONE NO I DO NOT
HAVE IN FRONT OF ME ONE MOMENT.
INSIGHTFUL.
WE NEED THE MICRON
ALL RIGHT SORRY THROUGH NOW
OKAY MEMBERS. THE EIGHTY ONE
SIX SEVEN IS OUR K. TWELVE
CLEANER TRAILER BILL AND IT
MAKES A VARIETY OF CLARIFYING
CHANGES TO INDEPENDENT STUDY
INCLUDING SPECIFYING THAT OUR
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES MAY
RECEIVE APPOINTMENT. EXCUSE ME
RECEIVE APPORTIONMENT FOR
STUDENTS PARTICIPATING IN
INDEPENDENT STUDY AS A RESULT
OF BEING QUARANTINED FOR COVERT
NINETEEN. IT ALSO SPECIFIES
THAT OUR CLASSROOM BASED
CHARTER SCHOOLS DO NOT HAVE TO
FILE FUNDING DETERMINATIONS FOR
PROVIDING INDEPENDENT STUDY
INSTRUCTION TO THOSE STUDENTS
IN COVERT NINETEEN RELATED
QUARANTINE. WHAT MAKES A
VARIETY OF OTHER CHANGES
NECESSARY TO IMPLEMENT THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET.
INCLUDING THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO BUDGET SKEWS ME INCLUDING
PROVIDING A PROCESS FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF MODEL CURRICULA.
AMENDING THE SPLIT A FEDERAL
STIMULUS FUNDS AND PROP NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUNDS FOR A
VARIETY OF PROGRAMS. AND
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
FLEXIBILITY FOR THE USE OF
SUBSTITUTE TEACHERS AMONG OTHER
AMENDMENTS. AND WITH THAT I ASK
FOR YOUR ADDRESS. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM SENATOR BURGESS. THE
PRESIDENT IF I MAY POSE A
QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR. THE
CHAIR. SENATOR SKINNER YOU
ACCEPT THE QUESTION YES HE
WROTE THANK YOU I RECEIVED A-
SOME PHONE CALLS FROM FOLKS- IN
EDUCATION AND THEY HAD SOME.
FINANCED THEY HAD SOME CONCERN
ABOUT THE INDEPENDENT STUDY-
REQUIREMENT. I'M TRYING TO RIP
RECOLLECTED EXACTLY WHAT
CHANGED. IN THE EARLIER
ITERATIONS BUT NOW THAT WHEN
KIDS ARE OUT OF SCHOOL BECAUSE
OF A CODE RELATED MATTERS THAT
THEY MUST DO AN INDEPENDENT
STUDY AND THAT TRIGGERS A WHOLE
NEW SET OF REQUIREMENTS HAVE
YOU HEARD FROM- SUPERINTENDENTS
OR- THEIR REPRESENTATIVES
AFFILIATES ABOUT THE CONCERNS
ABOUT. HELLO THIS IS A LITTLE
BIT IN THIS IS BURDENSOME AND
COULD CREATE COMPLICATIONS FOR
THE FOR THE DISTRICT'S. THERE
WERE SOME FINANCE ARE THERE
WERE SOME ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
THEY JUST FEEL THEY WERE NOT.
THE VARIETY OF EXPRESSIONS WERE
VARIED AND SO TO LAND ON A
PARTICULAR CHANGE THAT WOULD
ADDRESS TE VERY CONCERNS WAS
DIFFICULT GIVEN ARE GIVEN THE
TIMING WE HAD. BUT THE CHANGES
WE ARE MAKING DO ACCOMMODATE
FOR OUR UNANTICIPATED SURGE DUE
TO THE DELTA WHERE WE ARE
HAVING MORE CHILDREN HAVING TO
BE QUARANTINED AND THUS IN
ORDER FOR THEM TO CONTINUE TO
GET INSTRUCTION. ALLOWING THEM
TO DO INDEPENDENT STUDY WHICH
THIS BILL DOES. SO IT DIDN'T
LET ME JUST CLARIFY THIS MAY
NOT BE OF. THE OPPORTUNE MOMENT
THIS MAIN NEED RECORD THIS MAY
NEED A LITTLE BIT MORE
REVISITING. BUT IF I RECOLLECT
APPROPRIATELY- DURING NORMAL
COVE IN WHEN A STUDENT WAS OUT
THEY WERE GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY-
TO MAKE UP CLASS. IN THE NORMAL
FORMAT AS OPPOSED TO HAVING TO
GO THROUGH THE RIGORS OF AN
INDEPENDENT STUDY. AND THAT
TRIGGERED- ALL SORTS OF
OVERSIGHT AND- THE DIFFICULTY
THAT SOME OF THE INDEPENDENT
STUDY FOLKS HAVE HABIT OF
COURSE DO WITH BROADBAND SO
MAYBE ADD AT A LATER POINT IF
YOU COULD PUT THIS- FEATHER IN
YOUR CAP TO REVISIT SUFFERED
FROM SUPERINTENDENTS AND OTHER
FOLKS ESPECIALLY IN RURAL
FOOTHILL MOUNTAIN COMMUNITIES.
THAT THIS COULD BE A POTENTIAL
CHALLENGE- FOR FOLKS THAT- ARE
DEALING WITH THE COVERT ISSUE-
WHAT I WOULD REFERENCE IS THAT
AS I THINK ALL OF US APPRECIATE
IN THE ACTIONS WE TOOK IN JUNE
WE WERE OUR INTENTION WAS TO
HELP GET EVERY STUDENT BACK IN
THE CLASSROOM IN EVERY SCHOOL
TO HAVE INSPIRATION
INSTRUCTION- NOW IF WE SEE THAT
WE CONTINUE TO HAVE THE LEVEL
OF EITHER NEW CODE NINETEEN
VARIANTS AND THE LEVEL OF- OF-
INFECTION RATES. THEN WE MAY
HAVE TO MAKE MORE MODIFICATIONS
IN JANUARY CLEARLY HOWEVER
THESE ARE ON THE MAIN
MODIFICATIONS THAT ARE
DIFFERENT DISTRICTS INCLUDING
OUR CHARTER SCHOOLS ASKED FOR
AND WE ADDRESSED THOSE IN THIS
BUT OF COURSE WE'LL CONTINUE TO
MONITOR AND IF NEEDED WILL MAKE
ADDITIONAL IN JANUARY OR-
THEREAFTER. AND WITHOUT- I
WOULD END WITH ASKING FOR A NO
VOTE. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL ABOUT AN MET MEMBERS THIS
MAY BE ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THIS.
ANY OBJECTION TO USING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. NOT VERY
MANY OF US HERE SO MAYBE IT'S A
WAY TO DO IT I'M JUST KIDDING-
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THIS
MEASURE PASSES WE'RE GONNA MOVE
ON TO FILE IT AND WENT THIRTY
EIGHT ADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. THAT'S SIMPLY BILL ONE
SEVENTY TWO BY THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AN ACT
RELATING TO HUMAN SERVICES I'M
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED TO THE
BUDGET. SENATOR SKINNER. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. EIGHTY ONE
SEVENTY TWO IS THE HUMAN
SERVICES TRAILER BILL WHICH
ESTABLISHES THE CENTER FOR DATA
INSIGHTS IN INNOVATION. WITHIN
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY. IT ALSO
CREATES. THE COMMUNITY CARE
EXPANSION PROGRAM TO AWARD
GRANTS TO PRESERVE THE
CAPACITY. OF RESIDENTIAL ADULT
AND SENIOR CARE FACILITIES. AND
TO PROVIDE OPERATING SUBSIDIES
TO THESE FACILITIES. AND
FINALLY IT CREATES THE CAREER
PATHWAYS PROGRAM FOR PROVIDERS
OF IN HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES.
SO THAT THEY MAY BE TRAINED FOR
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CAREER
ADVANCEMENTS. WITHIN THE HEALTH
AND HOME CARE INDUSTRIES BUT B.
BUT TO BRING THEM FURTHER-
ORANGE OTHER OPPORTUNITIES THAN
WHAT THE CURRENT. WHAT THE
POSITIONS THEY CURRENTLY HOLDS.
HANDS WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. SEVENTY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CENTER
TIGHTER. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY AS CHAIR
OF THE SENATE HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE
SEVEN TWO IN PARTICULAR I WANT
TO KNOW MY SUPPORT OF B. CAREER
PATHWAYS PROGRAM AND THE
COMMUNITY CARE EXPANSION
PROGRAM. I'M A FAN OF CAREER
TRAINING PROGRAMS ESPECIALLY
THOSE THAT SUPPORT WORKERS IN
THE HEALTHCARE FIELD AND A
CAREER PATHWAYS PROGRAMS WHICH
BENEFIT BOTH PROVIDERS AND
RECIPIENTS OF IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES. B. I. H.
S. S. PROGRAM ALLOWS RECIPIENTS
WHO MIGHT OTHERWISE LIVE IN AN
INSTITUTIONAL SETTING TO REMAIN
IN THEIR HOMES AND WITH OVER
FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE WHO PROVIDE I H. S. S.
SERVICES IT'S A MAJOR EMPLOYER
OF CALIFORNIA'S HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE AND LIKELY TO GROW IN
THE COMING YEARS. EVER
RECRUITING AND RETAINING
PROVIDERS CAN BE A CHALLENGE
THIS IS BECAUSE THE WORK. WHILE
REWARDING CAN BE DIFFICULT THE
PACE NEAR MINIMUM WAGE MMHM
NEAR MINIMUM WAGE AND THERE'S
NO BUILT IN PATHWAY FOR WORKERS
TO ADVANCE PROFESSIONALLY. THIS
BILL WILL CREATE A CAREER
PATHWAYS PROGRAM DESIGNED TO
INCREASE THE QUALITY OF CARE
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION OF
PROVIDERS AND TO PROVIDE
TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
CAREER ADVANCEMENT IN THE HOME
CARE AND HEALTHCARE INDUSTRIES.
I ALSO WANT TO COMMENT ON THE
COMMUNITY CARE EXPANSION
PROGRAM WHICH IS DESIGNED TO
PRESERVE AND EXPAND THE
CAPACITY OF RESIDENTIAL ADULT.
AND SENIOR CARE FACILITIES THAT
SERVE LOW INCOME RESIDENTS. WHO
RECEIVE BENEFITS FROM SS I SS
P. OR THE CASH ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM FOR IMMIGRANTS. IN AN
OVERSIGHT HERE LAST YEAR WE
LEARNED THAT THE SUPPLY OF
THESE LICENSE FACILITIES WAS
LIMITED AND DIMINISHING. BY
ALMOST TWO THOUSAND FACILITIES
SINCE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN.
SINCE THEN I'VE BEEN WORKING TO
REVERSE THIS ALARMING TREND AND
I'M PLEASED THIS BILL CREATED
PATH TOWARDS PRESERVING BUYING
AND BUILDING CAPACITY FOR
PEOPLE WHO CANNOT LIVE
INDEPENDENTLY. DUE TO THEIR
PHYSICAL LIMITATIONS OR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS.
PRESIDENT FACILITIES LIKE BEES
ARE KEY TO PREVENTING AND
FIGHTING HOMELESSNESS THE
COMMUNITY CARE EXPANSION
PROGRAM AND CAREER PATHWAYS
PROGRAM ARE CONSISTENT WITH.
THE OTHER EFFORTS TO GROW HOME
AND COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES
THAT ALLOW PEOPLE TO LIVE
WITHIN THEIR COMMUNITIES. BOTH
OF THESE PROGRAMS WILL HELP
SOME OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS TO RESIDE IN SAFELY
WITHIN THEIR COMMUNITIES AND I
URGE COLLEAGUES YOUR AVAILABLE.
IS THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SAYING NINE. CENTERS CAN REMAKE
INCLUDE ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI AT
KINS I FACE. BECKER I PORCHES.
BRADFORD I HAVE A YELLOW I
PROTESTING I DALLY. GOD I
TORONTO HI ADNAN GLAZER ICONS
ALL AS I GROW. HERTZBERG HI
WEST SO I FOR TIDO HI JONES NO
CAMCORDER I LAYERED I LLEVA I
LIVE ALONE. HI MCGUIRE.
MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN I A SHOW OF BOTH I CAN.
I FORTUNE TINO I BROUGHT. I
RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN AMBERG
I LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER I WILL.
HI PLEASE CALL THE OB TO
MEMBERS. BATES FOR JUST. DALLY
EGGMAN. GROVE. MAGUIRE HI
MELINDA'S. STERN FIVE THIRTY
TWO KNOWS ONE THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ONTO FILE ITEM
ONE THIRTY NINE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
SEVENTY THREE BY THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC SAFETY AND
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BIL RELATED TO THE
BUDGET. CENTER SKINNER. THANK
YOU- MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS.
EIGHTY ONE SEVENTY THREE IS OUR
PUBLIC SAFETY TRAILER BILL IT
MAKES IT A PUNISHABLE OFFENSE
TO BRING SPECIFIED WEAPONS INTO
THE NEW STATE OFFICE BUILDING
THAT- SOME OF US WE MOVING INTO
ACROSS THE STREET THE SWING
SPACE IT ENSURES THE DOJ
CONTINUES TO SHARE. GUN
VIOLENCE DATA WITH RESEARCHERS
AT THE STATE FUNDED CALIFORNIA
FIREARM VIOLENCE RESEARCH
CENTER AT UC DAVIS AND IT
CREATES A DISCRETIONARY.
PROCESS FOR OTHER BONA FIDE
RESEARCH CENTERS DOING FIRE
ARMS RESEARCH TO RECEIVE DATA.
WHILE ENSURING THAT THAT
INFORMATION REMAINS
CONFIDENTIAL. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NONE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA I.
CAN SEE. ON MY FACE NO BACKER.
PORCHES NO BRADFORD. BY ADAM HI
PROTESTING. DALLY NO DOG I
TORONTO HI AIKMAN GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE HI GROSS NO
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO I JONES NO KAMMERER. I
LAYERED I LLEVA I THE MOON I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S. NO MAN I
NEWMAN. NIELSEN NO A SHOW OF
BOTH. PAM HI PERSON TINO I
BROUGHT I RUBIO I'M SKINNER I
STERN AMBERG I WORK OWSKI I
WINNER I WILL. NO PLEASE CALL
THE OB TO MEMBERS. BACKER I
BRADFORD I. CORTESE I. EGGMAN
NEWMAN. CONTROL OF BOTH. STERN.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ADMIN NEWMAN. A TRIO OF BOTH NO
STERN. FIVE TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS
NINE THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING
ON FILE I'M NUMBER ONE FORTY
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SEVENTY FOUR
BY THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AN ACT RELATING TO
VEHICLES AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY THE LIVES
THE BUDGET. CENTER SKINNER
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS EIGHTY ONE SEVENTY FOUR
IS THE TRANSPORTATION IT'S
REALLY A CLEANUP BILL FOR
TRANSPORTATION- THERE WILL BE
OTHER TRANSPORTATION ACTIONS
WILL TAKE NOT IN THIS SESSION
BUT- BUT THIS BILL CLARIFIES
EXISTING LAW RELATED TO
RENEWAL. PROCESS SHE'S FOR
DRIVER'S LICENSE AND ID CARDS
FOR CHP ENFORCEMENT RULES. AND
FOR COMMERCIAL VEHICLE
INSURANCE REPORTING. THE LAST
THE DMV TO CONTINUE WITH ITS
EXISTING VIRTUAL FIELD OFFICES.
APPROACH TO DRIVER'S LICENSE
RENEWALS FOR ANOTHER YEAR. AND
IT GIVES LEGISLATURE TIME TO
DESIGN A PERMANENT APPROACH TO
DM VIS VIRTUAL SERVICE
OFFERINGS. AND WITH THAT I ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEAMAN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA HI ADKINS I
FACE I BACKER HI FORTUS HI
BRADFORD I HAVE A HYPERTENSIVE.
DALLY DOT HI TORONTO I EGGMAN
GLASER I CONSOLIDATE I GROSS.
HERTZBERG FIVE WEST SO. I HER
DAUGHTER. HI JONES. CAN LONGER
I LAYERED I FLAVOR I THE MOON
HI MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S I MEN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN I A SHOW OF
BOTH. HI PAM I FORTUNE TINO I
ROCKED I REVIEW I SKINNER HI
STERN I'M BERG. WHITE HOUSE HE
I. WINNER I WILL HI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. COURTS
HEAVY. I ALLEY. EGGMAN GROSS.
JONES STERN AMBERG HI. FIVE
THIRTY FIVE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES PUTTING ON FILE AT ONE
FORTY ONE PLEASE READ. THAT'S
ONLY THE ONE SEVENTY FIVE BY
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AN ACTUAL LEADING TO
HOUSING AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL REALLY
TO THE BUDGET. CENTER SKINNER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
EIGHTY ONE SEVENTY FIVE IS THE
CLEANUP TRAILER BILL ON
HOUSING. IT MAKES TECHNICAL IN
CLARIFYING CHANGES TO EXISTING
LAW. TO ASSIST THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE HOUSING
HOMELESS HOUSING ASSISTANCE AND
PREVENTION PROGRAM. THE
REGIONAL EARLY ACTION PLANNING
PROGRAM OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
AND THE FORECLOSURE
INTERVENTION AND HOUSING
PRESERVATION PROGRAM. IT ALSO
MAKES STATUTORY CHANGES
NECESSARY TO ALLOW TWO PROJECTS
A HOMELESS SHELTER. IN
SACRAMENTO AND AN AFFORDABLE
PRICE. TWENTY FOUR DOUBLE
HOUSING PROJECT IN LOS ANGELES
THIS ALLOWS THEM TO MOVE
FORWARD. LASTLY THE BILLS
PROVIDES THIRTY MILLION FOR
ENFORCEMENT OF LABOR
REQUIREMENTS ON PUBLICLY FUNDED
HOUSING PROJECTS. AND WITH THAT
I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SAYING MAN PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA I
ADKINS I HATE. BACKER FOR JUST.
BRADFORD I COME BY OTHER HIGH
COURTS HAS HE I DALLY. DOT I
THE RUSSELL HI EGGMAN GLAZER
EYE CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH.
HERTZBERG I WAS SO HI HER TADO
I JONES. CAN LONGER I LAYERED I
LLEVA. I THE MON HI WIRE I
MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. A TOWBOAT. I CAN I
FORTUNE TINO HI RALPH I REVIEW.
HI SKINNER I STERN AMBERG HI WE
CASKEY I WINNER I WILL. PLEASE
CALL THE OB TO MEMBERS. FAITH
BECKER I FORTUS. DALLY AIKMAN.
GROWTH JONES. MELINDA'S NIELSEN
STERN WELL. FIVE THIRTY NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES LIVING UNDER
FILE ITEM ONE FORTY TWO. PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SEVENTY
SIX BY THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON BUDGET AN ACT RELATING TO
STATE GOVERNMENT AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL
RELIEVES THE BUDGET. SENATOR
SKINNER THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT EIGHTY ONE SEVENTY
SIX IS THE TRAILER BILL ON
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. AND IT.
CONTAINS TECHNICAL IN
CLARIFYING CHANGES NECESSARY TO
IMPLEMENT ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS AND TAX CREDITS THAT
WERE IN THE BUDGET BILL WE
ADOPTED JUNE JUNE. EXTENDS
CERTAIN LIMITATIONS ON WAGE
GARNISHMENT. BANK LEVEES TO THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD. IN
ADDITION TO PRIVATE DEBT
COLLECTORS. AND WITH THAT I ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SAYING NONE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA I.
ACTIONS I BASE. BACKER HI
FORTUS I BRADFORD I HAVE A I
DON'T. I PROTESTING HI DALLY.
GOD HI TORONTO HI AIKMAN LASER
I CONSOLIDATE HIGH GROWTH. HI
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HI FURTADO
HI JONES. CAMCORDER I LAYERED I
PLAY A I LIVE ALONE I REQUIRE.
I MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. A CHARTER OAK I CAN HI
PERSON TINA I BROUGHT I REVIEW
FIVE SKINNER I STERN AMBERG.
WHITE HOUSE SKI I WINNER I WILL.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BATES DALLY. EGGMAN
JONES I MELINDA'S NIELSEN I
STERN AMBERG. FIVE THIRTY FOUR
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING ON TO OUR FINAL BUDGET
ITEM ONE FORTY THREE PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SEVENTY
SEVEN BY THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON BUDGET AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC SAFETY AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION AIRPORTS TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
BUDGET. CENTER SKINNER. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS YES
THIS IS OUR FINAL TRAILER BILL
FOR THIS SESSION ON THE TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET. AND IT
IS RELATED TO SOME PUBLIC
SAFETY ITEMS SPECIFICALLY THE
COURTS. MAYBE ONE SEVENTY SEVEN
ELIMINATE SEVENTEEN CRIMINAL
ADMINISTRATIVE FEES AND AS WE
APPROPRIATED IN OUR BUDGET
ORIGINAL BUDGET BILL. IT
RELIEVES ANY OUTSTANDING DEBT
FROM THE SPECIES ON JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY SECOND AND
BACK FILLS THE COUNTIES FOR ANY
LOSS IN REVENUE THAT THEY MAY
RECEIVE FROM THIS V. REPEAL. I
WANT TO THANK THE
ADMINISTRATION AND STAKEHOLDERS
FOR WORKING ON THIS WE- ARE
LOOKING WE HAVE THE INTENT TO
PROVIDE SOME OTHER FEAR RELIEF
OUR COURTS. IN RECENT YEARS
HAVE TURNED MORE AND MORE TO
USING FEES TO HELP SUPPORT
THEIR OPERATIONS AND THOSE FEES
HAVE FALLEN DISPROPORTIONATELY
ON VERY LOW INCOME PEOPLE AND
ESPECIALLY WITH- DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND OTHER TIMES
REALIZED THOSE KINDS OF DEBTS
THAT AS THEY INCREASE OUR- VERY
HARMFUL AND WE SHOULD BE ABLE
TO FIND OUR- COURTS IN WAYS
OTHER THAN JUST INCREASING FEES
ON. PRIMARILY LOW INCOME PEOPLE
SO WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS BUT I WANT TO
REALLY THANK THE ADMINISTRATION
AND STAKEHOLDERS FOR THE WORK
WE'VE DONE SO FAR THE BILL ALSO
INCREASES THE COURT REPORTER
TRANSCRIPTION RATE. AND IT
CODIFIES A LIMITED TIME
PROCEDURES RELATED TO THE USE
OF REMOTE TECHNOLOGY IN OUR
CIVIL COURT PROCEEDINGS BECAUSE
AS WE KNOW THAT WE'RE STILL
UNDER THE PANDEMIC OPERATING.
IN SOME CASES REMOTELY AND WITH
THAT I ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS.
CENTER BRADFORD. THE
PRESIDENT'S PRESIDENT I TOO
WANT TO RENOUNCE AGAIN THANK
THE BUDGET STAFF BUDGET YEAR
FOR ALL THE HARD WORK TO GET
DONE- I KNOW THIS IS A- TAXING
PROCESS. SO THANK THEM AGAIN
AND ESPECIALLY IN REGARDS TO
FREEDOM OF . ELIMINATION. AND
I WANT TO GIVE A BIG SHOUT OUT
TO DEBT FREE JUSTICE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR ALL THEIR HARD
WORK ON THIS ISSUE YEAR AFTER
YEAR. IT'S BECAUSE OF ALL THEIR
HARD WORK THERE WERE REMOVING
SEVENTEEN CRIMINAL AND
VIDEOGRAPHY HE'S FROM OUR LAWS
FROM OUR BOOKS PISA TRAP PEOPLE
ALREADY IN POVERTY AND IN JUST
MOVE THEM INTO GREATER
PROPERTY. FEES AT OFFER VERY
LITTLE ESCAPEES ATTACKS FOR
PEOPLE SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY ARE
POOR AND WHILE WE ARE BUILDING
ON THE GREAT WORK THAT WAS
STARTED BY SENATOR MITCHELL
WHEN SHE WAS HERE. OVER THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS- WE HAVE TO
KNOW THAT THERE'S STILL WORK TO
BE DONE MUCH MORE IN THIS AREA
SO WHEN WE COME BACK IN
JANUARY- WE'LL BE LOOKING AT
CIVIL ASSESSMENTS BECAUSE THEY
CONTINUE TO HARM. AGAINST
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND LOW INCOME
FOLKS- THERE ARE MANY MORE FEES
TO BE ELIMINATED BUT THIS IS. A
GOOD START- AND- I ENVISION A
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. THAT
DOES NOT HAVE TO CHOOSE THIS
MONEY AND- IN USE POOR PEOPLE I
SHOULD SAY TO FUND SYSTEMS OF
THE RICH. BUT HAVING A SYSTEM-
THAT IS FIGURED WE ALREADY HAVE
PRISONS WE ARE HAVE FIND VERY
HAVE RESTITUTION SO WE DON'T
NEED TO FIND A DRESS FOR
PROGRAMS TO. THESE FEES I AM
PROUD TO BE A PART OF THIS AND
JOIN ALL THEIR STRONG ADVOCATES
AND- BRING FORTH AS V. FIVE
EIGHTY SIX AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE. FOR ABC ONE
SEVEN SEVEN. FOR ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SINAN
CENTER SCANNER YOU MAY CONCLUDE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THIS
IS OUR FINAL- GBL JUST- AGAIN
THANK EVERYONE INVOLVED OF
COURSE THERE ARE OUR BUDGET
STAFF AS WE HAVE REFERENCED AND
ARE. THE STAFF OF THE PRO TEM'S
OFFICE AND IN ALL OF OUR MEMBER
OFFICES IN POLICY COMMITTEES
THAT WORKED ON THIS PLUS OF
COURSE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND THE STAFF IN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND THE
STAKEHOLDERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE WHO ALSO- NEGOTIATED WITH
US ON ALL THE PROVISIONS OF THE
VARIOUS ACTIONS THAT WE TOOK
BOTH IN JANUARY AND NOW. AND
IT'S- IT'S GREAT TO HAVE THIS
DONE AND WE SHOULD FEEL VERY
PROUD OF THE INCREDIBLE
INVESTMENTS THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS MAKING INTO ITS
PEOPLE IT'S BUSINESSES ITS
ENVIRONMENT AND ITS PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE AND SO
MUCH MORE AND WITH THAT I ASKED
YOU I DON'T. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I FACE NO
BACKER. I PURCHASE NO BRADFORD
I COME BY OTHER HYPERTENSIVE I
DALLY. NO DOG. I TORONTO I
EGGMAN GLAZER HI CONSOLIDATES I
GROSS NO HERTZBERG I WAS SO. I
TIDO I JONES. NO CAMCORDER I
LAYERED I LABOR I THE MOON I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S NO MAN I
NEWMAN I NELSON. GO TO A VOTE
NO PAM I FORTUNE TINO HI RALPH
I REVERE RUBIO I SKINNER I
STERN AMBERG I LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER. I WILL NOW. PRICE
TWENTY NINE KNOWS THE NINE THE
MEASURE PASSES. CENTER GROVE
MADAM PRESIDENT I'M I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO TAKE A POINT OF
PURPOSE PERSONAL PRIVILEGE AND-
I THINK THE BUDGET CHAIR THE
STAFF THAT WORKED ON IT FROM
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE BUT
SPECIFICALLY THE SENATE PRO TEM
WHO TRULY UNDERSTANDS LOCAL
CONTROL. ED THERE IS BUDGET
LANGUAGE THAT WAS FLOATING
AROUND- THAT WAS GOING TO
REMOVE ALL LOCAL CONTROL FROM
OUR COUNTIES ON PERMITTING FOR-
SOLAR AND RENEWABLE ENERGY AND
THE SENATE PRO TEM'S WISDOM.
AND NEGOTIATION POWER WHERE SHE
HAD THE ABILITY TO MAKE SURE
THAT LOCAL CONTROL REMAINED
WITH THEIR COUNTIES WITH
SIGNIFICANT FOR ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES BUT SPECIFICALLY KERN
COUNTY WITH ELEVEN PROJECTS. ON
THE BOOKS FOR ON. FOR SOLAR
LARGE SCALE SOLAR. I'M IN THE
MIX OF THAT SPECIFICALLY I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK KIP LIPPER
WHO UNDERSTAND SYKORA
UNDERSTANDS ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY UNDERSTANDS THE
BENEFITS. OF RENEWABLE ENERGY
IN BEING ADDED TO THE GRID AND
HE WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN MAKING
SURE THAT THAT LANGUAGE DID NOT
APPEAR IN THESE BILLS AND I'M
FOREVER GRATEFUL. TO BOTH OF
THEM FOR MAKING SURE THAT LOCAL
CONTROL STRAIGHT WITH LOCAL
CONTROL AND IT DID NOT END UP
IN A BUREAUCRACY IN THE STATE
ARENA IN EACH COUNTY HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO. MAKE SURE THAT-
THEY APPROVED THINGS THAT WAS
LAND USE USES SPECIFICALLY FOR
THEIR COUNTY SO AGAIN FOREVER
GRATEFUL TO THOSE SPECIFIC TO
INDIVIDUALS AND- ALL THE BUDGET
TEAM THAT WORKED ON THIS BUDGET.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR FOR YOUR COMMENTS TO
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO GO BACK.
TO THE ASSEMBLY THIRD READING.
WE'RE GONNA START OFF WITH
WHERE WE LEFT OFF WHICH IS A
FILE ITEM NUMBER NINETY EIGHT
SO SINCE- SENATOR WEST SO
YOU'LL BE FIRST THAT. AFTER
WHICH WEEK. NNETY EIGHT NINETY
NINE HUNDRED AND A HUNDRED AND
ONE. SENATOR RESO IS READY
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX FIFTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON AND
ACTUALLY INTO CEMETERIES. YES
THANK YOU OF MINE PRESIDENT
SENATORS- AB SIX FIVE ONE- WHAT
WOULD IT PREVENT PRIVATELY
OWNED CEMETERIES ACROSS STATE
OF CALIFORNIA FROM FALLING INTO
DISREPAIR DUE TO NEGLECT
MISCONDUCT AND FINANCIAL
ISSUES. COURSE WHEN SWEDEN-
PARKLAND CONSUMERS- PAY FOR
SOMETHING THEY SHOULD RECEIVE
IT EVEN AFTER. THEY HAVE A GUN
TO THE HERE AFTER SO THIS IS A
BILL THAT WOULD HOLD CEMETERY
KIRK CARETAKERS ACCOUNTABLE
PREVENT RISK OF INSOLVENCY BY
GRADUALLY INCREASING ENDOWMENT
INVESTMENT LEVELS THAT HAVE
BEEN LONG OVERDUE. A. B. SIX
FIVE ONE IS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT I WAS SURE THAT NOT ONE
MORE FAMILY HAS TO BEAR THE
PAIN OF FINDING THEIR LOCAL
LEVEL ONCE ABANDONED. THE
AUTHORS ALSO REQUEST YOU TO
MAKE A TECHNICAL AMENDMENT
BEFORE THIS BODY RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NOT ABLE. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINETY EIGHT. SINGMAN MEMBERS
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTION. SEEING NONE ICE
THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. YOU'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO ITEM HELLO WE WILL
PASS TEMPORARILY ITEM NUMBER
NINETY NINE AND MOVE ON TO.
ITEM ONE HUNDRED CENTER PENN IS
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR FIFTY
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LORENA
GONZALEZ AN ACT RELATING TO
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
SENATOR PENN FOR SEARS THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT SENATORS
ASSEMBLY BILL. FOUR MEDIC
DISCIPLINARY REVIEW BOARD
THAT'S AN APPEALS OF MEDIC
LICENSOR DISCIPLINE. CURRENTLY
THE EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
AUTHORITY ISSUES PARAMEDICAL
LICENSES CONDUCTS DISCIPLINARY
AS INVESTIGATIONS AND PROSECUTE
THE PLANES. THEY HOLD THE SOLE
AUTHORITY TO MAKE FINAL
DETERMINATIONS AND SERVICE
INVESTIGATOR PROSECUTOR JUDGE
AND JURY WHEN TAKING ANY ACTION
REGARDING PARAMEDIC LICENSES.
ALTHOUGH PARAMEDICS CAN APPEAL
TO ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE
EVEN AFTER THE ENTIRE PROCESS
IT IS SIMPLY A RECOMMENDATION
THAT GOES BACK TO THEM SO THAT
MAKES THE FINAL DETERMINATION
NO OTHER CALIFORNIA ISSUES
MEDICAL. ISSUES LICENSES LEFT
IN THE HANDS OF A SINGLE
INDIVIDUAL TO MAKE THE FINAL
AND BINDING DECISIONS THAT
IMPACT THE LIVES OF THE
LICENSEES. EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY-
ESTABLISH A BOARD OF MEDICAL
PEERS AND MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO BRING BALANCE AND FAIRNESS
TO THE PARAMEDIC DISPLAY
PROCESS EXPECT WE ASK FOR A
NIGHT OUT. FOR ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SAYING
MAN MEMBERS THIS IS ALSO
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING IT. ANY OBJECTION TO
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SAYING
NINE FIVE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ONTO
FILE ITEM ONE A ONE SENATOR MAN
IS PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL FIVE
EIGHTY THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
DAVIES AN ACT RELATING TO
MARRIAGE AND MAKE AND DECLARING
THE URGENCY THERE OF SIX FACT
MEDIALLY CINNAMON THE FLOOR'S
YOURS THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES I WOULD ASK YOU TO
HARKEN BACK TO A TIME WHEN YOU
WERE YOUNG AND FULL OF LOVE-
YOU WANTED DESPERATELY TO GET
MARRIED TO THA SPECIAL
SOMEONE- BUT- DURING THIS
PANDEMIC YOU WOULD NOT HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO DO THAT. AND SO
THIS BILL- JUST CREATES A
LIMITED ABILITY TO ALLOW FOR
ELECTRONIC ISSUANCES OF
MARRIAGE LICENSE AND
SOLEMNIZATION CEREMONIES HAS NO
OPPOSITION- PAST THE PAST I ASK
YOU TO VOTE ON. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SINGMAN MEMBERS THIS IS ALSO
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING THE EIGHT UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SEEING NONE ICE THIRTY
EIGHT KNOWS THEY'RE ON THE
URGENCY ICE THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO ON THE MEASURE. IT PASSES.
MEMBERS ARE GONNA MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER. ONE OH TWO.
SENATOR LEYVA. SHE IS READY
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE OH FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS AND
ACTUALLY IN THE HOSPITAL'S
CENTER LIVE THE FLOOR'S YOURS.
THE DENT THERE WE GO EVEN
PRESIDENT GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS EVEN BEFORE THE COVERED
NINETEEN PANDEMIC COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR OR DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED BY AN EQUAL ACCESS TO
QUALITY HEALTHCARE THE CDC HAS
FOUND THAT RACISM IN OUR HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM. HAS CONTRIBUTED TO
FUNDAMENTAL INEQUITIES AND
DISPARITIES IN HEALTHCARE AND
LIFE EXPECTANCIES AND THIS
PANDEMIC HAS FURTHER EXPOSED
AND WORSENED THESE INEQUITIES
WITHIN OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM.
AS SUCH IT IS IMPORTANT WE HAVE
COMPLETE ACCURATE AND
TRANSPARENT DATA REPORTING IN
ORDER TO IDENTIFY AND RESPOND
TO HEALTH DISPARITIES WITHIN
OUR STATE. AB TWELVE OH FOUR
WILL REQUIRE HOSPITALS AND
HEALTH SYSTEMS TO SUBMIT EQUITY
REPORTS TO DETAIL THEIR
PERFORMANCE ACROSS A STANDARD
SET OF MEASURES WHICH WILL HELP
THE ASSET. ASSESS ACCESS TO
HEALTHCARE QUALITY AND OUTCOMES
BY RACE RACE ETHNICITY AND
OTHER DEMOGRAPHICS. MEMBERS AB
TROUBLE FOR WILL HELP COLLECT
THE NEEDED METRICS AND HELP
MEASURE AN EFFECTIVE AND
EQUITABLE RESPONSE TO THE LONG
LONG TERM IMPACTS OF THE
PANDEMIC IN OTHER DEPARTMENTS
OF HEALTH AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR AND OTHER HISTORICALLY.
UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
MAN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN.
FIVE ARCHULETA I ADKINS I BAIT
NO BACKER HI PORCHES NO
BRADFORD I COME BY OTHER
HI YOU'RE AWESOME I EGGMAN
GLAZER. GONZALEZ I DROVE NO
HURTS BERG I WAS SO I FURTADO
HI JONES NO CAN LONGER. LAYERED
I LLEVA I THE MOON HI WIRE HI
MELINDA'S NO MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. NO CHOKO NO PAN I
PERSON TINA I BROUGHT. I RUBIO
I SKINNER HI STERN AMBERG I
LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER I WILL.
NO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. EGGMAN GLAZER I CAN
LONGER I STERN. PRICE TWENTY
NINE KNOWS NINE THE MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS ARE GONNA MOVE
ON TO ITEM ONE OH THREE SENATOR
RUBIO'S PREPARED PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE EIGHTY ONE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO AN ACT
RELATING TO CRIMINAL PROCEDURE
SENATOR RUBIO'S FOR SEARS THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT SENATE
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE EIGHTY ONE. THIS
BILL SEEKS TO AMEND THE PENAL
CODE SECTION RELATING TO THE
EXPUNGEMENT OF CRIMINAL RECORDS
TO SPECIFY THE DISMISSAL OF A
CASE UNDER THOSE SECTIONS WOULD
NOT AUTOMATICALLY READ A
DEFENDANT FROM THE TERMS OF AN
UNEXPIRED TENURE CRIMINAL
PROTECTIVE ORDER ISSUED IN THIS
CASE. THESE TEN YOUR PROTECTIVE
ORDERS ARE ONLY ISSUED IN
CERTAIN SERIOUS CASES SUCH AS
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE STALKING OR
ELDER ABUSE THE ORDERS PLACED
SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN PROTECTING
SOME OF THE MOST VULNERABLE
VICTIMS OF VIOLENT CRIMES. THIS
BILL IS SUPPORTED BY CRIME
VICTIM ADVOCACY GROUPS THIS
BILL HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THROUGH THE
BOTH HOUSES THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NINE MEMBERS THIS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL USE
THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS IT FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO. THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
ITEM ONE OH FOUR SENATOR
RUBIO'S PREPARED. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE SIXTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO AN ACT
RELATING TO FOSTER YOUTH CENTER
RUBIO. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT SENATE COLLEAGUES B.
THREE SIXTY SIX ADDRESSES
SHORTCOMINGS REGARDING SEVEN
POLICEMEN WITHIN OUR FOSTER
YOUTH SYSTEM THEY'RE VERY
COMPLEXITIES FOR CIVILIANS
WITHIN THE FOSTER SYSTEM AND
THE VALUE OF PRIORITIZING
SIBLINGS BEING PLACED TOGETHER
IS WELL ESTABLISHED IN PRACTICE
HOWEVER TOO MANY CHILDREN
REMAIN SEPARATED FROM THEIR
SIBLINGS AND RELATIVES DUE TO
BUREAUCRATIC HURDLES THAT ARE
NOT RELATED TO THE CHILD
SAFETY. EIGHTY THREE SIXTY SIX
WOULD STRENGTHEN EXISTING
PROTECTIONS IN FOSTER CARE
ASSURING SIBLINGS ARE PLACED
TOGETHER UNLESS THERE IS THE
SHOWING THAT PLACE THAT WOULD
BE CONTRARY TO THE WELL BEING
AND SAFETY OF ANY CITY SETTLING.
AND WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR
RIVAL THANK YOU. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SAYING NINE THIS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTION. THE SAME THING NO
OBJECTION HIGHS THIRTY SEVEN.
OUR BACK TO THIRTY EIGHT OKAY-
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT THAT NO ZERO.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ITEM ONE OH FIVE FILE IN ONE OF
FIVE. SENATOR WIENER. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTEEN OH FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO AN ACT
RELATING TO LAND USE CENTER
WINNER THE FLOOR IS YOURS I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT AT THIRTEEN OH FOUR-
WHICH CLARIFIES A PUBLIC
AGENCIES MUST AFFIRMATIVELY
FURTHER FAIR HOUSING. IN ALL
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT RELATED ACTIVITIES
EXISTING LAW ESTABLISHES THE
FAIR HOUSING ACT WHICH
PROHIBITS DISCRIMINATION IN THE
RENTAL SALE OR FINANCING OF
HOUSING BASED ON RACE COLOR
NATIONAL ORIGIN RELIGION SEX
FAMILY STATUS OR DISABILITY.
HOWEVER THERE HAVE BEEN RECENT
REPORTS OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THAT HAVE NOT ADEQUATELY FILLED
THEIR- FAIR HOUSING OBLIGATIONS
MAYBE THIRTEEN OR FOUR WILL
CLARIFY THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
MUST ADDRESS. RACIAL
INTEGRATION AND SEGREGATION
PATTERNS AS WELL AS OTHER FAIR
HOUSING ISSUES WITHIN THEIR
JURISDICTION AS A WHOLE- AS
WELL AS THEIR INVENTORY OF
HOUSING SITES. AND THEIR POLICY
GOALS RELATING TO AFFIRMATIVELY
FURTHERING FAIR HOUSING MOVING
FORWARD. THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
BILL THAT WILL ENSURE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE ADDRESSING
HOUSING INEQUITIES AND ACTIVELY
PLANNING FOR A MORE INTEGRATED
AND EQUITABLE FUTURE I ASKED
FOR AND I WILL. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SAYING MAN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA I ACTIONS I
FACE NO BACKER HI FORTIS NOPE
BRADFORD I KERR BY ADAM I
PROTECTING OUR YOUTH DALLY. NO
DODD I TORONTO I EGGMAN GLAZER
I CONSOLIDATE I GROVE. NO
HERTZBERG I WAS SO HI HER TADO
I JONES NO CAN LONGER I LAYERED
I LLEVA HI THE MOON HI WIRE. HI
MELINDA'S NO MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. BUT SHOW VOGUE NO PAM
HI FORTUNE TINO I. ROSS. HI
RUBIO HI SKINNER FIVE STERNE
AMBERG ALL RIGHT I LIKE HOW SKI
I WINNER I WILL KNOW PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. EGGMAN
NIELSEN NO STERN. ICE TWENTY
NINE KNOWS NINE PHOTOS NINE
KNOWS. AS YOUR PASSES MOVING
ONTO FILE ITEM ONE OF SIX
INTERLEAVE IS READY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE EIGHTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RODRIGUEZ AN ACT
RELATING TO EMERGENCY SERVICES
CENTER LABOR THE FLOOR'S YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT GOOD
EVENING MEMBERS THIS BILL AN
AXE RECOMMENDATIONS IDENTIFIED
IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITORS WILL REPORT ENTITLED.
CALIFORNIA IS NOT ADEQUATELY
PREPARED TO PROTECT ITS MOST
VULNERABLE RESIDENTS FROM
NATURAL DISASTERS. EIGHTY FIVE
EIGHTY WILL PROTECT VULNERABLE
PEOPLE SUCH AS THE H. BLIND
DISABLED THOSE WITH LANGUAGE
BARRIERS AND OTHERS BY
REQUIRING THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICE TO
COORDINATE WITH REPRESENTATIVES
OF THE ACCESS AND FUNCTIONAL
NEEDS POPULATION. WHEN THE
OFFICE UPDATES THE STATE
EMERGENCY PLAN. THIS BILL ALSO
REQUIRES COUNTIES TO SEND A
COPY OF THEIR EMERGENCY PLANS
TO- YES ON OR BEFORE MARCH
FIRST TWO TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
THE BILL WILL REQUIRE- YES IN
CONSULTATION WITH
REPRESENTATIVES OF PEOPLE WITH
A VARIETY OF ACCESS AND
FUNCTIONAL NEEDS TO REVIEW THE
EMERGENCY PLAN OF EACH COUNTY
TO DETERMINE WHETHER THE PLANS
ARE CONSISTENT. WITH BEST
PRACTICES AND GUIDANCE MEMBERS
EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY WILL IMPROVE
EMERGENCY PLANNING AND
COORDINATIONWITH VOLVO
CALIFORNIANS AND IT WILL SAVE
LIVES OUR SUCCESS FOR NIVEAU.
THREE DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SINGMAN MEMBERS THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING THE A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING NONE ICE THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
SENATOR HERTZBERG WOULD YOU
LIKE TO TAKE UP YOUR MEASURE.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ I
DON'T FOLLOW HIM NUMBER ONE OH
NINE. THE ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
NINETY FOUR BY THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON PRIVACY AND
CONSUMER PROTECTION AND
ACTUALLY THE CONSUMERS SENATOR
HERTZBERG SUPPORTERS THANK YOU
THIS MEASURE MAKES A NUMBER OF
TECHNICAL CHANGES TO THE BNP
CODE. ENTER THE CCPA THAT WE
ADOPTED A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO
EXTENDS THE FIVE YEARS THE
AUTHORITY OF COUNTIES TO CHARGE
FEES FOR INSPECTING AND TESTING
WEIGHTS AND MEASURES DEVICES
RECEIVE UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN
BOTH HOUSES NO OPPOSITION
ASTRONAUT BOTH. THIRTY
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEAMAN MEMBERS THIS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ANY
OBJECTION TO USING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING NONE ICE THIRTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS ARE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO FILE IT IN NUMBER
ONE TEN CENTER GONZALEZ IS
READY MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ SOMEBODY BUILT THREE
THIRTY NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LEE AND ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC
MEETINGS. CENTER GONZALEZ.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS TODAY AND PRESENTING AB
THREE THREE NINE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE WHICH
EXPANDS OPPORTUNITIES FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. TO
ENGAGE WITH THEIR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THIS BILL REQUIRES
CITY COUNCIL AND COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS IN JURISDICTIONS
WITH A POPULATION OF OVER TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC TO PARTICIPATE
EITHER THROUGH TELEPHONE OR
THROUGH INTERNET AT THEIR LOCAL
MEETINGS WE KNOW THIS IS
POSSIBLE AS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HAVE SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENTED
REMOTE PARTICIPATION OPTIONS
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC. TO
ADDRESS COST CONCERNS THE
AUTHOR HAS TAKEN MANY
SUBSTANTIVE AMENDMENTS
THROUGHOUT THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS IN ORDER FOR US TO HAVE
A REPRESENTATIVE GOVERNMENT WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO HEAR THE
VOICES OF ALL OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND REDUCE.
EXISTING BARRIERS IN PLACE THAT
STOP THEM FROM PARTICIPATING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE. ON
A. B. THREE THREE NINE. IS
THERE ANY. DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NONE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN. ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS I BASE. BACKER HI FOR
JUST. BRADFORD I HAVE A-
CORTESE I. DALLY NO DOG. I
TORONTO HI ADNAN GLAZER.
GONZALEZ I DROVE NO HERTZBERG I
WAS SO HI FURTADO JONES
CAMCORDER. I LAYERED HI LLEVA.
HI THE MOON HI WIRE HI
MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN. I
NIELSEN NO A SHOW OF BOTH I CAN
I PORT AND YOU KNOW HI RALPH I
REVERE HI SKINNER. I STERN
AMBER I LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER.
I WILL NO PLEASE CALL THE OB TO
MEMBERS. ALAN BATES. GORGEOUS
NO. COME BY ELEVEN NO. ADMIN
GLAZER. HER TADO NO JONES.
MELINDA'S TURN. GOD I DON'T
KNOW. THE I. TWENTY FIVE KNOWS
EIGHT THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO GO BACK TO
ITEM EIGHTY ONE. I'D M. EIGHTY
ONE SENATOR MCGUIRE IS READY.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR EIGHTY ONE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER TO AN ACT
RELATING TO MILITARY EQUIPMENT-
MY GUARD FOR TWO YEARS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH BETTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SAY AB FORTY ONE BY SIN
REMEMBER Q. IS A GOOD
GOVERNMENT TELL IT ESTABLISHES
TRANSPARENCY BETWEEN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES WHO SERVE THAT WITH
REGARD TO THE USE OF MILITARY
EQUIPMENT. THE BILL CALLS FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THIS IS ALL
ABOUT LOCAL CONTROL IT CALLS
FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO WORK
WITH OUR LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
ENFORCEMENT PARTNERS TO
ESTABLISH A TRANSPARENT
MILITARY EQUIPMENT POLICY THAT
ALLOWS FOR BASIC ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR THE PUBLIC. IT SIMPLY ASKED
STATE AGENCIES TO ESTABLISH A
CLEAR MILITARY EQUIPMENT USE
POLICY THAT'S REVIEWED BY THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IN POSTED
ONLINE FOR THE PUBLIC TO SEE
THE BILL'S FINAL VERSION
ADDRESSES KEY CONCERNS BY THE
POLICE CHIEF OF THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL AND WAS ARRIVED
AT AFTER SIGNIFICANT ENGAGEMENT
BETWEEN US AND THE VIRTUE WHICH
GRATEFUL FOR HIS WORK- AS WELL
AS LAW ENFORCEMENT. NOTHING IN
THIS BILL NOTHING IN THIS BILL
RESTRICTS THE COMMUNITY OR
POLICE DEPARTMENT FOR PROCURING
ANY MILITARY COMMAND THEY
CHOOSE TO THE BILL WOULD SIMPLY
ENSURE THE PUBLIC KNOWS WINNING
HOW MILITARY EQUIPMENT BEING
USED ESPECIALLY WHEN PUBLIC
DOLLARS ARE PAYING. FOR THAT
EQUIPMENT WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AND I HAVE A- THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE THIS ITEM.
SENATOR BURGESS. A RISE IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL I THINK THIS IS ANOTHER
EXAMPLE OF US MICROMANAGING LAW
ENFORCEMENT. WITHOUT HAVING THE
REQUISITE INSIDE UNDERSTANDING
OF THE THREAT THEY ARE FIGHTING
AGAINST MANY OF THESE GANGS.
HAVE SOPHISTICATED WEAPONS. SO
WHETHER YOU'RE IN SWAT OR IN
SOME OTHER TACTICAL UNIT. BEING
ABLE TO HAVE THIS INFORMATION
IN A REHAB THESE RESOURCES AT
YOUR DISPOSAL ARE TERRIBLY
IMPORTANT SO THIS IDEA THAT. IF
THEY COULD GIVE A CITY OR A
COUNTY WERE TO CREATE A
MILITARY EQUIPMENT PURCHASE
LIST. THAT IS ONLY A SEGUE INTO
JUSTIFICATION FOR WHY IT'S
NEEDED AT ALL. AND I THINK WE
ALL KNOW WHERE THIS IS GOING
THIS IS. A CLEAR EXAMPLE OF A
PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT HAS
THAT'S GOING TO HAVE.
CONSEQUENCES THAT. ULTIMATELY
IS TRYING TO TIE THE HANDS OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT IN THEIR
ABILITY TO HANDLE DYNAMIC IN
VERY DANGEROUS SITUATIONS. SO I
WOULD I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST COLLEAGUES LOOK AT THIS
FOR WHAT IT IS. THIS IS NOT
GIVING LOCALS THE AUTHORITY TO
DECIDE ON MILITARY EQUIPMENT
LESS IMPOSING IT ON LINE. THIS
IS A PRELUDE TO THEM HAVING TO
JUSTIFY THE PURCHASE OF THAT
EQUIPMENT HOW IT'S ARSENAL LIES
IN HOW ULTIMATELY IT IS USED. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST A NO VOTE.
FOR ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SENATOR
REID JUST A QUESTION OF THE
AUTHOR OF THE PRESENT. DO YOU
ACCEPT IT A QUESTION CENTER
MOLESTED A PRESENT THANK YOU HE
WILL. I GUESS MY QUESTION IS
THE OPPOSITION LISTA. UP TO
DATE ON THIS PARTICULAR FLORIDA
OFFICES. THANK YOU SO MUCH AT
SENATOR AS FAR AS IT BEING UP
TO DATE I DON'T KNOW IF IT
REFLECTS THE DAY OF SEPTEMBER
NINTH WHICH IS TODAY SO I
APOLOGIZE AND I DON'T KNOW HOW
UP TO DATE D. SUPPORTER IN
OPPOSITION LISTED. AND IF I MAY
ASK ONE MORE QUESTION THIS
THROUGH THE EMAIL PRESIDENT.
MMHM YOU KNOW I HAVEN'T VOTED
FOR THESE BILLS IN THE PAST AT
LEAST THE ONES THAT I RECALL.
BUT AS I READ THIS ONE AND I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE I'M CLEAR-
MISSED FOR MANAGER. PRESIDENT
THERE'S A LIST OF IN THE BILL
ITSELF IS A LIST OF. ALL SORTS
MOTOR EQUIPMENT FROM. FIFTY
CALIBER AMMUNITION TO WATER
CANNONS TO A WHOLE VARIETY OF
THINGS- SOME OF WHICH I HAVE
DIFFICULTY UNDERSTANDING. HOW
THOSE COULD BE UTILIZED IN AN
URBAN SETTING BUT OTHER PIECES
OF EQUIPMENT I COULD SEE IN
CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES YOU MIGHT
WANT TO. DEPLOY ALL THE ALL OF
THAT EQUIPMENT. IT CAN BE
PURCHASED. BY LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY PROVIDED
THAT THE LOCAL BOARD WHETHER
IT'S A CITY COUNCIL OR BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. AUTHORIZES THAT
ACQUISITION IN A POLICY AND
PRESUMABLY AT THE TIME OF
PURCHASE BECAUSE OF COURSE THE
BUDGETS HAVE TO BE APPROVED BY
THOSE OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT
BODIES IS THAT CORRECT SENATOR
YOU'RE CORRECTED BILL DOES NOT.
ADVANCE AN OUTRIGHT BAN IN FACTTHE PREVIOUS BILL WHEN GOVERNOR
BROWN WHY IS IN OFFICE WAS
VETOED BECAUSE HE BELIEVED THAT
THIS ORIGINAL BILL THE ORIGINAL
BILL OF WHAT WE HAVE IN FRONT
OF US TODAY QUOTE WAS OVERLY
BROAD- I WANT TO MAKE SURE
FOLKS KNOW ON THE RECORD- THAT.
LAW ENFORCEMENT CAN CONTINUE TO
PURCHASE BUT THEY DO HAVE TO
LISTED- IN A PUBLIC FORUM SO
THE NAME IS THAT WE'RE TAKING
CLARIFY. THAT ITS GENERAL USE
IN QUITMAN STANDARD ISSUE ITEMS
RIDGE ARRANGING FO PEPPER
SPRAYED SHOT GUNS- IN THIS
MEANS LAW ENFORCEMENT CAN
CONTINUE ACQUIRING DAILY USE
ITEMS- IS WELL SO AGAIN IT
SIMPLY CREATES THIS DATABASE
BUT IT DOES NOT BAN- THE
PURCHASE OF EQUIPMENT. WELL
THANK YOU SIR I THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. IN MADAM PRESIDENT
IF IT'S ALRIGHT I JUST RECEIVED
INFORMATION TO- THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM IN AN EMPIRE THE
ONLY GROUP AS OF TODAY MY
UNDERSTANDING FROM THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE IS THE AGAIN ALWAYS WANT
TO BE TRANSPARENT TO THE
CHAMBER THAT REMAINS THE STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION THAT THEY
REMAIN IN OPPOSITION- CURRENTLY
SO I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WAS A QUESTION THAT WAS
ASKED I COULDN'T ANSWER I DO
HAVE THE ANSWER INTO TO SENATOR
ROSS I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT IT WAS ABLE TO ANSWER THAT.
SENATOR MELINDA IS I THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT- SENATORS I
THINK THE PREVIOUS SPEAKERS
BROUGHT UP SOME VERY GOOD
POINTS TONIGHT IT'S- NOT
NECESSARILY IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF PUBLIC SAFETY TO
HAVE OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES HAVE TO SAY MOTHER MAY
I BEFORE THEY PURCHASE QUICK
MINUTE EQUIPMENT THAT THEY NEED
TO KEEP THE COMMUNITY SAFE AND
IF YOU LOOK AT THE LIST OF
ITEMS YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT YEAH
THERE'S CERTAINLY SOME BIG
TICKET ITEMS IN THERE AND SOME
BIGGER PIECES OF EQUIPMENT. BUT
THERE'S ALSO SIMPLE THINGS LIKE
BEAN BAGS AND EQUIPMENT TO YOU
KNOW BE ABLE TO BREAK DOWN THE
DOOR TO GET IN THERE AND GET
SOMEONE WHO'S IN DANGER- I JUST.
IS THAT WHERE WE WANT TO GO
WHERE WE WANT TO HAVE OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT QUESTION BY CITY
COUNCIL MEMBERS. WHO VERY
LIKELY ARE NOT LAW ENFORCEMENT-
FORMER LAW ENFORCEMENT MEMBERS
THEMSELVES ARE THEY THE BEST
PEOPLE TO DECIDE. WHETHER OR
NOT THE- AGENCIES NEED THOSE
THINGS TO BE ABLE TO KEEP THE
COMMUNITY SAFE I THINK THIS
GOES. A LITTLE FAR AND I WOULD
URGE YOU KNOW BUT THANK YOU. IS
THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CENTER MY
WORRY MAKING FOOD THANK YOU SO
MUCH LOOK. I UNDERSTAND IT IS
CONTAGIOUS CONCERNS AND REALLY
GRATEFUL I TWO THREE SENATORS
ADVANCED QUESTIONS AND CONCERNS.
NUMBER TWO HAS BEEN WORKING TO
BE ABLE TO NARROW THIS DOWN.
AND TO BE ABLE TO FOCUS ON SOME
OF THE BIGGER CHALLENGES. SO
AGAIN THIS MEANS LAW
ENFORCEMENT WITH THIS BILL
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN COULD
CONTINUE ACQUIRING DAILY USE
ITEMS SUCH AS PEPPER SPRAY
STANDARD ISSUE FIREARMS- IS
WELL WITHOUT ANY NEW REPORTING
UNDER THIS BILL BUT LOOK WE ALL
TALK ABOUT LOCAL CONTROL WE ALL
TALK ABOUT TRANSPARENCY. THIS
BILL ADVANCES LOCAL CONTROL.
AND IT'S ULTIMATELY UP TO THE
ELECTED OFFICIALS BOARDS OF
SUPERVISORS CITY COUNCILS
APPEAR TO MAKE THIS DECISION.
NUMBER TWO IT'S ALSO ABOUT
TRANSPARENCY IN THE PUBLIC DOES
DESERVE TO BE ABLE TO SEE- WHAT
LAW ENFORCEMENT MILITARY
EQUIPMENT IS POTENTIALLY BEING
PURCHASED OUT OF LOCAL CONTROL
IN RESPECT FOR TRANSPARENCY
WOULD RESPECTFULLY RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. ADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ARCHULETA. AT KINS I FACE NO
BACKER. HI FOR JUST NO BRADFORD
I KERR BY ADAM I PROTESTING HI
DALLY NO GOD. NO TORONTO I
EGGMAN GLAZER. GONZALEZ HI
GROVE NO HERTZBERG I WAS SO. I
HER TADO I JONES NO CAN LONGER.
LAYERED I LLEVA I THE MOON.
MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S NO MAN.
NEWMAN NIELSEN NO A TURBO NO
PAM HI FORTUNE TINO. I BROUGHT
HI RUBIO I SKINNER HI STERN
AMBERG HI I LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER. I WILL. NO THIS CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN I
ARCHULETA I. EGGMAN GLAZER. CAN
LONGER I LET ALONE. IN. NO
NEWMAN. STERN. FIVE TWENTY FOUR
NOS ELEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY EIGHT
SENATOR MCGUIRE IS READY MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTEEN ELEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD AN ACT
RELATING TO RECYCLING. SENATOR
MCGUIRE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE PRESIDENT TO- I JUST WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU TO SOME MEMBER
WOULD FOR HIS FOCUS ON THIS
VEHICLE. IT'S A DISTRICT BILL%
MUCH OF THE MODERN RECYCLING
MOVEMENT CAN TRACE ITS ROOTS
BACK ACTUALLY TO THE CITY OF
ARCADIA AND IN FACT FORMER
SENATOR WEST CHESBRO. WAS ONE
OF THE LEADERS IN THE- IN
AMERICA'S RECYCLING MOVEMENT.
FOR DECADES THESE LEADERS IN
THESE COMMUNITIES HAVE LED THE
WAY BUT AS IT STANDS TODAY IT'S
EFFECTIVELY IMPOSSIBLE FOR
RESIDENTS IN HUMBOLDT AND MANY
OTHER RURAL COUNTIES. TO REDEEM
THE YEAR C. R. V. CONTAINERS.
THE SETTLEMENT HAS BEEN WORKING
WITH LOCAL STAKEHOLDERS TO
IDENTIFY A HANDFUL OF SMALL
CHANGES THAT WOULD ALLOW
RECYCLING CENTERS TO BE ABLE TO
OPEN IN THE BEAUTIFUL COUNTY OF
HUMBOLDT. THESE MODEST CHANGES
BY NO MEANS SOLVE THE CRISIS
THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA RECYCLING. BUT IT IS
A SIGNIFICANT STEP FORWARD
GRATEFUL FOR THESE SOME MEMBERS
WORK- AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN IPHONE. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SINGMAN MEMBERS THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
C. NINE EYES THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA GO BACK TO
UNFINISHED BUSINESS. UNFINISHED
BUSINESS. SENTIMENT SENATOR
MICHAEL WOULD YOU LIKE TO TAKE
UP YOUR BILLS AND UNFINISHED
BUSINESS SINCE YOU'RE ON A ROLL.
SO WE'LL START WITH FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVENTEEN. SENATOR
MCGUIRE IS READY MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL THREE FORTY ONE BY SENATOR
MCGUIRE AN ACT RELATING TO
TELECOMMUNICATIONS CENTER MY
GARDEN FOR TWO YEARS THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THE PRESIDENT I
KNOW IT'S ME IN FRONT OF OUR
DINNER BREAKS ON BE QUICK I
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
NUMBERS FROM TO HEMA. BEAVER
NAPA AND CONTRA COSTA FOR THEIR
WORK ON THIS IS WELL LONG STORY
SHORT THE NAME IS TAKEN YOU
SIMPLY ENSURE THAT BACKUP POWER
REQUIREMENTS ON
TELECOMMUNICATIONS EQUIPMENT-
N. CALLAWAY S. MAPPING
REGULATIONS ARE BOTH CONSISTENT
WITH THE EXISTING CPUC
PROCEEDINGS AT THESE ELEMENTS
OF- BROUGHT MUCH OF THE
WIRELESS INDUSTRY TO NEUTRAL I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND
I VOTE ON THIS BIPARTISAN
MEASURE. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SINGMAN MEMBERS THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL ANY OBJECTION TO USING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING
NONE ICE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO.
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND
MEMBERS AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY NINE.
SENATOR MCGUIRE IS READY MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL SIXTY NINE BY SENATOR
MCGUIRE AND ACTUALLY IN
TRANSPORTATION CENTER MAGUIRE I
RISE TO PRESENT DSD SIXTY NINE
IS THE GREAT RIVER TRAIL ACTED
SMACK ON CONCURRENCE IN THEM
AND TAKING THE SIMPLY-
TECHNICALLY REMOVE ONE SECTION
DEALING WITH A POTENTIAL
TRANSFER OF AGENCY ASSETS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES AND IT FURTHER
CLOVER CLARIFIES THAT THE STATE
WILL NOT BE RESPONSIBLE FOR ANY
POTENTIAL LIABILITIES AND MAKE
ONE CODE CHANGE. HAS BROAD
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NIVEAU.
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. HE'S SAYING NONE
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SEEING NONE ICE THIRTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THE MEASURE THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. ITEM NUMBER FIFTY
SIX SENATOR MCGUIRE IS PREPARED
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL SEVEN
SIXTEEN BY SENATOR MCGUIRE AND
ACTUALLY DIDN'T LAND USE
SENATOR MCGUIRE THANK YOU SO
MUCH AT THIS BUILDING SINCE A
SEVEN SET FOR THE HABITAT FOR
RESTORATION ENHANCEMENT ACT
AMENDMENTS TAKEN THE SIMPLY
EXTEND THE SUNSET ON PROVISIONS
IN LAW ARE RELATED TO THE
ENDOWMENT ACCOUNTS FOR
MITIGATION LAND- AND I KNOW
THAT ALL OF YOUR TAKING NOTES
ON THIS. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
NO VOTE. I KNOW. WHEN I VOTE
THIS IS JUST TO SEE IF YOU'RE
AWAKE. THIS IS RECEIVED NO NO
VOTES THEN HE CLARIFIED WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I VOTE
THAT WAS EMBARRASSING. IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SENATOR THERE.
PRESIDENT COULD WE SUBSTITUTE A
UNANIMOUS YOU KNOW ROLL CALL
FOR THIS FILM. SEEING SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS. ROLL
CALL ANY OPPOSITION TO USING
THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL WHICH
IS OF COURSE. THIRTY EIGHT EYES
AND ZERO KNOWS. THIRTY EIGHT
FIVE ZERO NO. THE MAN THAT-
SOMEBODY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS ARE GOING
TO RECESS FOR THE DINNER OUT AT
THE DINNER AND OUR RETURN AT
SIX. I KNOW WE'RE ALL ANXIOUS
TO FINISH UP THERE ARE A-
UNFINISHED BUSINESS WILL COME
BACK AND WE'LL WE'LL DO IT AT
THAT TIME. WE. AT SIX O'CLOCK
IT ENSURES THAT WE GET THROUGH
OUR BUSINESS AND THAT WE CAN BE
OUT OF HERE IN A NOT TOO LATE
OUR.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FORTY
SIX. FILE ITEM NUMBER FORTY SIX
A SENATOR GONZALES. SHE IS
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL SIX OH SIX BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ LIKE AN ACT
RELATING TO OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY.
SENATOR GONZALES THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT SP
SIX OF SIX WHICH IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE IN ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN
THE ASSEMBLY REMOVE LANGUAGE
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD HAVE
AUTHORIZED COLOURS TO ENFORCE
CERTAIN PORTIONS OF THE LABOR
CODE. CLARIFY THE DEFINITION OF
A GREGIS VIOLATION SIMPLIFY THE
ABATEMENT PROCESSOR AND A WHITE
ENTERPRISE WIDE BY CITATIONS
AND GIVE EMPLOYERS A THIRTY DAY
BUFFER TOO BYE BYE EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS THESE CHANGES ARE
CRITICAL TO STRENGTHENING
WORKPLACE PROTECTIONS AND
ENSURING HEALTH AND SAFETY FOR
ALL WORKERS THANK YOU KNOW
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOREIGN FIVE
VOTE. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SAYING
NONE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
I ARCHULETA I ADKINS I HATE NO
FACTOR. FOR JUST NO BRADFORD I
HAVE A I DON'T. HI PROTESTING
FIVE DALLY NO DOG. YOU'RE
AWESOME. EGGMAN LASER NO GUNS
ALLAH'S I GROW NO HERTZBERG I
WAS SO. HURTADO JONES NO CAN
LONGER LAYERED I LIVE ON. I THE
MOON. WIRE I MELINDA'S. MAN
MELINDA'S. NO MAN I NEWMAN I
NELSON. THE TROUBLE NOPE PAN HI
FORTUNE TINO. I. ROSS HI RUBIO
I SKINNER HI STERN AMBERG I
PLAYED HOCKEY HI WINNER. WELL
NO. WEST SO I'D- SENATOR
GONZALES MOVED THE CALL WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER FORTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
ROB IS PREPARED PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SIX OH SEVEN BY
SENATOR MAN AN ACT RELATING TO
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS AND
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE. SENATOR ROB. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THIS
OMNIBUS BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS BILL IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
REVISE SENSEI DATES FOR A
NUMBER OF PROGRAMS. ELIMINATE A
REQUIREMENT FOR STUDENTS
STUDENTS TO COMPLETE A TEST
PROGRAM AND ROMANOF PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATIONS.
INSTITUTIONS AND ADDRESS
CHAPTER RING ISSUES REQUESTS
AND I VTE. THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SINGMAN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA I AT KINS I
FACE. BACKER FOR JUST. BRADFORD
I COME BY OTHER HYPERTENSIVE I
DALLY. GOD I TORONTO. EGGMAN
LASER. GONZALEZ I GROSS.
HERTZBERG I WAS SO SORRY FOR
TIDO I JONES. I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I LABOR I THE MOON. I
REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S I MEAN I
NEWMAN I NELSON. A SHOW OF BOTH
HI PAM I PERSONS YOU KNOW HI
RALPH I RUBIO HI SKINNER. HI
STERN ON BURKE I LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER. WELL I SENATOR ROCK
MUSICAL MOVING UNDER FILE ITEM
NUMBER FORTY EIGHT SENATOR HER
DAUGHTER IS PREPARED PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL SIX OH NINE
BY SENATOR HER TADO AN ACT
RELATING TO CALFRESH. CENTER
TYLER THE FLOOR'S YOURS THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT- SP SIX
ZERO NINE IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE SP SIX ZERO NINE
GRANTED OFFICIALS PARTICIPATED
IN ADULT EDUCATION AND CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION PROGRAMS
ACCESS TO CALFRESH BENEFITS.
THIS BILL SUPPORTS OLDER
STUDENTS LOOKING TO RE ENTER
THE WORKFORCE OFFERING THEM
ACCESS TO AID BEGINS TO SUSTAIN
THEMSELVES AND THOSE AROUND
THEM ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS TO THE
BILL REMOVES LANGUAGE
PERTAINING TO CALFRESH ET
EXPANSION AND IMPROVEMENT- THIS
BILL RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN THE ASSEMBLY FORM
HAS NO OPPOSITION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY BOAT.
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NONE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA I
AND CAN I FACE I BACKER HI OR
JUST. HI BRADFORD HI HAVE MY
OTHER HYPERTENSIVE I DELHI I
DONT HI YOU'RE AWESOME HI ADNAN
GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE I GROW. I
HURTS BERG. WEST SO HI HER TADO
HI JONES I CAN LONGER I LAYERED
I LABOUR HI THE MOON. HI WIRE.
HI MELINDA'S I MEN FIVE NEWMAN
I NIELSEN. A TROUBLED. I CAN I
PERSON TINA I BROUGHT HI RUBIO
I'VE SKINNER. HI STERN NUMBER
FIVE CASSIE I WINNER. WELL I
SENT HER DAUGHTER MOVES A CALL
MOVING ON FILE ITEM NUMBER
FORTY NINE SENATOR LAYERED IS
READY PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL
SIX NINETEEN BY SENATOR LAYERED
SOONER OR LATER THE FLOOR'S
YOURS THANK YOU S. B. SIX
NINETEEN HIS SUPPORT FOR THE
STATE PART ORGANIC WASTE
DIVERSION PROGRAM. AMENDMENTS
TAKEN IN THE ASSEMBLY PROVIDES
LIMITED RELIEF FROM FINES AND
PENALTIES IN EXCHANGE FOR
CONTINUED PROGRESS TO MEET THE
REGULATION REQUIREMENTS BUT NOW
WITH OUR BUDGET ACTIONS THERE
SIXTY MILLION. DOLLARS IN THE
BUDGET TO ASSIST LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS IMPLEMENT THAT
THIS INTERNET EDITION ALL
AMOUNT TO A- TO IMPLEMENT
STATEWIDE THEIR SUPPORT ON BOTH
SIDES I WOULD ASK FOR MICHAEL.
THIRTY IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SAYING
MAN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
I ARCHULETA I ADKINS I FACE. HI
BECKER. ARI FORGES I BRADFORD I
HAVE ITEM I PROTESTED. I. DALI.
I DON. HI TORONTO. HI ADNAN
LASER. AIKENS ALL AS I GROW. I
HURTS BERG I WAS SO. HI HER
TADO HI JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED. I LABOUR I THE MOON I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S. FIVE MAN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN I SHOW ABOVE I
CAN HI FORTUNE TINO HI RALPH I
RUBIO FIVE SKINNER FIVE STERNE
AMBERG ALL RIGHT HI WHAT KIND
OF SKI. I WINNER. WELL I. THE
SINNER LAYERED MOOSE CALL.
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER FIFTY
ONE FILE ITEM NUMBER FIFTY ONE
SENATOR DR SO IS PREPARED
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL SIX
THIRTY NINE BY SENATOR ALSO AN
ACT RELATING TO EMPLOYMENT
CENTER DRAWS A- THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT YES PLEASE SIX THIRTY
NINE IS UP FOR CONCURRENCE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS INCLUDE-
THAT SELF ADVOCATES WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCE WORKING FOR SUB
MINIMUM WAGES WILL SERVE. ON
THE ADVISORY GROUP THAT WILL
PLAN THE PHASE OUT OF SUB
MINIMUM WAGE EMPLOYMENT IN
CALIFORNIA THEY ALSO INSURE
THAT SUB MINIMUM WAGE WILL NOT
BE PHASED OUT PRIOR TO
DEVELOPMENT OF THE PHASE OUT
PLAN. AND THEY MAKE OTHER
TECHNICAL AND CONFORMING
CHANGES AND ADD COOP AS I ASK
FOR YOUR CONCURRENCE WITH
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SENATOR
DOLLY. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I AM REALLY
TORN ON THIS BILL AS SOMEBODY
WHO IS EMPLOYED. THE PEOPLE
THAT WERE IN PRISON AND FELONS
AND TRYING TO HELP PEOPLE IN
OUR LIVES NEVER HAD- LIKE.
SEVERELY DISABLED BUT- YOU KNOW
THE GOAL IS TO. HAVE THE
ABILITY BELLA. HELP THEM GET A
JOB AND THE SKILL SETS ALWAYS
AREN'T AT THE LEVEL OF THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THE JOBBUT-
OTHER QUICK A QUICK ACTION OF A
QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR IF I MAY.
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR. ARE
YOU WILLING TO TAKE IT CENTER.
I'M I'M SO VERY SORRY MENTIONED
CANNOT HEAR THE QUESTION AGAIN
WELL I HAVEN'T HE HASN'T ASKED
IT I'M JUST ASKING IF IT'S OKAY
IF YOU ASK YOU A QUESTION ALL.
SURE HE WILL TAKE THE QUESTION
SO THE GOAL IS TO ACTUALLY
EMPLOY THEM AND DO YOU BELIEVE
THAT IF WE RAISE THE RATE TO
THE MINIMUM WAGE THAT WILL
THEY'LL ACTUALLY NOT BE HIRED
THAT'S WHAT I'M WORRIED ABOUT
IS THAT AN EMPLOYER WOULD GO
WITH THE SKILLS THAT WILL MAYBE
NOT BE THERE BUT I WOULD BE
WILLING TO YOU KNOW TAKE TAKE
THE CHANCE AND MAYBE. HELP THEM
BE EMPLOYED. BECAUSE IT'S A
LOWER RATE AND IT'S GONNA TAKE
MORE WORK OR DO YOU BELIEVE
THAT WE'RE GOING TO ACTUALLY.
KEEP THEM EMPLOYED I I'M THAT'S
TORRES WAS TEARING ME ABOUT
THIS. THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION
SURE. FRENCH PRESIDENT YOU MAY
PROCEED THANK YOU- YES- WE ARE
GOING IN THAT DIRECTION ANYWAY
AS A COUNTRY- THERE ARE
APPROXIMATELY TEN OTHER STATES
THAT HAVE ALREADY GONE IN THIS
DIRECTION EVERYWHERE FROM NEW
YORK TO CONNECTICUT TO TEXAS.
R. ALASKA THEY'VE ALREADY MADE
THIS DECISION IN THEIR STATE-
SO I FEEL VERY COMFORTABLE THAT
IF IT HAD- BECAUSE- OUR
BROTHERS AND SISTERS IN THE
DISABILITY COMMUNITY TO LOSE.
OUT ON THAT DECISION. THAT IT
WOULDN'T HAVE GONE AS FAR AS
THE DATE AS FAR AS STATE TO
STATE TO STATE- WE ALSO TOOK
THE A MODEL OF MARYLAND- TO
COME UP WITH. THESE KIND OF
AMENDMENTS FOR EXAMPLE TO HAVE
SELF ADVOCATES THOSE WHO
ACTUALLY WORKED FOR SOME
MINIMUM WAGE OUGHT TO BE ON THE
ADVISORY SO WE COULD IT'S NOT
ME TELLING THEM. BUT IT'S
ACTUALLY THEY THEMSELVES
PARTICIPATING- WE ALSO CHANGED
IT TO SAY THAT A PHASE OUT PLAN
WOULD BE DEVELOPED WITH ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND THEIR
INVOLVEMENT SO WE'RE NOT
LOOKING TO DO THIS FROM ONE DAY
TO ANOTHER. IT WILL BE THREE
YEARS WE WILL HAVE A PHASE OUT
PLAN WE ARE NOT LOOKING OUT TO
HURT ANYBODY'S CHANCES OF
WORKING. BUT WE DO FEEL VERY
STRONGLY THAT. WHEN THEY WORK
THEY OUGHT TO BE ABLE TO COUNT
ON THE MINIMUM WAGE IN THIS
STATE AND I KNOW NATIONALLY-
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS ALSO
LOOKING IN THAT DIRECTION
THAT'S BEEN THE CONVERSATION
FOR A FEW YEARS SO- THE NUMBER
OF EMPLOYERS WHO ARE USING
THESE WAIVERS. HAS DECREASED
EVERY YEAR HERE IN CALIFORNIA-
AND THE NUMBER OF THOSE WHO ARE
WORKING UNDER SOME MINIMUM WAGE
HAS ALSO DECREASED SO I BELIEVE
WE ARE GOING IN THAT DIRECTION
LET'S PLANET LET'S DO IT THE
RIGHT WAY. WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS INVOLVED IF I IF I
MAY JUST ASK ONE MORE FOLLOW UP
WAS THERE ANY. STATISTICS.
SHOWN IN THOSE OTHER STATES
WHERE. THE EMPLOYER'S ACTUALLY
DID NOT CONTINUE TO EMPLOY THEM
BECAUSE THE WAGE WENT HIGHER
MAYBE THAT'S A SIMPLE WAY OF
ASKING THE QUESTION. I'M SORRY
I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO THAT
SENATOR. THANK YOU FOR YOUR FOR
I REALLY WANT TO. I THINK THIS
IS AN OPPORTUNITY REALLY I'M
LOOKING AT IS- AND I'M JUST
CONCERNED THAT. IF THE SKILL
LEVEL IS NOT THERE TO MATCH THE
ABILITY FOR THE WAGE THAT IT
MAY BE ACTUALLY WORK IN REVERSE
WHERE THEY WOULD NOT HAVE THE
UPDATE WOULD BE HIRED. SO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR INPUT- SO I HAVE.
SENATOR HER DAUGHTER THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IT'S A
BILL THAT- WE HEARD AND HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE AND I KNOW
IT'S A VERY. IT'S A IT'S A
DIFFICULT ONE RIGHT I MEAN WE
DON'T WANT TO ELIMINATE A JOB
OPPORTUNITY- FOR OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATION BUT I.
THE PRACTICE AS THE AUTHOR
MENTIONED- WE ARE MOVING
TOWARDS THAT PATH TO THE MATTER
FIVE YEARS AND- IT AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL AND THERE'S
ALREADY STATES THAT ARE WORKING
TOWARDS- TRYING TO IMPLEMENT
THAT AS THE AUTHOR MENTIONED.
AND I THINK THAT THIS BILL WAS
IMPROVED AND TRYING TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE WAS AN ADEQUATE
TRANSITION PLAN IN THERE SO
THAT. THEY'RE NOT LEFT BEHIND
THAT THEY'RE NOT LEFT WITHOUT-
OR AT RISK OF LOSING THE DOES A
JOB OPPORTUNITIES AND THERE'S
ALSO MONEY. I BELIEVE IN THE
BUDGET- TO HELP WITH ADDITIONAL
EMPLOYMENT ACTIVITY SO JUST
WANTED TO- EXPRESSED MY SUPPORT
FOR THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION
AND FOR THE AUTHOR AND- AND FOR
ALL HER WORK AND AT. DOING
EVERYTHING SHE CAN TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT BECOMES EVEN BETTER AND
MORE PROTECTIONS. AND FOR THOSE
REASONS I ASKED FOR AND I PUT.
SENATOR WITH A THANK YOU AND I
APPLAUD THIS BILL THE AUTHOR
FOR TAKING IT UP BY I RAN WITH
THIS BILL AND SUCCESSFULLY
APPROXIMATELY SEVEN YEARS AGO
AND I LAMENT THE DAY DIDN'T
PASS BECAUSE I'VE HAD
EXPERIENCE WORKING- WITH THESE
INDIVIDUALS HAVE HAD.
EXPERIENCE IN TERMS OF HOW THEY
PERFORM THEIR JOBS WORKING WITH
THEM I'M CONVINCED THAT OUR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THAT ON
THIS EARTH. THERE IS A PLACE
FOR EVERY SINGLE PERSON. IN OUR
SOCIETY AND OUR ECONOMY THERE
IS A PLACE. AND WE SHOULD NOT
PUNISH THEM FOR BEING PART OF A
GROUP. THAT IS IDENTIFIED WITH
HER HAVING CERTAIN ABILITIES
AND NOT OTHERS WE DON'T DO THAT
TO ANY OTHER HUMAN BEINGS AND
IT JUST DOESN'T MAKE SENSE THAT
WE WOULD SINGLE THEM OUT. AND
THIS IS A FORM OF
DISCRIMINATION IN OUR SOCIETY
THAT WE NEED TO END. THERE IS A
PLACE FOR EVERYBODY LET'S WORK
VERY HARD. AS A LEGISLATURE
MAKE PLACE IN CALIFORNIA FOR
EVERYBODY DESPITE THEIR SKILL
SET. ANYBODY COULD BE TRAINED
TO DO ALMOST ANYTHING AND
SOMEBODY COULD HAVE SOMETHING
VERY SPECIAL TO CONTRIBUTE IN
THIS ECONOMY AND WE COULD FIND
THAT. I HAVE WORKED WITH SO
MANY. NEVER MISS A DAY SOME ARE
NEVER LATE. SUMMER VERY
PRODUCTIVE AND TAKE MORE PRIDE
IN DOING THEIR JOB. THEN AGAIN
ANOTHER PERSON THAT MAY BE
IDENTIFIED AS HAVING. YOUR
ABILITIES AND THAT'S THAT'S THE
BOTTOM LINE. WE NEE TO VALUE
PEOPLE FOR THE FOR THE SKILLS
THAT THEY DO POSSESS THEM AND
ALLOW THEM TO DEVELOP THOSE
SKILLS A LITTLE BIT MORE WORK
SUCCESSFULLY IN OUR ECONOMY
THIS IS OVERDUE. I HOPE WE
STAND TOGETHER UP IN A BI BI
PARTISAN EFFORT TO BRING AN END
TO THIS PRACTICE AND START
INVEST. IN THE PEOPLE OF OUR
STATE. SENATOR KAMMERER. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE AS A
STRONG SUPPORTER OF THIS BILL
AND HAS A PROUD CO AUTHOR. I
WAS I'M EXCITED TO HEAR IT WHEN
IT CAME BEFORE US IN HUMAN
SERVICES. AND I DON'T RECALL IF
I SHARED THIS IN THE COMMITTEE
BUT. MY STEP SON WAS DIAGNOSED
WITH AUTISM. AND I AS A RESULT
HAVE SPENT A LOT OF TIME AT
REGIONAL CENTERS GETTING TO
KNOW OTHER PARENTS. ADULT
CHILDREN AND YOUNG CHILDREN.
WHO ARE ON THE SPECTRUM. AND
LEARNING ABOUT WHAT IT MEANS.
TO LOVE SOMEONE AND TO WANT TO
SEE THEM SUCCEED. WHO WAS ON
THE SPECTRUM. AND ONE EVENING
AT THE WESTSIDE REGIONAL CENTER
I ENDED UP HAVING A DISCUSSION
WITH THIS FATHER OF AN ADULT
CHILD. WHO'S ON THE SPECTRUM.
AND HE TALKED ABOUT HIS SON
WANTING TO WORK. AND HAVING A
REALLY HARD TIME FINDING WORK.
BECAUSE OF HIS AUTISM. AND THE
GLORIOUS MESS THAT CAME WHEN HE
WAS ABLE TO SECURE HIM A JOB.
AT A THEME PARK. AND HE TALKED
ABOUT THE VALUE THAT COMES FROM
WORK. THE VALUE THAT COMES FROM
BEING THE VALUE. FROM BEING
ABLE TO DO SOMETHING. CREATE
SOME THINGS ARE SERVICE SOMEONE.
THAT'S WHAT EVERY PARENT IS
HOPING THEIR CHILD WILL FIND.
REGARDLESS OF IF THEY ARE ON
THE SPECTRUM OR NOT. I RECALL
ANOTHER DISCUSSION THAT I HAD
WITH AN ADVOCATE NAME HERALD
AND HERALD SAID. I'M ON THE
SPECTRUM AND I CAN TELL YOU
WHAT THAT'S LIKE. THAT'S LIKE
BEING IN A HAM RADIO IN AN FM
DIGITAL WORLD. IT DOESN'T MEAN
YOU CAN'T DO SOMETHING IT
DOESN'T MEAN YOU'RE NOT WORTH
THE SAME AS SOMEONE ELSE IT
JUST MEANS YOUR DIFFERENT. THIS
BILL. IT'S ABOUT. THE ONLY. OUR
FAMILY MEMBERS AND OUR BROTHERS
AND SISTERS. WHO ARE ON THE
SPECTRUM. WE FIGHT SO HARD.
INTEGRATE. OUR FAMILY MEMBERS.
INTO SPACES WHERE THEY CAN LIVE
AND LEARN AND LOVE AND WAR. AND
CONTRIBUTE IN WAYS THAT MAKE
THIS STATE AND OUR COMMUNITIES
AND THIS COUNTRY GREAT. AND IT
IS ABOUT TIME THAT WE SEE. M.
FOR ALL THAT THEY ARE WORTH. I
CAN'T TELL YOU. I CAN TELL YOU.
THE BRILLIANCE THAT COMES. FROM
BEING TOUCHED BY SOMEONE WHO IS
ON THE SPECTRUM. AND SO I WOULD
ASK THAT YOU WOULD TAKE THAT
INTO CONSIDERATION WITH THOSE
FOLKS EVEN THOUGH I KNOW IT'S
ON CONCURRENCE. IN THE ALL
RIGHT. BECAUSE WE SHOULD BE
VALUING OUR WORKERS. AND WE
SHOULD NOT BE PLACING A LESSER
VALUE ON THEM. BECAUSE THEY
HAVE A DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY
OR BECAUSE THEY ARE ON THE
SPECTRUM. AND SO WITH THAT I
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE FOR SB SIX
THREE NINE. SENATOR BAKER.
THANK YOU AND I THINK BY
CALLING FROM LOS ANGELES FOR
THOSE MOVING WORDS AND I JUST
WAS COMPELLED TO RISE AS WELL I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL MY
BROTHER IN LAW HAS WORKED IN A
SEVEN WAY TIE CAPACITY IN
OREGON FOR MANY YEARS AND
THEY'VE ALSO MOVED IN THIS
DIRECTION AND MY- MOTHER IN LAW
SAYS IT'S BEEN BASICALLY GOOD
BUT BUT ALSO THERE'S BEEN SOME
NEGATIVE INFOGRAPHIC CATIONS AS
WELL SO I JUST- HI I APPRECIATE
THE OFFER FOR THE WORK AND
THEN. AND I JUST HOPE THAT AS
WE DEVELOP THIS THIS PLAN- WE
REALLY DO- TAKING ACCOUNT- ALL
THOSE CHALLENGES AND- AND LOOK
AT SOME OF THE SITUATIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN WORKING AND- YOU KNOW
AS WE GO PLAN GOING FORWARD SO
AGAIN I WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL AND JUST WHEN IT RAISES
CONCERNS FROM FROM WHAT I'VE
SEEN IN THE ORGAN SITUATION I
KNOW THAT WE HAVE. TO BE VERY
CAREFUL IN THIS AREA THANK YOU.
SENATOR BATES. YES THANK YOU-
MAN PRESIDENTIAL IN MY EARLY
YEARS AS A SOCIAL WORKER MY
SPECIFIC ASSIGNMENT WAS WITH IN
THE PROGRAM CALLED AID TO THE
DISABLED SO WE HAD MANY MANY
PEOPLE WHO DID HAVE THE
CHALLENGES ON ACROSS THE
SPECTRUM CERTAINLY PHYSICAL
MENTAL HANDED THE PHONE MINIMUM
WAGE WAS REALLY A WAY TO
INCENTIVIZE EMPLOYERS TO
ACTUALLY EMPLOY THESE
INDIVIDUALS AND I BELIEVE THE
IDEA STARTED WITH PEOPLE WHO
WERE. WORKING IN THE AREA
WITHOUT PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES- MY MOTHER IN LAW
WAS A SPECIAL ED TEACHER VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE CHILDREN IN
HER CLASSES THAT WOULD LEAVE
THAT AND HAVE NOWHERE TO GO SO
I THINK WE HAVE TO BALANCE HERE
OF THE INCENTIVE VISITATION FOR
EMPLOYERS AND THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR THOSEEMPLOYERS TO HAVE
KIND OF A GRADUAL- WAY TO HIRE
SOMEONE ON SET MINIMUM WAGE
TREATMENT AND MOVE THEM UP TO
MINIMUM THE NINETY EVEN BEYOND
BECAUSE SO MANY OF THE
INDIVIDUALS DESIGNATED AS
PHYSICALLY OR MENTALLY
CHALLENGED. WHEN THEY'RE GIVEN.
THAT AN INDIVIDUAL TREE RAINING
THE- ARE THRIVE IN THEY DO GROW
BUT I WOULD BE CONCERNED THAT
WE TAKE AWAY THE INCENTIVE. SO
THAT THOSE EMPLOYERS WHO
HAVEN'T BEEN INVOLVED IN ALL
THE THINGS THAT WE HAVE WITH
UNDERSTAND THAT GIVEN THE
CHANCE. ANSEL THE BALANCE IS A
CONCERN TO ME. THE DATE THAT
THIS WILL BE IMPLEMENTED TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE DOESN'T GIVE US
SOME TIME TO GET SOME EVIDENCE
IT MAY BE A WAY TO EDUCATE OUR
EMPLOYERS BUT I THINK FOR TODAY
I'M JUST GOING TO LAY OFF. THE
ON THOSE AND MAYBE WORK WITH
YOUI THINK IT'S A VERY NOBLE
EFFORT THAT YOU HAVE UNDERTAKEN
BUT I DO THINK WE NEED A LITTLE
MORE EVIDENCE TO MAKE SURE
THAT. WE ARE GOING TO SET
OURSELVES BACK INSTEAD OF
MOVING OURSELVES FORWARD. THANK
YOU. SENATOR CORTESE. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT RISE UP IN SUPPORT
OF SB SIX THIRTY NINE- IT WAS
CERTAINLY A BUILD UPON- THE
COMMENTS MADE BY MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SANGER AND CALLING FROM
LOS ANGELES- FROM THE OFFERING
FROM OTHERS WHO HAVE ALREADY
SPOKEN IN FAVOR OF THE BILL
TODAY I JUST WANT TO SIMPLY SAY
THIS. IN COMING TO THE STATE
SENATE- I KNEW THAT. WE WOULD
BE VOTING ON A LOT OF BILLS AND
I SUSPECTED THAT I WOULD BE
PROUD OF A LOT OF MY UNABLE TO
HOPEFULLY ALL OF THEM AND I CAN
SAY AS OF TODAY- THAT THAT'S
TRUE. BUT I DON'T THINK I'LL BE
PROUD. I'M MORE PROUD OF AND I
BUILT IN THE ONE I CAST I HAVE
CAST IN THE WINNER WILL CAST
AGAIN TODAY IN CONCURRENCE ON
THIS BILL BECAUSE THIS IS A
MAJOR CIVIL RIGHTS BILL A BOLD
STEP ON BEHALF OF THE
DISABILITY COMMUNITY. AND IT
IS. DESPITE THE NUMBER OF BILLS
THAT THEY'RE IN THE VOLUME OF
BILLS THAT WE DEAL WITH IT IT'S
STILL RARE TO GET THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CHANGE THE
COURSE OF HISTORY WHEN IT COMES
TO CIVIL RIGHTS WE'VE HAD THE
OPTION TO DO IT MORE THAN ONCE
IN THIS CHAMBERS RECENTLY-
THANKS TO. OTHER COLLEAGUES
AND- I JUST WANTED TO SAY TODAY
LET'S NOT. LET'S NOT. BE SO
BURIED IN THE NUMBER OF BILLS
THAT THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH IN
THE DETAIL. OF THE BILLS THAT
WE'RE DEALING WITH A TO NOT
CELEBRATE RECOGNIZE MOMENT. OF
THAT WE ACTUALLY HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CALIFORNIA TO
RECTIFY A WRONG THAT IS ALMOST
ONE HUNDRED YEARS OLD. THANK
YOU. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SENATOR- TROUBLE THIS
IS ON CONCURRENT. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I WAS NOT PLANNING
ON SPEAKING BUT- I FEEL
COMPELLED TO SHARE. THE WORDS
OF AND CONSTITUENT OF MINE
ACTUALLY TO- BOTH MOTHER AND
DAUGHTER THE DAUGHTER- IS A
SPECIAL NEEDS CHILD AND LEAD
TEACHER THIS IS FOR YOU. WHO
MET WITH ME ON A- Z. MEETING.
AT TWICE ADVOCATING. FOR
HERSELF TO BE ABLE TO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK. AND SHE
PLEADED YOU KNOW SHE PLEADED
HER CASE AND DID A BEAUTIFUL
JOB ADVOCATING FOR HERSELF AND
THOSE IN THE SPECIAL NEEDS
COMMUNITY. AND HER WORDS WERE
HEY GUYS PLEASE. PLEASE MAKE
SURE THAT I HAVE A JOB. PLEASE
MAKE SURE THAT- HE PROTECT MY
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK. YOU SEE
THE THING IS THAT WE HAVE
PEOPLE ON THE DISABILITY-
SPECTRUM TWITTERVERSE SOME CAN
BE EMPLOYED- ON MINIMUM WAGE
BECAUSE THEY'RE THAT FUNCTIONAL.
HOWEVER WE DO HAVE OTHERS WERE
ALSO ON THE DISABILITY SPECTRUM
WHERE THEY CANNOT AND WOULD NOT
HAVE OTHERWISE BE ABLE TO BE
EMPLOYED BECAUSE OF THEIR
DISABILITIES. AND IT IS FOR
THOSE. THAT DON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY TO IN A REGULAR IN.
THAT WE NEED TO PUT AND HAVE
THIS- THESE PARTS. FOR THE
MOTHER WAS VERY INTERESTING
BECAUSE WHEN I MET WITH HER I
ALSO WAS INTERESTED IN MAKING
SURE THAT HER MOM WAS THERE TO
ALSO- ADVOCATE FOR HER DAUGHTER
AND CONFIRM WHAT HER DAUGHTER
WAS STATING. AND HER MOTHER AND
THIS WERE HER WORDS HER MOTHER
STATED THAT MY DAUGHTER CAN'T
COMPETE WITH SOMEONE WHO IS AN
ENTRY LEVEL WAGE WORKER.
BECAUSE SHE DOESN'T HAVE THAT
CAPACITY. BY BRINGING OUR
SPECIAL NEEDS COMMUNITY TO THE
MINIMUM WAGE. REQUIREMENT SHE
HAS TO COMPETE WITH OTHER
PEOPLE WHO ARE ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS- SPEAKERS AND SHE HAS
TO COMPETE WITH ENTRY LEVEL
WAGE WORKERS WHO ARE FULLY
CAPACITY TO WORK FULLY EDIT
PRODUCE MORE THAN MY DAUGHTER
IS ABLE TO DO HOW DOES MY
DAUGHTER COMPETE. WITH THOSE
ABILITIES BECAUSE SHE CAN'T.
WHICH IS WHY SHE NEEDS TO BE
PROTECTED. IF MY DAUGHTER HAD
THE ABILITY TO COMPETE AND HAD
THE ABILITY TO PRODUCE. THE
EQUAL AMOUNT OF WORK AND THE
QUALITY OF WORK OF OTHER
INDIVIDUALS. THEY'RE FULL TO
CAPACITY ADDED IN THERE WOULD
BE NO NEED. FOR THOSE
PROTECTIONS. BUT SHE DOESN'T IT
IS BECAUSE OF THAT THAT WE
CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE TO PROTECT
HER ABILITY TO WORK. SO IT'S
INTERESTING BECAUSE IF I HEAR
THE WORDS FROM MY COLLEAGUES.
YOU KNOW I THINK ABOUT THE
TEACHER. AND I SAY HER NAME
BECAUSE I WANT TO VALIDATE HER.
BECAUSE SHE IS A FERVENT BITER
FOR HER ABILITY AND OPPORTUNITY
TO WORK. AND SHE HERSELF
ACKNOWLEDGES THAT SHE CAN'T
COMPETE WITH FULL CAPACITY TO
PEOPLE. I HAVE AN ORGANIZATION
IN MY IN MY DISTRICT BUT I HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TOUR. HAVE
THE ABILITY TO INTERVIEW PEOPLE
WHO WERE WORKING THERE PEOPLE
DISABILITIES A DIFFERENT
RANGES. AND I ASKED HIM. HOW DO
YOU LIKE WORKING HERE. AND EACH
OF THEM SAID THEY LOVED IT.
THERE WERE THERE WAS A
GENTLEMAN THERE WHO HAD WORKED
SIX YEARS EIGHT YEARS AND I
SAID WOW YOU'RE A LOYAL WORKER
AND HE TURNED TO EVERYBODY AND
HE SAID. I AM A LOYAL WORKERS.
I WANT IT TO WORK. PLEASE THINK
ABOUT THAT THIS IS A WELL
INTENTIONED BILL. BUT HAS
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES FOR
THOSE THAT CANNOT FULLY COMPETE
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE THE
CAPACITY. PHYSICAL MENTAL BUT
THE DESIRE TO WORK. SO ON
BEHALF OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO
WANT TO WORK BUT CANNOT COMPETE
IN PRODUCTIVITY. EITHER
PHYSICALLY OR MENTALLY BUT
DECIDED THE DIGNITY FIFTY ALL
THAT SELF WORTH. AND I HAD THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK ON THEIR
BEHALF THOSE INDIVIDUALS THAT I
MET IN MY DISTRICT. WE HAVE THE
HEART AND DESIRE TO WORK I
PLEAD WITH YOU LET'S NOT VOTE
ON THE BILL THAT JUST MAKES IT
REAL MORE MORMON BUZZY OURSELF
BUT THINK ABOUT THEM WHO ARE
ADVOCATING FOR THEMSELVES. A
TEACHER THIS IS FOR YOU MY
FRIEND AND BECAUSE OF HER I
ASKED RESPECTIVELY A NEW VOTE
ON THIS BILL. HE FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SINGMAN SENATOR ALSO YOU
MAY CONCLUDE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND THANK YOU TO ALL
OF MY COLLEAGUES FOR YOUR HARD
FELT OUR CONCERNS- I TAKE
EVERYTHING THAT YOU SAID VERY
SERIOUSLY- AND IT'S- THOSE THE
VERY SIMILAR SENTIMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN EXPRESSED TO ME. BOTH
ONE ON ONE AS WELL AS IN OUR
COMMITTEES I JUST WANT TO SAY
FIRST THAT THAT IS ALL OF YOU
ARE EXPRESSING THE SAME
CONCERNS THAT I HAVE AND THAT
OTHERS HAVE THAT PUT THIS
TOGETHER THAT PUT THIS BILL
TOGETHER. OF THE DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL
ON DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
THESE ARE ALL ORGANIZATIONS AND
OTHERS WHO AGREE WITH YOU AND
ARE WORKING HARD EVERY SINGLE
DAY SO THAT ANYBODY IN THE IT
D. COMMUNITY WILL FEEL LIKE
THEY HAVE THE FULLEST
OPPORTUNITIES IN THEIR LIVES
JUST LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE. EVEN
THOUGH THEY HAVE DIFFERENT
TALENTS AND DIFFERENT SKILLS
JUST LIKE EVERYBODY IN THIS
ROOM. EVERYBODY IN THIS ROOM.
HAS A DIFFERENT SKILL SET. OF
HAS A DIFFERENT LIFE EXPERIENCE
HAVE A DIFFERENT- UP SOMEONE TO
COLLEGE SOME DIDN'T. BUT WE ALL
WANT TO BE TREATED THE SAME
BECAUSE WE KNOW WE COULD LEARN
TO DO THIS WORK AND IT'S THE
SAME THING FOR OR SISTERS AND
OUR BROTHERS WHETHER THEY'RE
YOUNGER OR OLDER. IN THE IDT
COMMUNITY OF THIS STATE IS
INVESTING ENORMOUS AMOUNTS OF
MONEY WE DOUBLE THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY THAT WE'RE INVESTING IN
THIS BOOK TO HELP EMPLOYERS
TRANSITION. AND FOR THE
SERVICES THAT ARE NEEDED SO
THAT EVERY SINGLE PERSON HAS
THAT HAS THE CONFIDENCE THAT
THEY'VE BEEN GIVEN EVERY
OPPORTUNITY. AND FINALLY I JUST
WANT TO SAY THIS HAS BEEN PART
OF THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT IN
THIS COUNTRY. I MEAN THINK
ABOUT WHERE- ARE DISABLED-
COMMUNITY IS TODAY COMPARED TO
FIFTY YEARS AGO. THEY WERE
TREATED LIKE. THEY WERE
COMPLETELY- DISPOSABLE YOU KNOW
THEY WERE NOT GIVEN ANY
OPPORTUNITIES THEY WERE NOT
GIVEN BECAUSE THEY WERE SO
DIFFERENT. AND THEY ARE HUMAN
BEINGS WHO CAN COMPETE THEY CAN
LEARN THEY DO LEARN. AND THEY
OUGHT TO BE GIVEN THE FULLEST
OPPORTUNITY IN THEIR LIVES TO
FEEL THAT YES THEIR WORK HAS
DIGNITY AND HAS THE SAME
DIGNITY AS EVERY OTHER PERSON
THAT WORKS IN THAT WORKPLACE.
SO I- I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS AND- I DO
APPRECIATE EVERYBODY'S-
SENTIMENTS AND YOUR OPINIONS
AND- EXPRESSIONS THAT YOU GAVE
TODAY THANK YOU. MEDITECH
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I BASE.
BACKER HI FORGES. BRADFORD I
HAVE I EVER HI CORTEZ HE- HI
DOLLY. DOT HI TORONTO HI EGGMAN
GLAZER. GONZALEZ I GROVE.
HERTZBERG I WAS SO HI HER TADO
I JONES NO CAMCORDER I LAYERED
I LLEVA HI THE MOON HI WIRE. I
MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN I A SHOW OF BOTH NO PAN.
HI FORTINO FIVE ROTH HI RUBIO
HI SKINNER FIVE STERNE AMBERG
HI FI CASKEY I WINNER I WILL
KNOW. PLEASE CALL THE OB TO
MEMBERS. ALAN BAYTEX. FORTUS
VALLEY I. AIKMAN GLAZER. GROVE
MELINDA'S STERN PRICE TWENTY
NINE KNOWS THREE THE MEASURE-
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MEMBERS I WANT TO
REMIND YOU THAT WE ARE ON-
CONCURRENCE AND- WHILE I
GENTLEMAN GENTLE REMINDER WHILE
IT'S GREAT TO HEAR ALL THE
PASSION WE'RE REALLY ONLY
TALKING ABOUT WHAT AMENDMENTS
THE SENATE THAT ASSEMBLY MADE
SO ONE- MIND YOU- SENATOR. ALAN
IS PREPARED PLEASE READ. FIVE
FIFTY TWO SENATE BILL SIX SIXTY
FOUR BY SENATOR ALAN AN ACT
RELATING TO HOSPICE SENATOR
ALAN. IMPOSES A TEMPORARY
MORATORIUM ON NEW HOSPICE
LICENSES UNTIL ONE YEAR AFTER
THE COMPLETION OF A STATE
AUDIT. TO IDENTIFY DEFICIENCIES
AND RECOMMEND IMPROVEMENTS TO
THE HOSPICE LICENSURE AND
OVERSIGHT PROCESS IN
CALIFORNIA. SO WHAT'S HAPPENED
SINCE HE WAS IN THE SENATE THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE- THE OTHER WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS ENSURE THAT NEW HOSPICE
LICENSES. WILL BE ALLOWED IN
AREAS WITH DEMONSTRABLE NEED
STEMMING THE INCREASE OF
DEFICIENT HOSPICES WILL
ENSURING ACCESS. FOR THOSE THAT
NEED HOSPICE CARE REMEMBER
THESE BILLS ONLY FOCUS ON THOSE
AREAS THAT HAVE A SURFEIT OF.
HOSPICES SO- IT'S NOT CAN
IMPACT FOLKS IN IN RURAL AREAS
THE BILL'S RESEARCH. A
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN THE
SENATE ASSEMBLY ENJOY WHAT IS
IT ABOUT A COMMITTEE I RESPECT
FRACTION OF A- IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SAYING MAN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA I AT KINS FIVE
BASE. BACKER I PORCHES.
BRADFORD I HAVE A HYPERTENSIVE
HI DOLLY. NO DOG. I TORONTO.
YEAH I EGGMAN GLASER ALRIGHT
CONSOLIDATES I GROW HI HURTS
BERG I WAS SO I HER TADO HI
JONES NO CAN LONGER. LAYERED I
LLEVA I THE MOON HI WIRE HI
MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN I
NELSON. I A SHOW OF BOTH. PAN
HI PERSON TINO I BROUGHT I
RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN AMBERG
ALL RIGHT HI FI CASKEY I
CLEANER I WILL KNOW PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. FAITH
PORCHES. EIGHT MEN. CAN LONGER.
I MELINDA'S A TRUE OF BOTH.
STERN. FIVE THIRTY ONE KNOWS
THREE THE MEASURE THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS MOVING ONTO FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIFTY THREE SENATOR
AMBER. HE IS PREPARED PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL SIX SIXTY
FIVE BY SENATOR UMBERG AN ACT
RELATING TO EMPLOYMENT. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES AS P. SIX SIX FIVE
IS THE BILL PROVIDES PRIVATE
EMPLOYERS THE SAME RIGHT THAT
THE GOVERNMENT HAS IN TERMS OF
PROVIDING A VETERAN'S
PREFERENCE THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS I HAD A SIGNIFICANT
BURDEN TO EMPLOYERS WHO WISH TO
ENGAGE BUT I STILL ARE NOT ABLE.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SAYING
NINE MEMBERS THIS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ANY
OBJECTION TO USING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING
NONE ICE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO.
THIS IS THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
PARK OCCURREDIN MOVING ONTO
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIFTY FOUR
SENATOR RUBIO IS PREPARED.
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL SIX
EIGHTY TWO BY SENATOR RUBIO AN
ACT RELATING RELATING TO PUBLIC
HEALTH SENATOR RUBIO THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT SENATE COLLEAGUES I
RISE TO PRESENT SENATE BILL SIX
EIGHTY TWO WHICH IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE. THIS BILL WILL
HELP REDUCE RACIAL DISPARITIES
IN CHILDREN'S AND HEALTH
OUTCOMES ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS TO
ARTICLE AUTHORS AND ESTABLISHES
THIS BILL AT THE END RACIAL
INEQUALITY IN CHILDREN'S.
HEALTH IN CALIFORNIA AND THEY
SHOULD BE IN RICH CALIFORNIANS
SHOULD HAVE AN ACCENT ADVISORY
GROUP THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
STRONG BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
NO AND NO VOTES ARE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIFLE
THANK YOU. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THESE
ITEMS DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SAYING THEN PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. WITH ALAN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS I FACE I BECKER I
PORCHES HI BRADFORD I KERR BY
OTHER HYPERTENSIVE I'VE DALLY.
DODD I TORONTO I A GUNMAN LASER
I CONSOLIDATE I GROW. HERTZBERG
I WAS SO I HER TADO I JONES.
CAN LONGER I LAYERED. I PLAYED
BY. HI THE MOON I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN I
NELSON. A CHARTER OAK. I CAN HI
PERSON TINA I BROUGHT I REVIEW
SITES SKINNER I STERN I'M BURKE
HI HI MY CASKEY I WINNER. HI
WELL I PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. DALLY ADMIN GROVE.
JONES MELINDA'S NIELSEN STERN.
FIVE THIRTY THREE NO ZERO THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIFTY FIVE
CENTERING A MOAN IS PREPARED
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL SEVEN
OH TWO BY SENATOR LIMO ON AN
ACT RELATING TO STATE
GOVERNMENT SENT US AN EARLY
MORNING THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT S. B.
SEVEN OH TWO SIX TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIA'S LEADERSHIP
REFLECTS ITS READER POPULATION
THE COLLECTION OF GUBERNATORIAL
APPOINTEE DEMOGRAPHIC. DATA IS
CRITICAL TO ACHIEVE AND
MAINTAIN NOT JUST GENDER AND
ETHNIC DIVERSITY BUT GEOGRAPHIC
EQUITY ON BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS AS WELL SOMETHING
WE ALL CARE ABOUT ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ADDED CO AUTHORS
MODIFY THE DATES OF THE WORKING
GROUP IS TO MEET AND WHEN THE
REPORT IS DUE TO AGGREGATE
DEMOGRAPHIC INFORMATION ABOUT
INDIVIDUALS APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN ITEM. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
BILL. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SEEING NONE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI AT
KINS HI EIGHT FIVE BECKER. I
PORCHES BRADFORD I HAVE A
HYPERTENSIVE I DALLY. DOT I
TORONTO I EGGMAN GLAZER. I
CONSOLIDATE I GROSS. HERTZBERG
I WAS SO HI HER TADO I JONES. I
CAN LONGER I LAYERED I LAVER I
THE MOON I REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S.
MAN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN. A
TROUBLE. PAM I FORTUNE TINO HI
RON. I REVERE HI SKINNER. I
STERN I'M BERG I WORK OWSKI I
WINNER I WILL. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. FOR JUST. DALLY
EGGMAN. GROVE HE MELINDA'S.
NIELSEN A SHORT BOAT. STERN
WELL HI. FIVE THIRTY TWO NO
ZERO THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIFTY SEVEN
SENATOR BATES. SHE IS PREPARED
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL EIGHT
SEVEN EIGHTEEN BY SENATOR BATES
AN ACT RELATING TO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE SENATOR BATES THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU MADAM
RESIDENTIAL MEMBERS I'M ASKING
FOR CONCURRENCE IN ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ON SB SEVEN
EIGHTEEN. THE BILL DRAWS A
NARROW EXEMPTION IN CURRENT LAW
TO ALLOW THE CONTINUATION OF
THE BIO CON CALIFORNIA HEALTH
BENEFIT TRUST IT INCLUDES
IMPORTANT EMPLOYEE PROTECTIONS
THAT ENSURE THE HIGHEST QUALITY
HEALTH BENEFITS. AND REQUIRES
THAT THE HEALTH PLAN BE FULLY
INSURED AND REGULATED BY THE
STATE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ADDRESS CHATTERING ISSUES AND
MAKE CLARIFYING AND TECHNICAL
CHANGES THE BILL HAS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT. THROUGHOUT
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SINGMAN
MEMBERS THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING
NINE FIVE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. PUTTING ON THAT
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIFTY EIGHT
SENATOR BRADFORD HE IS PREPARED
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL SEVEN
NINETY SIX BY SENATOR BRADFORD
AN ACT RELATING TO STATE PARKS
DECLARING THE URGENCY THERE OF
STATEMENTS MEDIALLY. UNDER
BRADFORD THE FLOOR'S YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRO TIP
MOUNTAINS PRESIDENT. ON
AMENDMENTS AND SEVEN NINE SIX
SIMPLY ADDRESS MANY OF THE
WRONG- ISSUES EVER CREATED
THROUGH THE WRONGFUL TAKING OF
THE BRUCE'S PROPERTY- THE FIRST
FAMILY ALMOST A HUNDRED YEARS
AGO. INCLUDES RESOLVING TAX
IMPLICATIONS OF RETURNING THE
SLANT TO THE RIGHTFUL OWNERS
AND THAT'S THE BRUCE FAMILY
THIS ALSO INCLUDES CLARIFYING
THE LEGISLATURE'S CLEAR INTENT
TO RECOGNIZE OR RESPOND TO THE
RACES ACTS. BY THE CITY OF
MANHATTAN BEACH IN NINETEEN
TWENTY AS WELL AS SOME OF THE
PRACTICES TODAY THEY STILL HAVE
YET TO APOLOGIZE TO THIS FAMILY.
A MANHATTAN BEACH USED THE LAW
TO COMMIT A CRIME. TIME AND
TIME AGAIN DIFFERENT GOVERNMENT
BODIES HAVE USED THEIR POWER TO
DENY WEALTH AND OPPORTUNITIES.
FROM TO MANY COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. THIS BILL REPRESENTS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THIS GOVERNMENT
TO FINALLY DO THE RIGHT THING.
TO UNDO A WRONG COMMITTED BY
THE CITY OF MANHATTAN BEACH.
AND AIDED BY THE STATE AND THE
COUNTY BY TAKING POSSESSION OF
THIS PROPERTY. S. B. SEVEN NINE
SIX REPRESENTS ECONOMIC. AND
HISTORIC JUSTICE AND IS A MODEL
WHAT REPARATIONS CAN TRULY LOOK
LIKE I RESPECT WITH ITS RIVAL.
IS THERE ANY- DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SINGMAN
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR YOU FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SITTING
NINE FIVE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO.
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIFTY NINE CENTER
ROCK IS PREPARED MADAM
SECRETARY THREE. SENATE BILL
EIGHT OH ONE BY SENATOR
ARCHULETA AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALING ARTS. CENTER ON. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THIS IS THE
SUNSET BILL FOR THE BOARD OF
BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES AND BOARD
OF PSYCHOLOGY AND IT TOO IS
BACKFOR CONCURRENCE THE BILL
EXTENDS THE OPERATIONS OF THESE
PROGRAMS BY FOUR YEARS TO
JANUARY ONE TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
SIX. MEMBERS TAKEN IN THE
ASSEMBLY OF LANGUAGE TO REFLECT
THE NUMBER OF PATHWAYS TO
LICENSURE AS A PSYCHOLOGIST
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL METHOD FOR
FOREIGN PSYCHOLOGY DEGREES TO
BE EVALUATED ENHANCE THE
BOARD'S LICENSING COMMITTEE
AUTHORITY TO CONSIDER SUPERVISE
PROFESSIONAL EXPERIENCE TOWARD
LICENSURE. AND CREATE A PROCESS
FOR A LICENSE TO BE REINSTATED
IF AN INDIVIDUAL SURRENDERS IT
FOR NON DISCIPLINARY REASONS
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THINKCENTRE ROTH MEMBERS IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING THEM
MEMBERS THIS IS EIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING
ANONYMOUS ROLL CALL SEEING AND
HEARING NONE ALL EYES THIRTY
EIGHT MINUTES ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS ARE MOVING BACK
TO FILE ITEM TEN SENATOR
PALMEIRO. SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWENTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR KERR BIO AN ACT
RELATING TO COMMUNICATIONS
CENTER PROVIDER THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. SENATE BILL TWENTY
EIGHT RETURNS FROM THE ASSEMBLY
WITH AMENDMENTS THAT FOCUS THE
BELL ON THE DAY OF BECAUSE THAT
STATUTE THIS IS THE BROADBAND
BILL. I THINK YOU AND I ASK YOU
FOR YOUR VOTE IN CONCURRENCE
WITH THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU SENATOR CABALLERO
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
AND OR DEBATE. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE MEMBERS THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION.
SEEING AND HEARING THEN FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT MILLER ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS ARE
MOVING BACK TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. SENATOR SKINNER
WHEN YOU ARE READY. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT. UNDER MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS PLEASE MOVE THE
FOLLOWING TO BE AN ACTIVE FILE.
815-581-6280. 1-658-166-8160.
EIGHT EIGHTY ONE SIXTY NINE
EIGHTY ONE SEVENTY. ADD AB ONE
SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SO ORDERED. SENATOR
RATIO ALSO UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS IF YOU COULD MOVE
AB FIVE HUNDRED INTO THE ACTIVE
INACTIVE FILE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. SO IT IS SO ORDERED.
ALL ALL MEMBERS ARE GONNA GET
READY TO. LEFT THE CALLS.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO GET WE'RE
GOING TO LIFT THE CALLS ON THE
BILLS THAT HAVE BEEN PLACED ON
FILE. THE FIRST ONE IS FILE
NUMBER SEVENTY THREE AB THREE
SIXTY TWO PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN. ATKINS HI BACKER. I
EGGMAN MCGUIRE. HI NEWMAN I
WANT A STERN AMBERG I. PLEASE
CALL THE OB TO MEMBERS. ALAN I
BAGMAN STERN EYES TWENTY NINE
NINE WHO KNOWS THE MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING ON TO FIND ITEM
NUMBER FORTY SIX. PLEASE CALL
THE OB TO MEMBERS. BACKER I.
DOT I. YEAH HI. THEY SAY
THEY'RE ALSO I ADMIN HER TADO.
CAN LONGER I LIMONEIRA I
NIELSEN. STERN WINNER HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
GOD EGGMAN FURTADO I NIELSEN NO
STERN. FIVE TWENTY SEVEN NO TEN
THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
ITEM FILE ITEM NUMBER FORTY
SEVEN S. B. SIX OH SEVEN PLEASE
CALL THE OB TO MEMBERS. BATES.
BACKER. I FORTUS. DALLY.
TORONTO I EDMUND GLAZER I
GROWTH. NIELSEN STERN WEINER I.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
FAITH FOR JUST. BALLY EGGMAN
GROVE NIELSEN I STERN YEAH.
FIVE THIRTY FOUR NO ZERO THE-
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
INCURRED IN. WE HAD TO FILE AN
ITEM NUMBER FORTY EIGHT S. B.
SIX OH NINE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. EGGMAN HERZBERG
I NIELSEN I STERN WEINER. I.
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
ITEM NUMBER FORTY NINE. S. B.
SIX NINETEEN. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ADMIN STERN
WINNER HI. FIVE THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. IF THERE IS
NO OTHER BUSINESS CENTER
ACTIONS THE DESK IS CLEAR.
MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO
MUCH- COLLEAGUES THANK YOU FOR
A VERY BUSY AND PRODUCTIVE DAY
AS A REMINDER OF MEMBERS I WANT
TO LIVE LET YOU KNOW WE WILL BE
WORKING INTO FRIDAY EVENING
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE. BILLS THAT
ARE- TOM SPECIFIC AS TO WHEN WE
CAN TAKE THEM UP AND SO WE WILL
BE WORKING INTO THE EVENING AND
WITH THAT OUT WITH THE REST OF
THIS EVENING LEFT. LET ME SAY
THAT THE NEXT FLOOR SESSION IS
SCHEDULED FOR TOMORROW FRIDAY
SEPTEMBER TENTH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AT TEN THIRTY AM TEN THIRTY
AM. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
THE SENATE WILL BE ADJOURNED WE
RE RECONVENE TOMORROW AT TEN
THIRTY AM.